Scholastic audio presents...
Wings of Fire.
Book 15.
The Flames of Hope. by 2 E.T. Sutherland.
Read by Shannon McManus.
The Lost Continent Prophecy.
Turn your eyes, your wings, your fire, to
the land across the sea, where dragons
are poisoned, and dragons are dying, and
no one can ever be free.
A secret lurks inside their eggs.
A secret hides within their book.
A secret buried far below may save those
brave enough to look.
Open your hearts, your minds, your wings
to the dragons who flee from the hive
face a great evil with talons united, or
none of the tribes will survive.
Prologue.
The problem with belonging to a village
that worshipped a big, ominous hole in
the ground is that holes in the ground
tended to be very cryptic about their
mystical instructions.
Messages from the deep didn't arrive all
that often, luckily, and they arrived
even less often once the leaders decided
to abandon the Guardian of the Abyss.
After all, if no one ever visited him, and
there were no more ceremonies, how could
he?
Or the abyss, if you believed that part
of it?
Demand anything.
Instead, pretend it's not there, forbid
any mention of it, ignore the whispers
and the shadows.
And maybe everyone would eventually
forget about the big ominous hole that
had ruled the village for centuries.
That was the leader's plan.
In principle, Raven agreed with the
leaders.
She agreed that the abyss was creepy, and
that it was weird to worship a giant hole
in the ground, and that it wasn't great
to let that hole take a person to keep
for itself every 10 years.
But it's tradition was not a good enough
reason to go along with it.
Even after 1000s of years, maybe
especially after 1000s of years.
If it had really been that long, that
meant 100s of humans had been swallowed
up by the Abyss.
The great and wonderful ancestor who had
agreed to this in the 1st place was long
long gone, and maybe he hadn't never done
the math on how much sacrifice would be
involved.
That still felt a little blasphemous.
Their ancestor had saved them all.
He was perfect, and could do no wrong.
But maybe he could have made a better
deal with the abyss, was all Raven was
suggesting.
So yes, she agreed with the leaders.
It was time to stop feeding the abyss.
It was definitely time to stop giving it
new guardians.
Vol could be the last one ever.
But abandoning the abyss, and the whole
practice of abyss worship was one thing.
Abandoning Vol himself was too hard and
too sad.
Once upon a time, Vol had been a normal
person.
He'd been mole, silly big brother, funny
charming, really good at climbing sheer
rock faces.
It wasn't his fault that a green tentacle
had reached out of the abyss, and dragged
him in during the Guardian ceremony 4
years ago.
No one could ever predict who the Abyss
would choose.
If Raven were a sinister chasm looking
for someone's brain to steal, she would
have picked quartz, who played ball
kicking games all day long, and was
extremely boring.
Court could have become guardian and sat
beside the abyss all day, staring into
space.
And it wouldn't be all that different
from how he was before.
Raven could have gone on with her life
just fine if everyone decided to give up
on courts.
She thought.
Probably.
Even that idea made her feel a little
sick inside.
But Vol?
If there were a tiny part of him that was
still himself in there, she didn't want
him to be alone.
She didn't want him to think she'd left
him, like everyone else.
Mole was the only one still allowed to
visit him to bring him food.
The leaders couldn't condemn Bull to
starving to death.
But no one else was supposed to go near
him.
At first, a few had tried to talk him
into leaving the abyss, and coming back
to the village, and that had gone very
poorly.
The leaders didn't want anyone else to
risk getting thrown into the chasm.
So when Raven visited Vole, she had to do
it in secret.
Which meant she had absolutely no one to
tell when the guardian gave her his
terrifying instructions.
Find the dragon.
Bring it here.
Or everyone you know will die.
So, all right, 1st question, what
dragon?
Any dragon?
Was Raven supposed to somehow find a
specific particular dragon somewhere?
Deduce that that was the one the Abyss
wanted, and then...
What?
Tie it up and haul it all the way down to
the abyss?
Did the Abyss think she had superpowers?
How was a human supposed to make a dragon
go anywhere?
And again, what dragon?
Saying, the dragon sounded nastily
specific.
The abyss wasn't like, bring me a dragon
as in, anyone will do.
But if it did want a particular dragon, it
needed to give her something to work
with.
A color for starters would be great.
How many wings?
Big or small?
Alive or dead?
Ha, ha, ha.
As if Raven could kill a dragon, whether
the Abyss wanted her to or not.
In any case, the Abyss had not deigned to
answer any of these questions.
Voll had continued to stare intently over
the edge into darkness, ignoring her.
So after days of useless thinking and a
few unsuccessful experiments, Raven had
done the only possible thing.
She'd dragged Mole into her problem.
She found him alone at one of the cave
lakes, knocked him over, and sat on him
before he could run away.
Don't be mad, she started.
God, no.
Mole gripped his face with his hands.
Raven!
How about don't do things that make
people mad?
I didn't do this, she protested.
I swear.
I mean.
She squinted up at the ceiling.
That is, I did a thing that might make
you mad, but the actual problem I have to
tell you about is not my fault.
Seriously.
Can you tell me one without telling me
the other?
he asked.
She thought for a minute.
Mole lay still on the stone floor
underneath her.
His fishing net dropped nearby, his arms
propped behind his head.
He was a little judgmental, and too much
of a rule follower.
But he was smart, and still usually the
most agreeable person Raven knew.
Hypothetically, she said.
If you really needed to get a dragon from
one place to another, how would you do
it?
He stared into her eyes.
Finally, he said, What?
Imagine there's a dragon, she said.
And you need it to go somewhere pretty
specific, and you would prefer to not get
eaten on the way?
What would you do?
Specifically.
Raven, he said.
When you say somewhere pretty specific, do
you mean the abyss?
Who said anything about the abyss?
She flailed.
I didn't.
Why did you?
Nobody said.
Hey, wait.
What happened to the rules?
You said abyss, not me.
It wasn't me this time.
The rules.
Nobody mentions the abyss.
Nobody goes near the Abyss.
Everyone pretends the Abyss does not
exist anymore.
Everyone acts like they hear absolutely 0
whispers and feel 0 weirdness coming from
the creepy, big, dark hole.
Mole rubbed his face again and gently
pushed her off him.
He sat up and buried his hands in his
hair.
If you're talking about what I think
you're talking about, Vol said the same
thing to me.
He did?
Raven poked him in the arm.
Why didn't you tell me?
Why would I?
We're not supposed to talk about the
abyss, remember?
I'm not even allowed to mention Vol.
How could I tell anyone he's given me a
weird abyss message?
You definitely shouldn't somehow know
about it already.
He sighed.
Raven.
How did you?
He trailed off.
I visit him sometimes, she mumbled.
She pulled one of the knives out of her
boots and stabbed it into a crack in the
floor.
I don't get too close.
I just... sit nearby and talk to him.
When she looked up, she was startled by
Mole's expression.
It wasn't mad at all.
He looked like he was about to burst into
tears.
Don't be weird about it.
She cried.
I feel bad for him.
I know he's not really there anymore, but
I still kind of keep waiting to see if he
is.
I can't help it.
I'm an idiot.
I know that.
You are.
But so am I, Mole admitted.
So he gave you the same message.
Find a dragon, bring it to the abyss?
Raven sighed as he nodded.
How can we possibly do that, Mole?
Do you think we have to?
Could we ignore him?
My message ended on a pretty clear, or
everyone you know will die, note, she
said, which also wasn't very specific, but
I can imagine how a possessed guardian
and an abyss full of green tentacles
might go about killing everyone.
On the other hand, I don't want to make
the dragons mad either.
Mole said.
I'm guessing we need one from that big
group that settled in the caves last
month.
But if we somehow did steal one of their
dragons, wouldn't that make the rest all
furious and vengeful?
I don't know about you.
But I don't love the idea of living in a
cave system with 100s of angry dragons.
That sounds even worse than an angry
abyss.
So, we have to be clever about it.
Raven suggested.
I was thinking we skip over the problem
of which dragon it wants, and see whether
we can get any dragon there.
My 1st thought was to let one of them see
me and hope it's hungry enough to chase
me to the abyss.
Oh, wow, Mole said.
Terrible, terrible plan.
I hated very much.
More terrible than you realize, she
said.
Only like 2 or 3 of the dragons in that
group are hunters.
I can't get any of the colorful 4 wing
ones to chase me.
You've tried?
he said, looking at her aghast.
Of course I've tried, she said.
I've tried lots of things.
I wouldn't bother you without trying
everything I could think of first.
The colorful dragons are not interested
in me at all.
I can dance under their noses, and the
worst they'll do is sniff me.
I could get the big green Dobe one to
chase me, but that's risky.
He's really determined.
I don't want him to accidentally find the
village.
Right, he said.
We should definitely avoid that.
What have you tried so far?
she asked.
Um, he said.
Worrying?
I've tried every variety of worrying.
That's my best friend, she said, punching
his shoulder affectionately.
Doing the hard stuff so I don't have to.
Ha, ha.
What have you done besides volunteers
dragon snack?
She made a face.
I looked for treasure.
Dragons like shiny things right?
That's what the storybooks say.
I thought maybe if I made like a trail of
diamonds, some dragon might follow it all
the way to the abyss.
That's...
A lot of diamonds.
I know.
There's no way I can surreptitiously
gather that much treasure.
I tried prying one teeny tiny diamond out
of the wall in the Salvation Tunnel, and
mom caught me, and I got in so much
trouble.
You have no idea.
The week I didn't see you, he gasped, and
she shrugged.
He knew her parents.
Solitary confinement was their usual
punishment for everything.
So, what else can we do?
Any ideas?
She asked.
There's that flower juice the doctors use
to make people sleep during surgeries.
What if I somehow got a lot of that and
gave it to a dragon?
Maybe you could trick a dragon into
eating something so it fell asleep, Mole
said pensively.
But then you'd have to figure out how to
move a giant sleeping dragon, Raven.
Yes, all right.
That's where the plan fell apart in my
head too, she said.
Unless...
Wheelbarrows?
Pulleys?
Hypnotize the whole village and have them
carry it for me?
Okay, fine.
Too hard.
What about some kind of message for the
dragons?
he suggested.
Like a drawing, a map to the abyss.
With a picture of a big pile of treasure
in the abyss.
Raven laughed despite herself.
We might end up luring the dumbest dragon
in the history of the world, she said.
La, la, la.
What's this lying here on the floor?
A map to treasure.
This doesn't seem suspicious at all.
Off I go, dum dum, along this trail to
get my pile of diamonds.
This is completely normal.
Your imaginary dragon sounds way too
human.
Mole protested.
I'd be more worried that dragons would
know what a map is, let alone how to
follow one.
You don't watch them enough, Raven
pointed out.
They are definitely smart enough to read
maps, and too smart to fall for a fake
one.
Next, you'll be telling me they have
feelings like us too, he said.
As though there are dragons who care
about their brothers or something.
He glanced sideways at her.
Or dragons who would do anything for
their best friends.
Her hand stilled on her knife.
Wait.
Dragons with feelings?
If any dragons had feelings.
It was probably those rainbow colored
butterfly looking ones.
Maybe they did care about one another
like humans did, more or less.
And if so, maybe she could use that.
Maybe this was how they could trick a
dragon.
By finding its most human weakness.
Raven, Mole said, as she tucked her knife
back into her boot.
She met his eyes and smiled ruefully at
him.
He was wearing his rules are rules, and
what am I going to do with you, face?
Which usually meant a lecture was
coming?
But then he said, I know I should be mad
you broke the rules to see Vol, but...
Raven.
I'm so glad I finally have someone I can
talk to about this.
She felt little cracks spreading across
her heart.
Mole had been all alone with this secret
just like she had.
He'd thought the fate of the village in
everyone's lives rested entirely on his
own thin shoulders.
Poor mole.
When he already had so much to deal with
between being Voles, sole caretaker, and
the only remaining son and heir of the
leaders.
She put one arm around him, and he rested
his head against hers.
We'll figure this out together, she
promised.
You don't have to do it alone.
I have a new idea.
Uh-oh, he said, and they both laughed.
He reached across her and took her free
hand in both of his.
Raven.
Why do you think the abyss is asking for
a dragon now?
After all this time.
I don't know, she said.
That seems like the dragon's problem, not
mine.
It's one of the things I've been worrying
about, he said.
Like, if the abyss is angry.
Is it a good idea to give it a dragon?
What is it going to do to the dragon?
And if dragons have feelings like
humans?
Raven thought.
Well, I wouldn't want to be given to a
sinister abyss.
Is this any better than the guardian
ceremony?
Mole said quietly.
Do we have a choice?
Raven asked.
Won't the whole village be in danger if
we don't do what Volt says?
Mole frowned.
And Raven instinctively reached to rub
his temple the way his brother used to.
Listen.
Whatever's going on with the abyss, and
the dragons?
Maybe this will fix it, she said.
Maybe this will make the abyss focus on
the dragons, and leave us alone.
Maybe.
Her breath caught in her throat for a
moment.
Maybe.
If we give it a dragon, it will give us
back vole.
The way he used to be.
Mole sat up with a gasp and stared at
her.
Do you think so?
I don't know.
Don't get your hopes up.
But we can ask, can't we?
He nodded.
His eyes drifting toward the lake.
Right.
And it's only one dragon.
He let out a long breath.
I hope we're doing the right thing.
Part one.
The land across the sea.
Chapter one.
Luna wanted to change the world.
She knew what it should be like.
She knew it could be more just and more
beautiful and more safe and more kind.
A world where dragons loved whoever they
wanted to love, where they created art
and took care of one another, and were
happy instead of hurtful.
Surely everyone wanted that world.
So why couldn't it exist already?
Luna knew exactly what she wanted to
change and why.
She just wasn't quite sure how yet.
She wished the world was more like a
weaving, where she could tear out the
bits that were knotted wrong, or colors
twisted in the wrong places, then reweave
it all again.
Better and mend it and perfect.
She knew how to fix a messed up
tapestry.
She had no idea where to start fixing a
broken world.
The problem was, there were so many
things wrong, and they all needed
fixing.
And the other problem was how many
dragons didn't seem to see that.
A lot of dragons thought everything was
fine.
Even some of Luna's very favorite, most
loved dragons didn't seem to care about
all the wrong bad things.
This had been baffling her all her life.
She had started noticing the problems
with her world.
From the 1st moment her mothers had
walked her through cicada hive.
And even more clearly, during her
earliest days of school at Silkworm
Hall.
How could anyone else miss them?
For instance, it was wrong that the hive
wings had cut down all the trees, and it
was very, very, very wrong, that the hive
wings had wiped out all the leaf wings.
It was wrong that a silk wing couldn't
choose her own life partner, her job, or
where she lived.
It was awful that Luna's father had been
taken away before she even hatched.
And it was unfair that Queen Wasp got to
decide everything that happened to the
Silk Wings, and they couldn't say
anything about it.
A lot of dragons might argue that those
things were fine, because Queen Wasp was
the dragon in charge, and she said so.
And also something, something war, and
something, something danger.
So that was how the world had to be.
But even if you accepted all of that.
Which Luna didn't.
It was still obviously wrong, all wrong
that hive wings could treat silk wings
like tiny bugs under their talons.
Silk wings were dragons too, just like
them.
Silk Wings didn't deserve to be stepped
on, sneered at, poked without permission
punished for no reason, or ignored.
It made no sense.
Why would a different wing shape, or a
slightly different scale color, or
antennae.
Make one dragon superior and another
dragon worth nothing.
But how did you fix that?
How could one dragon?
Even a dragon who cared very much.
Make a whole tribe change how they
thought and behaved.
How could she get into the heads of all
those sneering hive wings and shake their
brains around until they stopped being
awful?
She wanted them to see the better world
she could picture.
She wanted to stuff it into their
eyeballs until every hive wing went, yes
that world is way better than this one.
Let's be like that instead.
Luna wished she had magic.
Magic would be so useful for problems
like this.
Even if it was a magic like clear sights
seeing the future.
Well, she'd find a way to make it
useful.
But proper magic, like spells and
enchantments, and brain changers, like in
the old dragon fairy tales.
That's what she really wanted.
Something to go, poof.
Now you are all fair and kind, and
incapable of cruelty or injustice.
That's what she needed.
But apparently, it didn't exist.
Or if it had existed, once, in the
distant kingdoms.
Now it didn't work anymore.
She traced her claw through the sand with
a sigh.
The sun was rising behind her, casting
golden ripples across the ocean like
trails of flame silk.
On the other side of that ocean was
Pantala, her home.
Her mother's, her tribe, blue, and sword
tail.
And they were all in trouble, and it was
all a mess, and she didn't know how to
begin untangling it.
Before her metamorphosis.
Luna had dreamed of flying.
She dreamed of scattering the clouds with
her new pale green wings, and she
imagined sunshine pouring through her
scales the higher she flew.
She planned to weave tapestries with
secret chrysalis messages in them.
She imagined herself and swordtail at
clandestine chrysalis meetings, whispering
with other silk wings about how to change
things together.
But as it turned out, She couldn't simply
be Luna.
An ordinary silk wing, quietly changing
the world alongside other silk wings.
Now she had to be Luna, the flame silk
Luna, who spun fire from her wrists.
A flame silk.
Rarest of all silk wings, chosen to save
everyone somehow.
To Queen Wasp.
A flame silk was a valuable tool to be
locked up and controlled.
To the chrysalis, and the leaf wings.
Flame silk was power.
A weapon they could use to fight back.
Luna didn't particularly like thinking of
herself as a tool or a weapon.
She had planned on changing the world in
a silk wing way.
Not in a setting your enemies on fire
way.
Setting your enemies on fire sounded
fun.
But it was actually extremely scary.
Once you had a real dragon in front of
you, who would really burn if you wanted
them to.
Not to mention?
The 1st time she tried.
Her flame silk got caught in a hurricane
that then blew her to a whole other
continent.
So that wasn't the most auspicious start
for the great and glorious flame silk
savior, Luna.
But she had to use this power now that
she had it, didn't she?
She'd been chosen by the universe, to be
a dragon who could throw flaming lassos.
She couldn't exactly be like, oh, no
thank you.
Someone else go set Queen Wasp Bonfire
instead of me, please.
This was fine.
She just had to rethink her plans to
change the world.
Now that she was a little bit scarier
than she used to be, now that she had a
destiny, and maybe had to save the world
all by herself with fire.
I'm not all alone, though, even though I
feel that way, without blue and sore
tail.
Today, she was returning to Pantala with
9 other dragons, a human, and a mission.
One of those dragons went galloping past
charging into the water and plunging his
head below the surface.
His human stopped near the edge of the
waves, crossed her arms inside.
Did you see one?
The rain wing called from the air
swooping overhead.
No, of course he didn't.
Ren called back.
Skye's head shot out of the water again
and he shook himself vigorously, then
stood with his snout tilted, as though he
was waiting for water to drain out of his
ears.
False alarm, not a dolphin, he called to
the rain wing.
Just to confuse jellyfish.
Pineapple.
Luna reminded herself.
Pineapple the rain wing.
She was great at remembering faces
because they were kind of like tapestries
on dragon snouts, but usually she had
trouble with names.
This time, though, she was determined to
memorize all the names of her traveling
companions.
It would help if pineapple could pick one
color and stay that color.
Because her trick of picturing him in a
tapestry holding a pineapple didn't work
if he kept looking completely different
all the time.
Not that I'm complaining.
Having all these dragons to figure out, is
much better than sitting on this beach by
myself, staring wistfully at an ocean
that's entirely too big.
Are you still here?
A voice demanded behind her.
Luna smiled over her shoulder at Jerboa.
We are leaving as soon as the ice wing
arrives.
She said reassuringly.
Soon this beach will be so quiet, and
you'll miss us so much.
That sounds great.
Treboa grumbled.
Clomping up to sit beside Luna and
scattering sand everywhere.
I haven't talked to this many dragons in
literally centuries.
And now I remember why.
Truboa always moved in an odd way, which
at 1st Luna had thought was how all 2
winged dragons walked.
But now that she'd met a bunch more.
She was pretty sure there was something
different about Jaboa, as though she was
secretly in pain, or her bones didn't fit
together quite right.
I, um, I made you something.
Luna said tentatively.
She handed your boa the leaf wrapped
packet beside her.
The sand wing furrowed her brow at it, as
though every present she'd ever been
given before had bitten her.
It's just a little thing.
It's terrible, Luna said in a rush.
I don't have a loom here.
So I couldn't weave you the tapestry I
was imagining in my head.
And then I thought, maybe I can create a
new kind of art with my fire.
So, I've been trying to carve pictures
into wood with bits of flame silk, and
it's harder than you'd think.
So this is the best I was able to do so
far.
But it is still pretty awful, and you
don't have to keep it if you don't want
to.
I just wanted to give you something to
say thank you.
Thank you for what?
Treboa asked.
For helping me get better, and for
putting up with all of us in your space.
You didn't have to come find me when I
crashed here, Luna said.
I know you could have stayed in your hut
and kept out of all of this.
Treboa didn't say very much about herself
or her past.
But she had clearly lived alone for a
long time.
And Luna got the sense that the sandwing
both really wanted to connect with
someone, and also got very overwhelmed
very quickly by normal dragon
interactions.
That was a guess.
Jerboa was not in the business of
discussing her feelings, or making facial
expressions.
She mostly looked either bored or mildly
annoyed.
But Luna was familiar with the no
feelings here, face.
Her own was more of a, see, I'm smiling.
I'm not causing any problems.
Everything is totally fine.
Face.
But it was still in the same genre of
face.
It's no problem.
The Sandwing said brusquely.
I figured I might as well do something
useful.
Treboa gingerly peeled the leaves off the
gift.
Revealing the soft white curve of
driftwood underneath.
Luna had burned the shape of 2 little
dragons into it.
Each sitting on their own continent on
either side of the ocean.
One had 4 wings, and the other had two.
They were looking toward each other and
waving.
Well, they were supposed to be.
The one with 4 wings looked like she was
about to fall over backward, and the
other one's face had come out all wrong
so she looked like she was sneezing.
Never mind, Luna said, trying to grab it
out of Jerboa's talons.
It's an awful, weird looking art fail.
Sorry.
Stop that, Treboa said. batting her
away.
This is my weird looking art fail.
Get your claws off it.
When the world is all fixed, I'll make
you a tapestry, Luna said, It'll be much
better than this, I promise.
Turboa squinted at the dark clouds that
were huddled like suspicious high wing
guards on the far horizon.
When the world is all fixed, she echoed.
Hmm.
Don't get your hopes up.
Every time you think you've fixed
something, something else always goes
wrong.
That's the spirit.
Kembley. the other Sandwing said, popping
up behind her.
Hey, I have an idea.
Let's stop fixing things, and then maybe
nothing else will go wrong.
Treboa frowned at him.
Uh-oh, Kibley said to Luna.
I think I'm about to be called a
preposterous whippersnapper.
Tell your continent they can keep this
one?
Turboa said, flicking her tail at
Kibley.
Kibli grinnedadder, then turned to Luna
again.
Tsunami wants to show you something
important, if you have a minute.
He pointed out the beach to where the
blue sea wing was sitting with cricket.
Oh, sure, thanks, Luna said.
Her scales always gave an odd little
shiver when she saw cricket from a
distance.
Even though her brain knew this hive wing
was safe, and had helped them.
Her body still sent her an instinctive
heap, run, hide, set it on fire.
Reaction to the yellow and black dragon's
face.
There was a difference between knowing
she should trust this dragon and feeling
like she could.
She knew Blue trusted her.
But she'd only seen Cricket and Blue
together for a moment before Luna was
blown out to sea.
And to be honest, Blue wasn't the most
reliable truster of dragons.
He would probably trust a giant hissing
scorpion wielding knives, if it said
something sympathetic.
Also, there was a small part of Luna, that
was really angry, that blue and sore tail
had fallen into wasps' mind control
clutches, but cricket hadn't.
After all that.
Why should this blissfully lucky hive
wing get to escape yet again?
But the dragons Luna loved didn't.
It wasn't fair.
She couldn't say that out loud.
But it really wasn't.
Luna, Tsunami said.
Beckoning her closer, she approached.
I'm going to share another Pyrean secret
with you, because I think it will help
and I think it's important, and you know
what?
It's my thing.
Well, the Jade Mountain Academy's thing
and I'm the headmaster, basically.
And so I don't need any queen's
permission is what I've decided.
So there.
Um, Luna said.
Okay.
Tsunami held out a star shaped sapphire
that fit neatly in her cupped front
talons.
This is a dream visitor, she said.
One of those animus touched magic objects
you heard about?
Luna's heart sped up.
Magic.
What does it do?
She blurted.
Please say it'll save my tribe.
She glanced sideways at cricket.
Who was unusually silent.
Normally, the hive wing would have been
the 1st one asking questions.
But she was staring down at her claws
half buried in the sand.
She looked as though someone had said all
her favorite books on fire.
I've already let cricket use it.
Tsunami explained.
Why?
Luna thought mutinously.
Why her 1st and not me?
How is that fair?
When she's one of the bad guys.
No, no, don't let anyone see you think
that.
I'm smiling.
I'm not causing problems.
Everything is fine.
Tsunami went on.
A dream visitor lets you step into the
dreams of a sleeping dragon, no matter
where they are, so long as it's someone
you've seen before.
I figured it's probably still nighttime
in Pentala.
And maybe there's someone there you want
to check on?
She carefully placed the Sapphire and
Luna's talons.
Luna's mind was spinning.
She could actually see one of them
again.
Right now?
It wasn't tribe saving magic, but it was
still amazing.
Who should she pick?
Soretail or blue?
Blue or sore tail?
And then she realized.
Did you visit Blue?
She asked Cricket.
The hive wing nodded.
I tried, she said quietly.
He couldn't really hear me, though.
He was having a nightmare.
About what?
Luna asked sharply.
That was her little brother.
She should be the one worrying about his
nightmares.
A room full of silk wings, Cricket said.
Plants growing out of the walls
strangling them.
It can't be real.
Can it?
She appealed to tsunami.
I mean, was I seeing something he
actually saw?
Tsunami spread her wings.
I don't know.
We have dreams about real things and not
real things and both mixed together all
the time.
Cricket sighed, took off her glasses and
rubbed her eyes.
I'll visit Sortail, Luna said.
What do I have to do?
Hold it up to your forehead. tsunami
said.
Close your eyes and concentrate on him.
If it doesn't work, he might not be
asleep right now.
Or if he's having a nightmare, like blue
you might see him, but he might not hear
you.
But if he's having a normal dream, you
might be able to communicate with him.
Luna's claws were trembling as she
pressed the dream visitor to her
forehead.
It wasn't magic that could make all hive
wings disappear, which would have been
nice.
But the chance to talk to Soortail, after
all this time, was a magic she hadn't
dared hope for.
They'd never gone this long without
talking to each other.
Not since the day they 1st met 5 years
ago.
Swordtail.
She whispered, closing her eyes.
She pictured his unexpectedly sweet
face.
Other dragons saw his mischief, his loud
jokes, and his reckless arguments with
guards or teachers.
They might notice that he was strong and
brave too.
But hardly anyone seemed to see the true
sore tail, under all his noisy
silliness.
It was like the red leaf.
The secret chrysalis symbol hidden in the
metamorphosis tapestries.
You had to look for it.
You had to know to care about it.
Sortell understood about all the things
Luna saw that were wrong.
Even if he hadn't noticed them before.
He understood immediately when she
pointed them out.
He was the absolute best at going from
vaguely interested, to completely
outraged in the span of a conversation.
Sortell looked back into her eyes, and
his whole face lit up.
Three moons.
She was really somewhere.
Somewhere that wasn't a sunrise lit beach
in the distant kingdoms.
Somewhere dark, although a single bright
light shone over Soretail's head.
He was standing up on a pedestal, his
wings spread behind him, his front talons
outstretched.
Sore tail, she cried.
He didn't respond.
His claws twitched like he wanted to
reach for her, but he didn't move.
Oh, she knew where they were now.
This was misbehavior's way.
The place troublemakers like Swordtail
were sent to be punished whenever they
disobeyed hive wings.
She walked up to the base of the pedestal
and touched the letters carved in the
stone.
They looked like real words until she
tried to read them, and then they went
wobbly and slipped away from her brain.
Like in a dream.
Soretail, she said.
This isn't real.
You're not on misbehavior's way.
This isn't even what it really looks
like.
She turned to look behind her.
There were no other pedestals.
No other prisoners.
The stone paths rolled away into darkness
and the darkness hummed, like it was full
of bees.
The light over Swordtail's head was wrong
too.
It was too bright, and she couldn't see a
fixture or a ceiling, just the light
blazing down on him.
Sortail, get down from there right now
she said.
I don't know why you're dreaming about
this.
This is where I'm supposed to be, he said
suddenly, sounding resigned and
reasonable, which was not a very sore
tail way to sound.
I'm always here.
Remember?
You come and say with me?
You should weave a hammock and live here
because I'll probably be here more and
more as we get older.
Luna felt like she was about to cry.
The 3 times he'd been punished like this
before.
She'd found a way to go sit with him for
as long as she could.
On misbehavior's way.
The prisoners were temporarily paralyzed
with a hive wing nerve toxin, so they
couldn't move or speak.
But they could still hear and see.
So she'd read to him or sing, or tell him
about the day he'd missed.
You're not going to end up here again
Luna said.
I'm coming to set you free, swordtail.
No, no.
He said.
I'm coming to rescue you.
I'm helpful.
That's what.
Wait.
Didn't I already?
He trailed off, looking confused.
You did, she said.
Thortell, this is a dream, but I'm real.
You can get off that pedestal.
Get off it right now and come hug me.
He thought for a moment.
I like that idea much better than
standing here.
He broke his brow.
Concentrating.
Moving is tricky though.
Not sure if everyone knows that.
Hey, who's the boss of me?
Are these my muscles or what?
Don't I tell them what to do?
Look at them, arguing back, not listening
to me.
Hey, do what I say, stupid talents.
He glared at his claws, but they stayed
frozen in place.
All right, hang on.
I'll fix this.
I am the boss of me.
Nobody else tells my talents what to do.
Let's all not look at me for a minute
while I yell at myself.
Luna, talk about you instead.
What do you mean, you're real?
I'm in the distant kingdoms, using magic
to talk to you.
Luna spread her wings and flew up to
him.
This pedestal was also higher than the
real ones on misbehavior's way, but it
was only a dream, so she did not feel
guilty about shoving him off.
You're, he yelped, flapping around to
break his fall.
Hey, my wings can move.
Check me out.
Guess those ants for brains guards didn't
stab me the right way this time.
Swordtail.
Luna took one of his talons and tugged
him down to the ground.
He settled his wings behind him, and
looked down at their intertwined claws.
A thread of silvery gray silk spun out of
his wrist and wrapped around hers.
Now she was crying.
She wondered if she was crying in the
real world too. sitting on that beach
with tsunami.
She let a thread of harmless flame silk
the kind that shimmered gold, but didn't
burn, spin out and wrap around his talons
twining through his own silk.
Listen, she said.
I'm in the distant kingdoms, but I'm
coming for you.
I'm coming with sundew and cricket, and
some other dragons, and we're going to
save you, okay?
Do you know where you are?
I mean, really in real life?
Not in this dream?
Cicada hive, he said, blinking.
Guarding silk wings until wasp has enough
of her plant to infect them.
He tried to laugh.
Very boring job, actually.
It's a bit like guarding a flower shop to
make sure the orchids don't make a run
for it.
I can see why the hive wing guards were
always so excited when I gave them
something to chase.
WASP sent you back to our own hive.
Luna asked.
So the silk wings you're guarding.
Yeah.
Everyone we know, he said with an awkward
shrug.
Your moms are here.
They're all right.
What about Blue?
She asked.
Here too, he said, in a quieter voice.
But not really, you know?
It's like he's gone into a blue cocoon
somewhere inside himself.
I kind of wish I could do that too.
I mean, I want to fight something, but I
can't.
I can't do anything with these stupid
traitor talons.
He looked down at their intertwined claws
and took a deep breath.
She, we, captured Io.
So she's here too.
She can't even look at me.
It's not you.
Luna said fiercely.
Whatever Queen Wasp is making you do, it's
not you, sore tail.
Don't forget that.
You're still in there, and we're going to
get you away from her.
I promise.
I wish I were really talking to you, he
said.
These dreams always end with you being
dragged away in chains made of
lightning.
You are really talking to me, you lummox
Luna said, shaking his talons.
She wrapped her wings around him and
pulled him closer.
With a sigh, he rested his head on her
shoulder.
Soretail.
There's a dragon on this continent who's
like clear sight.
She told us this prophecy about Pentala
and a buried secret.
So we're coming to look for an abyss that
we think is connected to the mind
control.
We're going to fly into the abyss, find a
big obnoxious plant with a grudge, and
then Sundu's going to kill it a lot until
it's really, really dead.
And then the mind control won't work
anymore, and you'll be free.
All right?
Isn't that a great plan?
Aye.
Feel like I missed something, Swordtail
said.
Me too.
It's very confusing, Luna agreed.
But it's going to work.
We're leaving the distant kingdoms
today.
So pay attention.
And in a few days, you'll be like, oh wow
they did it.
The mind control doesn't work anymore.
Let's go stab Queen Wasp in the face, and
then find Luna, and hug her forever.
He laughed.
Shaking his head to clear the tears from
his eyes.
You do sound like real Luna.
Where will I find you after you save us?
The mosaic garden, Luna said. off the top
of her head.
That hill, where you finally confessed
your desperate love for me and said you
couldn't live without me?
Um, I believe my exact words were, hey
Luna, want to be my girlfriend?
He said with a grin.
Yes, you're very lucky I can translate
sword tail. she retorted.
And let's see.
I believe your romantic response was
Soretail, did you sit on this box of
honey drops?
Why are they all squashed?
And then I was like, Luna, pay attention
to me.
I am trying to make us an official
couple.
And you were like, yes, all right.
Obviously, that's fine.
Now go get us some more honey drops and
don't sit on them this time.
You do have a weird habit of squashing
any candy you get your talons on, she
pointed out, or your butt on, more
accurately.
I don't sit on candy on purpose, he
objected.
I certainly hope not, she said.
That would be weird, sore tail.
She nudged his snout with hers.
But it's all right.
I love you anyway.
I love you too.
He squeezed her talons.
I think I'm about to wake up.
Oh no, she said, starting to panic.
Already?
Wait.
I don't have a choice, he said.
She wants us for something.
Luna, I'm all right, but...
If you could come quickly, it would... it
would be better.
I will.
I promise.
Tell Blue we'll be there soon, she said.
More silk was spinning out of her
wrapping around his wrists, trying to
keep him with her.
Just hold on, sore tail.
We're coming.
We'll.
But he was gone.
Luna was back on the beach.
Early morning light brushing the clouds
pink overhead.
Tears were rolling down her snout, and
her talons held a cold sapphire, instead
of sore tail's warm claws.
Chapter 2.
Part of Luna wanted to dive to the bottom
of the ocean, and bury herself so deep
that she would fall asleep, and never
have to feel anything ever again.
And part of Luna, wanted to throw the
whole abyss mission out the window, and
fly straight to Cicada Hive, and set
everything on fire until she found sword
tail.
But by day 3 of their trip, all of Luna
was focused on not screaming at her
companions to fly faster.
She did not think it had taken her this
long to cross the ocean between the
continents.
Granted, she had been unconscious, and
dragged along by a hurricane, but they
could try a little harder.
She tried to focus on the plan in her
head.
Find Penthalin humans, follow them to the
abyss.
Do... something.
All right, most likely watch sundew do
something, and then the important part.
All the hive wings giving up and turning
on Queen Wasp.
Blue rescued from his nightmares, and
Luna getting to hug sore tail for real
and freedom for all the silk wings.
There were some wobbly bits in the plan.
Luna was trying not to think about the
wobbly bits.
Think about the happy ending instead.
Think about how we're going to change
everything.
Think about the tapestries you'll be able
to weave when this is all over.
Luna did a twist roll in the air to catch
a quick view of everyone. 10 dragons
altogether, flying through the bright
blue sky.
Dragons from 10 different tribes.
Not too long ago, she'd thought there
were only 2 living tribes in the whole
world.
This is the kind of art I want to make
she thought.
A tapestry of all of us flying together.
A tapestry that says, look how much
bigger the world is than you thought it
was.
Look at how different we are, but we're
all still dragons.
Look at how dragons we don't even know.
We'll fly across an ocean to help save
us.
Don't you want to be like these dragons?
Don't you want to reach for different
claws?
Fly alongside different wings?
Don't you want to do something brave and
kind?
Because someone has to.
I'll call it talent united from the
prophecy.
After all of this is over.
If we survive.
Black wings fluttered in the corner of
her eye, and Luna sighed.
The good news?
She was bringing a mini clear side back
to Pentala with her.
The bad news?
Moon didn't have quite the personality
Luna would have expected from a powerful
seer.
Luna had imagined more trances, more
mystical declarations, and plenty of
dramatic swooping about.
If she were a seer.
Luna would get out of every boring
conversation by suddenly closing her eyes
and announcing a need for silence.
The future is speaking, and so forth.
But on the plus side.
Moon looked all cool and eerie, especially
from a distance.
And especially when she wasn't talking.
She looked a lot like Clearsight did in
the paintings, so that was a good start.
Luna liked to imagine a scene where they
all flew into a hive, pointed at Moon, and
yelled, behold, the 2nd coming of clear
sight.
She says, actually, Queen Wasp is a jerk
and silk wings are great, and should have
their own queen, so there.
And then all the hive wings would cry, oh
no, we have been so wretched and wrong.
Tell us how to be better dragons, Luna.
Unfortunately.
Moon was too nervous and twitchy to be a
convincing prophet.
The night wing would have to manage a
much more imposing and inscutable face.
If she wanted any hive wings to fall over
at her talons, and renounce their
horrible ways.
In fact, after spending a few days with
them, Luna had discovered that all the
dragons who'd been chosen for the heroic
quest of fulfilling Moon's prophecy were
significantly less terrifying than she
would have preferred.
Apart from Zundu, who was impeccably
terrifying at all times.
Luna tilted her head up and sideways to
study them each as they flew, one by
one.
Links, the ice wing, gleaming silver and
blue, like diamonds slicing through the
air, too smiley.
Kibli, the sandwing, playing tag with a
seagull to make moon laugh.
Too hilarious, nowhere near series
enough.
Moon, the intimidating Nightwing
herself.
Too shy, lots of stammering, kind of
spacy at weird moments.
Cricket. too easily distracted, not a
fighter.
Plus, also a hive wing, and that still
felt weird.
She kept trying to fly next to Luna as
though she wanted to talk about something
but Luna could usually find a reason to
fly with pineapple, or sky, or lynx
instead.
Bullfrog.
The mud wing was big and strong looking
but he never said anything, not even when
Kibley was off hunting, and there was a
chance for other dragons to get a word in
edgewise.
If he had a personality or any sort of
passion for anything, it was buried very
deep, like a fossil.
And Luna's favorite new Pyrea friend
Pineapple the Rain Wing, was literally
falling asleep while flying.
Again.
Pineapple, Luna called, flying up behind
him and nudging his wing.
He was iridescent gold and rose and cyan
all over today, which was almost too
pretty to look at straight on.
Very up, he said.
Startling away and tipping sideways.
Definitely awake.
It's the middle of the day, Luna pointed
out.
And we got so much sleep last night.
How can you be tired?
He shrugged, not at all embarrassed.
This is when rain wings usually have our
suntime naps, and there's so much sun out
here.
The confusing part is how all of you are
still awake.
He yawned, and then grinned at Luna, as
she stifled a contagious yawn in
response.
There's an island coming up, Kibley
said.
He pulled out the map and consulted it
tipping it to a line with the ocean
below.
We could rest for a bit.
Arr, arr, arr.
Luna didn't want to rest anymore.
She'd spent forever resting on Jaboa's
beach, waiting for Moon and Kibble to
make a plan, waiting for the sea wings to
swim to Pentala and back, waiting for the
fleeing dragons from Pentala to get
organized and figure out their next
step.
She couldn't wait 12nd longer.
Swortail needed her now.
She wanted to get to Blue and Sortell and
save them at once.
A short rest, maybe, tsunami said, soaring
up beside Kibley.
I want to make it to this island by
nightfall.
She pointed to another island.
Three farther along the chain they were
following, and Kibley nodded.
Luna exhaled with relief.
Tsunami was a pretty fierce and noisy sea
wing, bigger than sundew, and maybe even
scarier sometimes.
She'd probably be useful against the hive
wings.
Luna thought.
But the last dragon in their group was
her direct opposite, Sky.
The affable, pale orange sky wing with a
human pet.
Luna wished he had his tiny human's
personality.
Ren could probably take down a hive all
by herself if she had fire and talons.
Sky was more likely to bump into a hive
and then apologized to its walls.
He reminded her a little bit of her
brother.
Blue.
Although Blue spent most of his time
trying to imagine how other dragons
felt.
And Skye seemed mostly interested in how
snails felt, or turtles, or dolphins.
He was really sweet.
They were all very lovely and funny and
kind, and if Luna were organizing a
dinner party, they'd be the perfect
dragons to invite.
But this wasn't a dinner party.
It was an epic life or death battle, with
an evil queen and her evil tribe, and
also a vitally important rescue mission.
With her own entire tribe's future at
stake.
How could 10 sweet dragons?
Or, all right, 8 sweet dragons, into
reasonably ferocious dragons, defeat the
scariest queen and the scariest tribe in
the whole world.
Blue and Swordtail were counting on her.
And this was the army she'd brought to
save them?
Luna fidgeted with her talons and glanced
back over her shoulder.
The distant kingdoms were so far behind
them now, that there was nothing to see
but sky and ocean.
Maybe they should go back and ask for
real armies again, though.
Armies, with lots of soldiers and weapons
that would be useful.
A magic army would be even better.
Luna imagined that tapestry for a
moment.
The whole top 3rd covered in wings
dragons swarming down surrounded by
lightning bolts, and enchanted swords
with Queen Wasp, alone at the bottom
making an uh-oh, very doomed face.
Landing in Pantala with a magical army
sounded like a much smarter idea than
flapping in with a talon full of cuddly
dragons and a human.
Don't worry, Moon said from her left.
Some of us are more useful than we look.
Luna pivoted to Squint Atter.
Moon said things like that a lot.
Things that sounded like she was talking
back to the thoughts in Luna's head.
Why would she suddenly swoop up and say
something like that now, out of nowhere.
Not me, Moon said quickly.
I meant like Kibli, just for one
example.
She looked a little less nervous for a
2nd as her eyes tracked the sand wings
soaring down to the water, scooping up a
floating coconut, and tossing it to sky
who fumbled it through his talons and
dropped it back in the ocean.
He's actually kind of great at saving the
world.
Kibli is her sore tail, Luna realized.
She'd sort of guessed, from the way they
looked at each other. and the way they
slept side by side every night.
Why are you telling me this?
Luna asked Moon.
Did you have a vision of what's going to
happen to us in Pentala?
She wished she could have a vision of the
future.
Imagine knowing the whole plan, how
everything should turn out and how to get
there.
The whole tapestry of the future, spread
out in her mind.
That would be amazing.
Sorry.
Moon stammered.
She pointed back the way Luna had been
looking.
I just, you looked like you were wishing
you'd brought someone else.
Or like maybe you want to go back?
She took a deep breath.
Sorry, never mind.
No, no, I'm totally fine.
Not worried at all.
Luna blurted, before moon could swoop
away.
Still smiling, not causing problems.
It's only that the closer we get, the
more I remember how terrifying wasp is
and the more I think, you know, wouldn't
it be great if we had something big and
stabby, or magic, or both?
Big stabby magic for stabbing hive wings
with?
I know.
Moon said sympathetically.
But remember, we're not going to confront
WASP.
Our mission is to find out what's in the
abyss that Queen Snowfall saw with her
vision from the ring.
And hopefully, it'll be a way to save
your friends without needing any magic or
um, stabbing.
The other dragons.
Especially Kibile and Moon, were
convinced that this abyss would solve all
their problems.
But frankly, Luna had some concerns about
what one might find at the bottom of a
dark, ominous abyss.
The word abyss kind of sounded like it
came with guaranteed death and
creepiness.
She couldn't imagine anything abyss
related that wouldn't require magic or
stabbing to defeat.
You haven't had any more specific
visions?
She asked Moon, hopefully.
Clues about what's down there, hints
about what we're supposed to do.
Maybe the tiniest flash of me dancing on
Wasp's grave?
Nothing helpful, Moon said, with a rueful
face.
But then, she always looks like that.
Luna thought grumpily.
Moon has resting rueful face, like a
permanent, oh, I'm so sorry, I can't help
you even with all my amazing magic.
I guess it only works on my problems
expression.
She glanced over at Moon again. and
caught the little black dragon flinching
as though something had jabbed her in the
snout.
We do have a little magic.
Lynx interjected from above and to her
right.
She pointed to the silver bracelets on
Sundew's wrists.
When should we start using those?
The wristbands gave Sundu the power to
turn any or all of them invisible
including herself.
It was a small gift of magic from the ice
wing queen, who was a flipping, terrifying
dragon if you asked Luna.
Snowfall could probably have defeated the
hive wings just by staring coldly at
them.
We're still at least 2 days from the
coast of Pentala, by my estimate.
Tsunami said.
She glanced at Kibli's map again.
Cricket, do you agree?
Me?
The bespectacled hive wing said
startled.
Oh, me, yes.
Um, sorry.
I was a little distracted when we left
Pentala, and we were coming from farther
north, but we don't want to aim for the
poison jungle this time, right?
We're thinking Dragonfly Bay?
Also, we're moving faster now than we
were with all the little and old leaf
wings.
But yes, right, 2 days, that sounds about
right to me too.
She added quickly, a tsunami frowned at
her.
The tiny human yelled something from
Sky's back, but the wind whipped her itty
bitty voice away.
Ren says maybe we should start using them
now then.
Sky offered cheerfully.
She says, better safe than super dead.
What?
Oh, sorry.
He cleared his throat and said in a much
deeper growlier voice, Danger could be
lurking around every cloud.
We could be murdered by zombie bug
dragons at any moment.
Then he spoiled the effect by bursting
into helpless giggles.
Pineapple grinned Adam.
Most of the Pyrean dragons seemed sort of
flummixed by Skye.
The least sky wingish sky wing ever
tsunami had called him.
But pineapple found sky delightful, which
made Luna like the rain wing even more.
She's not wrong, Sundu pointed out.
I like the idea of using the magic now
Luna said.
It won't run out, will it?
We can use it as much as we want.
That's right.
Link said, nodding.
Maybe we could start using it after our
next rest stop, then?
I'm not sure how much use it will be
though, Kibley said seriously.
I mean, even if we're all invisible.
I'm pretty sure bullfrogs nonstop chatter
is going to give us away.
The silent mudwing swung his head
ponderously around to give Kibli a
puzzled look.
Eh?
he said.
Yeah, that's what I'm talking about
Kibley said.
That nonstop yippyapping bullfrog.
They're going to hear you coming from
miles away.
Sky snorted a laugh that nearly knocked
Ren off his back.
Bullfrog considered Kibley for a moment.
Don't think so, he said after a while.
I know it's going to be tough, Kibley
said, but I'm afraid you'll have to be
way quieter.
Bullfrog turned his furrowed brow toward
the others.
I'm confused.
Kibley is being ridiculous.
Moon explained.
He's trying to find someone to argue with
him, since winter's not here to do it.
Do I talk too much?
Bullfrog asked pineapple. who was flying
beside him.
Do. I talk too much.
I think that was the most words I've ever
heard you say.
Pineapple admitted.
I'm sorry, Bullfrog, Kibley said, nudging
his wing.
I'm just kidding.
You're the stealthiest dragon we have.
I think you're awesome.
Really?
Bullfrog said, looking confused all over
again.
Kibble was not very much like blue in
most ways, but sometimes Luna saw little
things in the sand wing that reminded her
of her brother.
They both wanted to be liked so badly.
They both wanted everyone they meant to
feel warm and comfortable and happy
around them.
Kibli did it with jokes and banter, while
Blue let other dragons push him around in
order to keep the peace.
That was something she loved about Blue
that also drove her up a wall.
Luna did not care 2 honey drops, whether
any hive wings liked her.
So what?
They were mostly all terrible, the worst
rude and superior and entitled and
sneering.
Why would she need any of them to think
ah, yes, that Luna, what a lovely, quiet
silk wing.
No, no, no.
She would much rather they thought, uh-oh
here comes Luna.
She's probably going to set us all on
fire again.
Especially, if that meant she never had
to actually set anyone on fire.
But blue was always friendly and polite
to everyone.
No matter how awful they were.
That's why she'd never told him about the
chrysalis.
She had a feeling he'd be thoroughly
confused by a secret group of silk wings
who gathered to talk about fighting back
against Queen Wasp.
Fighting back wasn't in Blue's
vocabulary.
At least not until Luna turned out to be
a flame silk.
He'd been different when she came out of
her cocoon.
She hadn't been with him long enough to
really see how different, but from the
stories Cricket and Sundew told her, Blue
had been through a lot while Luna was in
her metamorphosis sleep.
Kibley was a little bit like Swordtail
too.
Sortail was funny like Kibley.
He also talked a lot when he was nervous
like Kibley did.
Sortail didn't need to be liked by
everybody, though.
He was happy to be loved by Luna and Blue
and his sister Io.
Everybody else could stuff termites up
their noses if they didn't like him for
all he cared.
Luna wished she could talk to him again.
She wanted to tell him about the dragons
she was traveling with.
What would he think of pineapple, or lynx
or sky?
Would he be able to trust cricket more
than she did?
Would he find Moon a little unsettling?
Or would he feel sorry for her, and how
shy she was?
She was pretty sure he would like Kibli.
She could imagine them annoying hive wing
guards together.
Luna had borrowed the dream visitor from
tsunami whenever they'd stopped, but she
hadn't been able to find Swordtail asleep
again.
She wondered what he was doing, or
worse.
What wasp was making him do.
She couldn't bear to think of Wasp inside
Soretail's head, or manipulating Blue's
talons.
She had to stop thinking about it, or she
might have to dive into the ocean and
scream for days.
And the whales probably wouldn't like
that.
There's the island, Pineapple said.
Flicking his tail toward the small blur
of a white sand curve rising out of the
ocean ahead of them.
Thank the moons.
I'm so ready to lie down.
He grinned at Luna, and swooped ahead of
everyone.
Tsunami checked the position of the sun
in the sky.
Well, past midday.
Luna knew from her internal clock, sighed
and sped up to fly after him, shouting.
Not for long, pineapple.
Don't you dare fall asleep.
I don't.
Think.
Bullfrog said slowly.
That I talk too much.
You don't, Moon reassured him.
Kibley is the one who talks too much, Link
said helpfully.
You know, I feel like I've heard that
somewhere before.
Kibley said, tapping his chin.
Race you to the beach bullfrog.
He took off without waiting for an answer
which was especially funny when Bullfrog
just blinked after him in more
confusion.
Maybe tomorrow?
Cricket said out of the blue, as though
she'd been working out a question in her
head, and missed the entire last half of
the conversation.
Starting tomorrow morning, we go into
invisible stealth mode.
What do you guys think?
That makes sense, doesn't it?
I agree, Moon said.
Sure.
I'll feel safer once we're invisible, Link
said, nodding.
Although, if we're all invisible.
Pineapple really can't fall asleep while
we're flying.
Luna joked, or he'll drop into the ocean
and we'll never find him.
Up ahead of them.
A dragon's scream sliced through the
sky.
Chapter 3.
Luna froze in midair, her wings beating
backward for a panicked moment.
She turned instinctively toward sundew
and saw links do the same.
But Moon cried, Kibli, and shot away
toward the island, leaving the rest of
them behind.
What was that?
Sky yelped.
I think it was pineapple, Lang said
frantically, as Sundew yelled.
Moon, wait.
The little black dragon was too far ahead
already.
And now Luna could hear roaring coming
from the distant beach.
More than one dragon roaring.
More than two.
More than 4 A dozen unfamiliar voices.
Too many dragons, roaring in fury and
rage and pain.
It's wasp, she said.
Her throat closing over the words.
She found us.
She found us already.
Everyone stay close.
Sandu shouted.
She vaulted to a higher wind current
spread her wings, and held up the magic
wristbands.
What if we get separated while we're
invisible?
Cricket yelped.
But Sundew was already touching the
diamonds together.
There was no time to answer, no time to
make a plan.
What were they supposed to do if they
lost the others?
Go on to the next island or go back?
There was only one map.
If something happened to sundo, or you
got separated from the group, would you
be an invisible dragon alone forever?
Luna reached out in panic and found
Lynx's talent doing the same.
They clasped claws just as they both
disappeared.
It was so eerie.
Feeling a cold talon in hers, when she
couldn't see the dragon on the other end
it was beyond eerie, to see empty air
where her own wings and tail and claws
should be.
Sundew, Sky and Wren, Bullfrog and
Cricket, were all gone too, leaving only
blue sky around them.
Luna twisted in the air to look for moon
tugging links along with her, but the
night wing was nowhere to be seen.
I think I got Moon before she was too far
away.
Sundu's voice said breathlessly.
Luna felt a thick wing bump hers and a
mumbled, oops, that she thought might be
bullfrog.
What about tsunami and Kibli and
Pineapple?
Cricket's voice asked.
Did you turn them invisible too?
I couldn't.
The magic can only cover dragons in my
line of sight.
Sundu answered.
Her voice sounded like it was coming from
the smoke thin wisps of clouds above
them.
So let's go save them, Luna said
urgently.
She wasn't sure if it was her own wings
or lynxes moving them toward the island
and the roaring and the screaming, but
everyone else seemed to be behind them
hovering, discussing, waiting, losing
time.
Come on, it must be hive wings
attacking.
We have to do something.
How?
Do what?
Yelled the panicked thoughts flying
around her brain.
Right, Sundu cried.
Yes, let's fight them.
Finally.
Won't they hear us?
Even if they can't see us?
Cricket asked.
They can't hear us.
Lynx answered Cricket, her voice
startlingly close to Luna in the empty
air.
Queen Snowfall said only dragons inside
the invisibility bubble can hear one
another.
But should we make a plan before we go
charging in?
Cricket said anxiously.
There's no time for a plan, Luna cried.
We have to fly over there and and
invisibly smack all the hive wings in the
head.
Yes, Sundu agreed.
Push them into the ocean, drop some
sharks on them.
Say pineapple and Kibli and tsunami, Luna
added.
And feed all the hive wings to fire
ants.
Sundoo yelled.
Wait, wait, no.
Cricket said.
There was a whoosh of wind past Luna's
scales, and then Sundu's voice called
You'd better all be right behind me.
But they're not.
Everyone see that palm tree on the south
end of the island.
Lang shouted. her voice drowning out
crickets.
Regroup there if we get separated.
Luna thought she could hear the human
yippering something at sky, but then she
and Links were flying fast.
Wing beats in sync, and she lost track of
where the others were.
The only one she was sure of was links.
Her strange ridged claws holding tight.
Don't let go, Luna thought.
Don't leave me alone up here.
The island was about as wide as cicada
hive, and maybe twice as long, curved
like a dragon tail, with a pair of huge
boulders off the shore on the north end.
The beach facing them rose quickly into a
tangle of trees and cliff, blocking the
view of the other side of the island.
Lynx gasped softly, tightening her grip
on Luna as they flew close enough to see
the dragons battling on the beach.
Hive wings swarmed across the white sand
teeth and stingers flashing.
There had to be at least 20 of them, giant
and deadly as a horde of murder hornets.
Luna's mind took an instinctive mental
picture of the scene.
Even though she knew she would never
never, want to weave a tapestry this
frightening. 20 hive wings.
What are they doing all the way out
here?
Queen Wasp must have sent them to follow
the escaping leaf wings, she said aloud.
That means she could be inside all those
dragons right now.
Cricket's voice said hopelessly from
above her.
Tsunami's blue scales were easy to spot
in the crowd, where the fighting was
thickest.
She roared and spun, slashing at the hive
wings around her, and smacking others in
the head with her powerful tail.
Close to her, Kibli was surrounded by 5
hive wings.
His venomous tail was curved up, stabbing
at his attackers as they darted in toward
him.
Luna saw him pull out one of the blow
guns the rain wings had given them.
But before he could aim it, a hive wing
lunged at him and knocked it into the
sand.
They grappled, with their front claws
locked, their teeth snapping at the air
between them, both tails fainting jabs at
the other.
But someone had managed to use the
blowguns.
One hive wing was lying on the beach, eyes
closed, with a dart in his neck, another
one, near tsunami, suddenly clapped one
tail into his cheek, staggered back, and
collapsed.
Luna squeezed Lynx's claws.
I think pineapple did that, she cried.
She'd never seen a rain wings camouflage
power in action before.
It was much more impressive than she'd
expected.
She couldn't see pineapple anywhere, but
a moment later, a 3rd hive wing stumbled
and went down.
Do we attack?
Links called.
Sundo?
Orders?
First Priority is keeping Sky and Ren
safe.
Sundu answered.
Skye, where are you?
There was no response.
Luna looked around, her heart racing, even
though she knew she wouldn't see
anything.
Sky, Sundew shouted again.
Come on, you twig brain?
Where are you?
Skye, if you can hear us, go hide.
Link shouted.
Luna could hear Sundu muttering curses
but no sound from Sky or Wren.
Had they lost them so quickly?
What happens to the rest of the plan if
we lose our little human?
How will we find the abyss without her to
help us talk to the Pentalon humans?
Sandu, can't you make tsunami and Kibli
invisible now?
Cricket asked.
I'd have to make us visible first, Sundu
said.
And I don't want the hive wings to know
we're here.
We can't risk them seeing Skye and Ren, or
catching the rest of us and leaving those
2 alone.
Below them.
A sudden burst of flame flared along the
tail of the hive wing in Kibley's claws.
The red and black dragon shrieked and
flung herself away from him, rolling and
rolling in the sand to put it out.
Where did that come from?
Moon?
Luna wondered.
Or bullfrog.
Nightwings and Mudwings could both
breathe fire.
Maybe they were already down there
fighting invisibly.
I have fire too.
She flexed her free claws, feeling the
heat of the flame soak in her wrists.
Should I use it?
This is my chance, right?
To use the weapon I was given?
But.
Can I really set other dragons on fire?
During one of those long days of waiting
on the beach in the distant kingdoms
while Luna was practicing making
different kinds of flame silk.
Jerboa had touched one of the fiery
threads, not realizing that it would burn
her.
She'd pretended that it didn't hurt very
much, but Luna had felt guilty about it
for days.
She still felt haunted by the angry red
mark on Jerboa's claw.
I could throw ropes of fire at the hive
wings.
But what if I hit one of the invisible
dragons?
What if I hurt one of my friends?
The other hive wings around Kibley were
turning, shouting, searching the dunes
for the source of the flames.
Kibble bolted away from them, and threw
himself at an orange speckled hive wing
who was circling around behind tsunami.
They slammed into a pile of seaweed and
skidded sideways, clawing and roaring at
each other.
Bullfrog, get that dragon off Kibley
Sundoo yelled.
Lynx, get out your blowgun and hit as
many as you can.
I'll help tsunami.
What about me?
Luna asked.
But her question was lost in a rush of
wing beats.
Links squeezed her talon and let go.
Luna felt momentarily dizzy, untethered
in the sky.
I think Sundew still doesn't quite
believe that silk wings and hive wings
can be helpful.
Cricket said quietly, from somewhere
nearby.
I can be, though, Luna protested, holding
up her glowing wrists before she
remembered that no one could see them.
I could set a high wing on fire.
I could. she added, although Cricket
hadn't disagreed with her.
Could you hurt another dragon like that?
Blue's voice whispered in her head.
But don't kill them, Cricket said, her
voice rising with alarm.
Remember, they're being controlled.
This isn't their choice.
That was a pretty hard thought to keep in
mind as 2 hive wings slashed at tsunami's
wings, one of them drawing blood, and
another one jabbed his spear into
Kibble's tail.
Luna swooped lower, trying to find a good
angle, trying to work up the courage to
throw her silk.
She was terrified of hitting tsunami, or
Kibli too.
They moved so fast as they fought.
She also remembered the last time she'd
tried to use her flame silk to fight hive
wings.
It had spiraled out of her control, caught
a storm, and ended up carrying her all
the way to Pyria.
What if it happens again?
What if I get blown away while I'm
invisible and can't find my way back to
everyone?
She hesitated, pulling her front talons
in close to her chest.
The high wing on top of Kibley suddenly
lurched sideways, as if something had
rammed into his side.
He yelled and slashed upward with his
claws, and Luna saw blood droplets spray
out from the empty air.
Flames from nowhere engulfed the hive
wing's tail, and he staggered, screaming
into the sea.
Kibley was up again, running back into
the crowd of dragons around tsunami
breathing his own fire now.
As he ran, the seaweed underfoot began to
slither around the hive wing's claws.
Luna saw one yellow and black dragon trip
and slam heavily into the sand.
Another pair found themselves wound
together, with long wet strands, and
began shoving each other furiously.
At the same time, Luna saw another hive
wing yelp and fall sideways into the
waves beside him, clutching his neck.
Maybe we do have a chance, she thought
with a rush of surprise.
She landed on a tall boulder and looked
down at the strange battle that covered
the beach.
Maybe we can win without even using my
flame silk.
Maybe I don't have to do anything.
I mean, we have 3 dragons who can breathe
fire.
Sundu and her leaf speak, invisibility
the tranquilizer darts, and a dragon who
can see the future.
Although, snakes and silkworms, moon, why
didn't you see this coming?
Maybe these kind, funny dragons can fight
a bunch of scary hive wings.
Something rustled in the trees above the
beach, and a new dragon came gliding onto
the sand.
His talons touched down lightly, and he
narrowed his eyes.
There's another dragon here.
He hissed.
One we cannot see, possibly more.
Luna's heart nearly stopped.
The new dragon's wings were gold, dappled
with lavender and gray, and long pale
purple antennae were slowly unfurling
from his head.
That wasn't a hive wing.
That was a silkwing, looking all peaceful
and harmless, while Queen Wasp's voice
slithered malevolently from his mouth.
A shudder ran down Luna's spine.
Sundew and Cricket had said that Wasp
could control Silkwings now, but Luna had
never seen it herself.
She hadn't quite believed it until that
moment.
The silk wing on the beach twisted his
neck around, and then slowly back in the
other direction.
What's he doing?
Cricket whispered from the air above
Luna.
Why are his eyes closed?
He's using his antennae.
Luna realized.
They pick up movement and vibrations in
the air.
Like, from invisible dragons?
Cricket said with alarm.
Or camouflage to rain wings?
Muna heard a small clattering sound.
We have to stop him.
Three moons, loading invisible darts into
an invisible blowgun is impossible.
Luna, help me.
We have to knock out that silk wing.
Luna fumbled for her own blowgun pouch
but before she could get it out, the
silkwing suddenly flew across the beach
and launched himself at one of the sand
dunes not far from her boulder.
Two other hive wings spun and attacked
the same spot in unison.
They all moved in the creepy, synchronized
way Cricket had told Luna about.
But it was so much more horrifying to see
it with her own eyes.
They didn't seem like dragons anymore.
They looked like knives that someone else
was slashing through the air.
There was a shriek beneath their claws
and a bright green dragon with white
wings suddenly appeared on the sand.
It took Luna a moment to realize that it
was pineapple.
She had never seen him in those colors
before.
Pineapple, she cried.
He couldn't hear her.
A moment later, one of the high wings
smacked a rock into the side of the rain
wings head.
Pineapple went limp.
His white spotted wings splayed awkwardly
under the talons of his attackers.
Bloody claw marks were scored along his
underbelly.
But she could see his chest still rising
and falling.
What do we do?
How do we rescue him?
There's someone else we can't see, said
the Silkwing, lifting his head again, one
with fire.
He paused, and then smiled, a slow
malevolent smile.
A lost flame silk, perhaps.
Luna.
Little flame silk.
Are you here?
Luna felt a sick yawning pit open up in
her stomach.
It was bone chilling to think that Wasp
knew her name.
To know that Wasp had spent time thinking
about her at all.
Even though she was invisible.
Luna felt as though Wasp was glaring
straight at her through the Silk Wings
maggot white eyes.
Everyone freeze.
Sundew shouted, from somewhere along the
beach.
Cricket says that Silkwings can sense
movement.
Don't let him find you.
Luna didn't need to be told twice.
She wasn't sure she could move anyway.
She kept her wings tight to her body
claws gripping the rock, hardly daring to
breathe.
The silk wing took a step toward her
Antenny twitching.
Beyond him, Kibley was sinking under the
attack of 3 hive wings, and Luna couldn't
even see tsunami in the wave of dragons
around her.
Another step.
Luna's eyes were riveted on the enemy's
antenna as they tested the air. pivoting
slowly in her direction, like mesmerizing
cobras.
He was going to find her.
Wasp was going to catch her and take her
mind and control her like these brain
washed dragons.
And Luna would end up as an empty shell
spitting flame soak for a monster for the
rest of her life.
A blast of fire suddenly hit the silk
wings left side, or almost did.
He whipped out of the way at the last
moment, and in one liquid motion, whirled
and pounced on a spot of empty air, that
was not so empty after all.
Here, the silk wing commanded, and 10
hive wings descended at once.
Luna pressed her claws to her face to
stop herself from screaming.
Silvery threads were pouring from the
silk wing's wrists, winding around the
empty air in the unmistakable shape of a
struggling dragon.
Flames burst from the invisible dragon
searing the closest threads to ash.
But if they set all the silk on fire
it'll burn their scales too, Luna
thought.
Can I?
If I burn the silk wing, I have to use my
flame silk to stop him.
But it was all happening so fast.
One of the hive wings stepped forward, and
long black stingers slid from under her
claws.
She stabbed them into the air where the
dragon's neck should be.
The silvery threads sagged and went
still.
With a grim smile, the silkwings spun
more and more silk, until the invisible
unconscious dragon was wound up like a
spider's lunch.
And from the size and the fire, now Luna
could guess who it was.
The hive wings had captured Moon.
Chapter 4.
We can still beat them, Luna thought
desperately.
It's not over.
But when she looked along the beach, She
saw that tsunami lay unconscious on the
sand.
Another hive wing with long claw stingers
stood over her, toxin, and blue sea wing
blood dripping from the sharp points.
Behind them, 5 hive wings had finally
managed to ping Kibley down.
He thrashed furiously, but even his tail
was trapped under heavy red talons.
The hive wing who had paralyzed tsunami
stepped over, and sank her stingers into
his neck as well.
Barely a moment later.
He was still.
Sundew.
Lynx's voice said from somewhere near
Kibley.
Sandu answered.
As the Silkwings head snapped up.
The antenna quivering suspiciously.
Silence fell over the beach.
All the hive wings seemed to be frozen in
place, forced motionless by the queen in
their heads.
Only the silkwing moved.
Stepping carefully around the fallen
dragons, avoiding the seaweed, and
studying the talon prints in the sand.
To Luna.
He seemed like a hollow shell of a
dragon.
Nothing but a weapon for Queen Wasp to
use against them.
Who was he before?
Which hive did he live in?
Was he in the chrysalis?
Does he know what's happening to him
now?
What kind of dragons are these?
The silk wing hissed.
He walked slowly around tsunami and Kibli
pausing to study Kibli's tale with an
expression Luna couldn't read.
I remember dragons like this.
He murmured, in a voice that suddenly
wasn't wasps anymore.
It didn't seem like his own, though.
His movement seemed even weirder and more
unnatural, as though Dragon Wings didn't
fit quite right on him.
His head pivoted to glare at pineapple.
And those, he spat, the ones that change
color, I remember those.
He lifted one of his claws to tap the
side of his snout, then shifted his
narrow gaze to the moon bundle.
I don't recall invisible dragons who
stayed invisible when unconscious
though.
Will I be able to control them?
Wasp's voice demanded.
Will the breath of evil work on them?
She paused, and then the Silkwing hissed
softly.
There's one way to find out.
He murmured, in the other voice.
A soft moan came from one of the
collapsed dragons.
Red and black scales rippled as the hive
wing tried to sit up, shivering with pain
from the burns on her tail.
Luna guessed she was the one who'd been
fighting Kibley.
The hive wing pressed her front talons to
her forehead for a long moment.
Then she glanced at the dark scorch marks
across her tail and winced.
Where are we?
She asked the soldier closest tour.
He stared into the distance with those
white marble eyes, unmoving and
unresponsive.
The hive wing scanned the beach, hive
wing bodies lying half in and half out of
the waves, or collapsed on the sand
others standing frozen, at attention.
Three unconscious prisoners who looked
nothing like any Pentalon dragon.
One mystery dragon shaped bundle of silk
and the ominous silk wing, still stalking
around the sand and muttering to
himself.
And the island itself, so vastly
different from the hives or the
savannah.
The hive wing blinked, bewildered.
Luna wondered how long these hive wings
had been under Wasp's mind control, and
if they had any memory of what they'd
done for her.
She wondered why Wasp had released this
one now, but not any of the others.
Are we in the distant kingdoms?
The hive wing asked.
But once again, the soldier did not
respond.
The silkwing, however, came gliding
across the sand to loom over her.
Were there any other dragons here?
This old wing snapped, back in Wasp's
voice.
The high wing looked confused.
And Luna thought, there was a flash of
contempt on her face too.
She's never had a silk wing talk to her
like that.
How would I know?
the hive wing demanded.
The Silkwing gazed coldly down at her.
What is your name?
Earwig?
The high wing answered sullenly.
Earwig.
Ah, yes, of Setsy Hive.
I'm inside your brothers now.
I could have them kill each other so
easily.
Or perhaps this one could rip off the
other's ears.
That would be entertaining.
Perhaps if you ever want to see them
again.
You could try addressing your queen with
more respect.
Earwig stared up at him, her wings slack
with astonishment.
Use your brain, hissed the silkwing.
There were 2 dragons we could see and 2
we could not.
Did you sense any others?
Luna held her breath.
Nah, no, your majesty, earwig said.
I mean, I wasn't really in myself.
And there was a lot, um, happening.
The silkwing made an impatient movement
that scattered sand across earwigs burns
and she winced again.
But I don't think so, she added quickly.
Did you notice any flame silk?
The Silkwing demanded?
An odd, brief struggle seemed to cross
his face, and then, in the other voice he
spat.
Or any plants acting strangely?
Plants acting strangely?
Earwig blinked several times, and glanced
at the palm trees up the beach.
No?
She didn't notice the seaweed.
Luna thought with relief.
Queen Wasp must have been so busy
controlling the silk wing that she didn't
notice it either.
Or, There are 2 minds fighting inside the
silkwing.
And maybe even if Queen Wasp did notice.
She's decided not to tell the other one
for some reason.
The silkwing peered up at the clouds, and
then around at the sand, radiating
suspicion.
Sundew!
He yelled suddenly.
Sundew, are you here?
Silence.
The sun shone brightly in an empty blue
sky.
Luna could hear birds fluttering in the
trees, but no dragons.
Nothing but earwigs labored breathing.
What if the others left?
And I'm the only one still here.
Her heart sped up.
And she tried to think calmer thoughts
but in the emptiness, it was hard to
believe she hadn't been abandoned there
alone on her rock, with enemies all
around her.
Sundew, the silkwing said.
Almost charmingly, except that his face
didn't even try to make an expression.
We're not finished with each other.
I know it.
You know it.
Why not come on out and face me.
Another long pause.
Don't you want to see your mother again?
The silkwing taunted the empty air, he
smirked.
All right.
Perhaps not her.
I don't blame you.
I'd chop that branch off too, if it was
related to me.
But what about your queen?
Or that little blue silk wing you went to
so much trouble to steal from me?
Blue.
Luna's heart thudded.
Blue, blue.
Blue, trapped in wasps' talons.
The silk wing turned toward her, and Luna
feared that she must have moved at the
thought of blue, that a flinch, or
indrawn breath had given her way.
But it crossed to the silk bundle and
prodded it, frowning.
This isn't you?
Leaf wings don't breathe fire.
And that wasn't flame silk, so it's not
my Luna either.
But if they're not with Sundoo, why are
these dragons here now?
Earwig looked around at the other frozen
soldiers.
Then back at him.
Ah, are you asking me?
He gave her disgusted look.
Do you know the answer?
No, she said.
I don't know anything.
I don't know who Sundu is, or why we
fought these mystery mutant dragons.
I'm not even sure where we are.
She tried to stand up, but a look of
agony crossed her face as her tail moved
and she collapsed to the sand again.
The silkwing jabbed one of the
unconscious hive wings in the face with
his claw.
When that got no reaction, he leaned down
and sniffed the air around the dragon's
snout, then squinted, until he spotted
the tiny dart jutting out between their
scales.
Not dead then, said Wasp's voice.
But utterly useless to me like this.
The silk wings straightened.
The rest of you will have to carry our
prisoners back to Wasp Hive.
All of them?
Right now?
Earwig asked.
Shouldn't we rest?
My wings feel like we've been flying for
days.
Is it a long way back?
If they have to carry a whole dragon, even
these tiny ones, even with 3 hive wings
to a prisoner, they're going to get tired
fast.
It is unpleasant.
To converse with a dragon who talks so
much.
Wasp remarked.
Earwig closed her mouth and rubbed her
forehead again.
You will stay here, and wait for these
dragons to wake up.
Wasp said, waving the silk wings talons
at the Vord tranquilized hive wings.
Then you will all return to Wasp Hive.
He snapped his tail, and the other hive
wings began to move in silent unison
splitting up to circle the prisoners, and
dragging vines from the trees.
Wait, Earwig said.
I don't want to be stuck here alone.
What if you're right?
And there are other dragons lurking
about.
She shivered.
Can't you jump back into me so I can go
with you?
Just make me like them again.
She pointed to the white eyed dragons who
were lashing long vines around tsunami.
Luna would have gasped if she could have
moved.
Earwig, was asking for Wasp to take over
her mind.
She was inviting the evil queen back into
her head.
How can she want that?
No.
Wasp didn't even turn the silk wing to
look at earwig again.
You are in too much pain.
It will distract me from the many claws I
am working with right now.
But I don't know how to get back.
None of us do.
Irwig cried.
You can't fly us all the way out into the
middle of the ocean and leave us to die.
This conversation is boring me, Wasp
said.
Let me be clear so it can be over.
I do not care what happens to you.
Luna noticed that your wig looked lost
but not terribly surprised by this.
The silkwing made a commanding gesture at
the marble eyed hive wings, and they bent
toward their captives.
As Kibli was lifted into his net of vines
his head lolled, and the pouch around his
neck slid off into the sand with a
soft...
A panicked cry tried to claw its way out
of Luna's throat, and she had to tense
every muscle in her body to keep it from
escaping.
She'd forgotten, that Kibley was the one
carrying the map in his pouch.
The map she and Sundu and the others
needed to get home to Pentala.
The map that could lead WASP and her army
to Pyria.
The map that must never, ever fall into
wasps' talons.
Don't find it.
Luna prayed.
Leave it lying there.
Don't even notice it.
The silkwing turned.
With agonizing slowness, and stared down
the pouch.
Chapter 5.
Please, Luna prayed.
Please ignore it.
Please don't find the map.
The silkwing nudged the pouch with one
claw.
It lay flat on the sand, like a deflated
leather sack.
He reached to pick it up.
It had this in it, earwigs said out of
the blue.
She held up Kibley's blowgun, which had
fallen near her talons.
She shook it a few times, and one of the
darts slid out.
I think he was trying to jab me.
Her claw flicked the dart.
Aha.
Wasp said, through the silk wing.
The trick they used on your unconscious
comrades, I assume.
The Silkwing turned to tsunami and yanked
the Seawing's pouch off her neck to peer
inside.
Yes.
They all seem to have them.
So it's a weapon they made, not a natural
dragon power.
Interesting.
He shook tsunami's pouch, and the dream
visitor Sapphire tumbled out along with a
blowgun.
Luna's heart sank.
She knew that it was better to lose the
dream visitor than the map.
WASP could do much worse damage with the
map.
And yet, losing the only way to contact
SwordTail felt like having all her
favorite tapestries torn to shreds.
The Silkwing held it up to his nose and
squinted at it.
Strange thing to carry around.
He said in one voice, and then went on in
wasp's voice.
A gift for me from the distant kingdoms.
How thoughtful.
He tucked it back into Tsunami's pouch
which he draped over his own head, then
beckoned the other dragons with his
tail.
Time to go.
They flared open their wings in unison
and lifted into the sky.
Kibli, tsunami, pineapple, and invisible
moon hung between them, wrapped in vines
breathing, but otherwise still.
Luna couldn't believe it.
They'd been arguing and joking and
laughing with her only moments ago, and
now, they were wasps prisoners.
It's all falling apart.
We haven't even reached Pentala yet, and
everything is already lost.
She watched helplessly as their wing
beats faded into the distance.
Earwig slumped on the beach, staring out
of the ocean.
She was alone, with the 4 unconscious
hive wings.
The sand all around her was churned up by
the battle, grooved with claw marks, and
splattered with blood.
I can move now, Luna thought.
But it was hard to convince her petrified
limbs.
The silk wing is gone.
Earwig won't notice me.
I can go to the palm tree and hope to
find the others there.
Should she try to grab Kibley's pouch
first?
What if earwig spotted it floating away?
Earwig sighed?
Long and tragic, and then, as if she'd
heard Luna's thoughts, she dragged
herself over to Kibley's pouch and picked
it up.
No, Luna cried inside her head.
No, no, no.
Earwig opens the pouch and peeked
inside.
With a barely curious expression.
She slid out the map and unfolded it.
Her eyes went wide.
She started to jump to her feet, let out
a yelp of pain, and toppled over again.
Wasp!
she shouted.
Come back.
Your majesty, I found...
Flip.
With the tiny sound of a dart, zipping
through the air.
Earwig's eyes rolled back in her head, and
she flopped over with a thud.
Whew. said Lynx's voice, loud and clear
in the silence.
Nice shot.
Bullfrog's deep voice came from the mess
of sandy talon prints near where
pineapple had fallen, not far from Luna.
She couldn't believe he'd been that close
to her, and so silent that whole time.
Well, maybe she could believe the silent
part.
Are we all here?
Sundu asked, from the far side of the
battleground.
I am, Cricket's voice answered.
Yes, said Bullfrog, and here, said Lynx.
Me too, Luna managed.
What are we going to do?
Cricket asked.
Her voice overlapping with links, saying
that was awful.
I felt like I couldn't do anything.
Poor pineapple.
Luna said.
She pressed her talons to her snout, and
took a deep breath to stop her tears.
I can't believe a silk wing.
She trailed off.
Was that terrifying?
Me neither, Sundu growled.
Ren, Sky, where are you?
Will the mind control work on the Pyrean
dragons?
Cricket asked.
That's the 1st thing wasp will do, don't
you think?
Inject them with her hive mind toxin?
No, because we're going to get them back
before that happens.
Sundew said firmly.
Skye.
Can we revisible ourselves now?
Cricket asked.
If I make us visible, Moon will be too
Sundew said.
And then they'll know she's another clear
sight.
But I might have to anyway, if we can't
find Skye and Ren.
Skye, Wren!
Yes, what?
The little human's voice demanded, as
wing beats descended from the clouds.
Four talon prints appeared in a puff of
sand, followed by a spray of moor sand as
guys shook out his wings.
What are you shouting our names for?
Ach, Sky, quit that.
You're getting sand in my mouth.
Where did you go?
Sundu said irritably.
We were worried about you.
I mean, not me specifically, but somebody
probably was.
We went to the palm tree to wait for you
Ran answered.
I told you, I'm not sending sky into any
battles with creepy bug dragon zombies.
No offense, Cricket.
Why?
I'm not cricket started.
But we could see most of what happened
Ren went on, and it didn't look great.
It was so horrible.
Sky's voice added mournfully.
I did not like those dragons.
Is pineapple all right?
Where did they take them?
I thought we weren't going to fight any
hive wings?
Ren added.
I thought our very specific plan was to
stay far away from any dragons who might
end up mind controlling us or hurting
Skye.
Or stealing our friends.
Sky added.
We didn't go looking for them, Sundew
barked.
They attacked us.
We couldn't not fight back.
I know, Ren said.
Just...
Sky's not that kind of dragon.
Battles like that, scare him.
I beg your pardon?
Sky said, ripples appearing in the sand
from his ruffling wings.
I'm not scared.
I mean, my heart is going really fast, and
my stomach is flippy wobbly, and I wish I
had a giant turtle shell that I could
crawl into and stay there and never see
those dragons again, but mostly, I am
worried about pineapple, and our other
friends.
They're still alive, Luna reassured him.
They were all unconscious.
They're being taken to Wasp Hive, where
the queen lives.
WASP prefers capturing dragons to killing
them.
Cricket explained.
They're more useful to her as new
soldiers to control than his corpses.
Ah, Ren said.
I don't like those options.
No, thank you.
We should follow them, shouldn't we?
Luna asked.
A 100000000 knows?
Ren cried.
Follow them?
What did I just say?
Of course we have to follow them.
Sundu said.
We stay at a distance until we can
tranquilize or dart the silk wing.
Maybe while they're sleeping.
Then we can sneak in and rescue
everyone.
I'm not sure WASP is going to let them
sleep until they're inside her hive.
Cricket said slowly.
She can drive the dragons she's inside
beyond the point of exhaustion.
I think that's how she got them this far
out here without the map.
I don't think she could get them all the
way to Pyria, but she can probably fly
them back to her hive without letting
them rest.
So, if we try to follow them, links added
we might end up over open water, with
nowhere to rest when we need to.
So, what's the alternative?
Sundu cried.
We can't let them take 4 dragons from
us.
From the plumes of sand around her
voice.
Luna guessed the invisible leaf wing was
lashing her tail.
They'd rescue us if they were here, Luna
agreed.
You know Tsunami and Kibbly wouldn't even
stop to think.
Um, I'm in favor of stopping to think
before doing dangerous things.
Links interjected.
Me too.
Cricket agreed.
And remember, our goal is to get to the
abyss and fulfill Moon's prophecy.
Don't we think that's the way to defeat
WASP and the other mind?
So it's actually the best way to rescue
our friends?
Better than throwing ourselves at an army
of creepy bug dragons, yes.
Ren chimed in.
But we can't fulfill the prophecy without
them.
Luna protested.
Talons United.
That means all 10 of us.
And Moon is the only one who can tell us
what to do.
We need to follow the prophecy exactly
and we're already failing.
You can't make a tapestry with half your
silk missing.
She thought anxiously.
Actually, Bullfrog's voice said slowly.
Clay says, prophecies aren't like
instructions.
And they aren't messages saying, this
will definitely happen.
He says, prophecy can give you a hint in
the right direction.
But you have to choose what you do with
it.
Everyone fell silent for a long moment.
Luna was so startled by the length of
bullfrog's speech, that it took her a
moment to process the meaning of it.
Wait.
So prophecies don't tell the future?
she asked.
Who's clay?
Cricket asked at the same time.
A mud wing, who was in a prophecy not too
long ago.
Links explained.
He has saved Pyria.
But our prophecies told us what would
happen, Luna argued.
I mean, the ones in Clearsight's book?
They were like instructions.
They were exactly instructions.
Maybe, Cricket said.
We don't know for sure because we never
lived in a time Clearsight actually
predicted.
All I'm saying, Bullfrog cut in, his
voice deep and implacable.
Is that we're the ones who make the
prophecy happen?
Not the other way around.
I'm confused, said Luna.
I still think we need all 10 of us.
I think I get it, Sundu said.
You're saying the future is up to us.
Whatever happens next?
It's because of what we decide to do, not
because of some mystical force pointing
us here, or plopping us there.
So we could decide to save our friends
couldn't we?
Luna said.
Shouldn't we?
Let's vote, Sundu said.
All in favor of chasing the hive wings
right now to rescue Moon and the others?
Me, Luna said.
Me too, Skye said.
Ouch, Ren, no kicking.
Bad pet human.
And me.
Sundu said.
Who thinks we should stick with the
original plan and go find the abyss.
Me?
Cricket and Bullfrog said together.
Me too.
Lynx agreed.
So it's a tie.
Sundoo said with a sigh.
Said Wren's little human voice.
I'm here too.
And I vote for the original plan.
I'd rather take Skye to a creepy abyss
than into a swarm of creepy murder bug
dragons, R, Skye, stop.
There was a thump, and a large dent
appeared in the beach, where Skye had
apparently flung himself down, followed
by a lot of sand flying, and crabs
scuttling about as he had a rolling
tantrum.
Little human footprints landed on the
sand and darted out of the way, then
stopped again.
Luna could easily picture Wen with her
hands on her hips, glaring at the mess I
was making.
Well, this is very mature.
Rand's voice said crossly.
Sky.
I know how you feel, Lang said.
My heart says rescue them too.
But my head says, we'll only get
ourselves caught or worse, and the most
logical way to save them is to get to the
abyss.
If we can defeat the other mind.
WASP won't have an army to control
anymore, right?
That's our theory.
And we can't risk losing you or Ren.
Cricket agreed.
You're the only ones who can help us talk
to the humans to find the abyss.
No, Sky cried.
Ren, you can't just save me in the
kingdom of sand, even when it was
dangerous.
That's what we do for friends.
And I finally have dragon friends.
Dragon friends who need saving.
All right, this is what we're going to
do.
Sundu said, with such authority that
everyone went quiet, and Skye stopped
invisibly thrashing around.
Links and I will go try to rescue them.
If it seems impossible, we won't risk it
but we'll take as many darts as we can
and see what we can do.
Meanwhile, the rest of you keep following
the map to Pentala and wait for us
there.
If we don't catch up with you in 2 days
go look for the abyss without us.
Just us?
Luna said softly.
Her, Cricket, Sky and Ren, and Bullfrog.
No tsunami or sundew to do the fighting.
No moon to tell the future.
No clever Kibli plans, no reassuring
links, smiles, or pineapple
cheerfulness.
Don't worry, Sundew said.
Will be there.
Luna wanted to believe that.
But if anything went wrong, the 5 of them
would have to face the abyss alone.
The last words of the prophecy echoed in
her head.
Face a great evil with talons united.
Or none of the tribes will survive.
Chapter 6.
Luna was not surprised that it was
raining.
It was the rainy season on Penthala.
She was used to the drumming sound of
raindrops on hive walls and silk
ceilings.
She was not, used to the damp, chilly air
spraying her no matter where she tried to
sit, though.
This cave was not designed for dragons to
live in during storms, especially if
those dragons had nothing to do, except
anxiously watch the sky outside for
missing friends.
Of course, she knew those friends would
be invisible.
So she wouldn't see them coming.
But she couldn't stop sitting near the
mouth of the cave, and staring out at the
thunderstorm anyway.
I can make a tapestry of this, Luna
thought.
Endless rain, an empty beach.
A sky that's all clouds and no dragons.
Or maybe I'd weave shapes away off in the
distance, blurred by lines of silver, silk
raindrops, but still there, like faraway
hope, coming toward us.
I would love some hope.
Even far away hope, right now.
Luna?
Cricket's voice said, her talon prints
approaching through the wet sand.
Are you there?
For a moment.
Luna considered pretending she wasn't.
If she held really still and didn't
breathe, Maybe cricket would walk away
and Luna wouldn't have to muster the
energy for a conversation, or more
importantly, for a conversation where she
had to act like she trusted this hive
wing, like it was fine that Luna was
stuck in a cave with her, instead of with
any of the dragons she really wanted to
be with.
She would know though.
And Luna couldn't bring herself to hurt
cricket's feelings, especially when she
remembered the way Blue looked at her.
I'm here, Luna said.
Just waiting.
Again, stuck in one place.
No idea what to do or how to help
anyone.
Maybe they're hiding out from the rain.
Cricket said, accidentally bumping one of
her wings.
Maybe they're worried about the lightning
and they'll be here as soon as the storm
lets up.
Maybe, Luna said.
More to let Cricket know she was still
there and listening than because she
agreed.
Sundu and Lynx should have been there
yesterday.
They'd agreed to wait for them at the
cave that connected to the Flame Hill
Cavern, the one where Luna had been blown
away by the storm.
A whole extra day they'd been waiting.
With no sign of the leaf wing or the ice
wing.
Have they been captured too?
It would be so, so bad for sundew to fall
into the clutches of Queen Wasp.
With sundews, leaf speak power.
The other mind could grow the breath of
evil plant from one edge of the continent
to the other in a matter of weeks.
Don't think about that.
She's fine.
I'm sure she's all right.
They'll be here soon.
Keep smiling.
No problems here.
Except no one could see her face.
So she didn't have to pretend, smile.
The one upside of being invisible.
Luna kind of wished she could spin
herself another cocoon, and go back into
it for a while.
This happened to her sometimes.
It felt as though she had her own rainy
seasons and sunny seasons inside her
head.
Some days.
She was full of light and endless energy
and knowing what was right and ready to
fix everything.
But then, Sundays, a kind of fog wove
through her thoughts, and she just wanted
to crawl away from everyone and wrap
herself in silk, and not be a dragon for
a while.
She thought she hid those days pretty
well.
She had a lot of practice at smiling
through the fog, so her mothers wouldn't
worry.
She didn't mean to add to all the
troubles everyone had, even Blue, who
noticed so much, and tried so hard to
understand everyone, usually couldn't
tell when she was having a rainy season
day.
There wasn't always a clear reason for
the sad feelings, or rather, in some ways
there were always reasons.
Teachers yelling at Luna and Blue in
school.
Sore tail in trouble again.
Luna's mother silverspot, lying sadly in
her hammock after another long day of
cruelty from her hive wing mistress.
All of them, too squashed flat by the
meanness of others, and too exhausted to
weave or make beautiful things, or dream
of a better life.
But this time, there was a very clear
reason.
And so the sadness felt even bigger, like
she was letting down the whole world.
Losing pineapple, moon, Kibli and tsunami
not knowing where sundu and lynx were.
Silkwings under Queen Wasp's Mind
Control.
Their mission failing before they'd even
begun.
And sore tail and blue.
She really couldn't let herself think
about sore tail and bloom, and how much
they needed her. and how much she was
failing to rescue them.
Or else, the fog cocoon might wrap her up
forever, and then she'd be no use to
anyone.
It also didn't help that she was still
invisible.
Each day that passed without seeing her
own talons or her friends' faces, made
Luna feel more and more unreal.
As though she didn't really exist.
Or maybe they didn't.
Or maybe nothing did.
She felt like she could dissolve into the
clouds, and no one would notice or care.
Sore Tail would.
He would care so much.
He needs me to be real so I can rescue
him.
My whole tribe needs me to rescue them.
Come on, Luna.
Sit up and keep going.
Luna pulled back her shoulders and
fluffed her damp wings, at least being
this cold and wet, meant that she must
still exist, right?
Also, being invisible was useful for
gathering food, without being spotted by
the patrols that were constantly
overhead.
The patrols were still mostly hive
wings.
Luna had been afraid that mind controlled
silk wings would be everywhere when they
reached Pentala, but she hadn't seen very
many so far.
She knew some of them were in the hives
imprisoned until wasp had more breath of
evil to infect them with.
With poor blue and sore tail forced to
guard them.
Shouldn't I go to them?
If this abyss plan is falling apart
anyway?
Shouldn't I fly to Cicada Hive and try to
save them?
How though?
I have all this fire.
But I don't know what to do with it.
Flame silk can't get wasp out of their
heads, and what else do I have?
Isn't it weird being invisible for this
long?
Cricket said.
Her voice more subdued than usual.
When it's quiet?
I have these moments where I suddenly
feel all alone.
As though everyone else is gone and I'm a
ghost, floating around with no body.
Do you ever feel like that?
Um, Luna said reluctantly.
Maybe a little.
She hesitated, but her curiosity won
out.
What do you do when you feel that way?
I come looking for you.
Cricket's voice said wryly.
I mean, Sky and Bullfrog and Wren help
too.
But you're the most real to me for some
reason.
Maybe because we're both from here.
Hmm, Luna answered.
She wasn't sure quite what to say to
that.
Cricket's disembodied voice was easier to
talk to than cricket's hive wing face, but
she didn't exactly find it comforting.
And sometimes, cricket went on.
I close my eyes, and try to focus on what
I can feel.
Like, my claws feel wet sand sifting
around them.
My wings lift in the wind from the sea.
I'm still here.
I really exist.
I'm in this dragon body in this world, you
know?
Does that make sense?
Luna took a deep breath and tried to
inhabit her senses beyond sight.
My scales are real.
My talons are real.
I am still here.
That does help, she said after a moment.
Also, if I were a ghost, I hope I would
pick a better place to haunt than this
damp, fishy smelling cave.
Cricket laughed.
I would haunt a library, she said
although it would be very frustrating to
only read books over other dragons
shoulders.
I'd haunt an art museum.
Luna said dreamily.
If she weren't real, she could look at
beautiful things all day long and avoid
mean dragons without feeling guilty about
all the dragons who needed her, and all
the tasks she should be accomplishing.
But I am real.
I'm really Luna, and I can't let myself
drift away.
Do you think Earwig made it back to
shore?
Cricket asked.
Grooves in the sand appeared as she drew
shapes with her claws.
She'd had a fight with Sundu about the
unconscious hive wing soldiers back on
the island.
We can help them, Cricket had argued.
Ewig is lost out here.
All 5 of these hive wings are.
We could draw her a map on a leaf or
something, just showing the safe island
trail from here back to Pentala?
It wouldn't be the whole map, just enough
to get her home.
So that Queen Wasp can have 5 more
dragons for her army if we run into them
again.
Sundew had demanded.
Why not leave them stuck out here where
they can't hurt us?
Because they're still dragons, Cricket
pointed out.
They didn't choose to come here or attack
us.
They're going to wake up scared, wishing
they could go home, and we could help
them.
Sundo.
We have to go now or we'll lose the
trail.
Links had said.
Breathing little ice crystals into the
air from above them.
We don't have time to argue.
Fine.
Do what you like.
Sundewad said to Cricket.
I think it's a mistake, but if you want
to take the time, go ahead.
And then she and Links were gone, leaving
the map with Luna.
Luna wasn't sure who was right.
Her instinct was to trust Sundoo, but
Crickets said Blue would want to help the
hive wings, and that, unfortunately, was
definitely true.
Luna knew her little brother would never
fly away and leave them lost like that.
So Luna had used her flaying silk to
carefully burn a copy of the map onto a
wide leaf.
Just the part of it that would get the
hive wings back home.
She'd added crickets note.
This is the way back to Pentala.
Good luck.
Friends who want you to be free.
Then they left it in the sand under one
of earwig's talons.
Luna hoped they'd done the right thing.
She hoped earwig would remember that
someone had tried to help her when Queen
Wasp had left her to die.
Una realized, she'd been thinking for too
long, and hadn't answered cricket's
question.
I'm sure she did, she said.
Cricket?
Do you really think there are good hive
wings?
Ones who would help us if they could?
She was glad she couldn't see the look on
Cricket's face.
Luna had been thinking about this
question for days, and couldn't believe
she'd actually blurted it out.
There was a long pause, and then Cricket
said softly.
I hope so.
There's Katie did for one, and my dad, I
think.
I haven't met him yet, but maybe Scarab
liked him.
I hope he turns out to be good once he's
free from wasps clutches.
But I guess I can't promise what any of
them will be like then.
I only know which side I want to be on.
And it's with you, and blue.
We need all the allies we can get, Luna
reminded herself.
She never did anything to help us
before.
But she's only a dragonette, like us.
Maybe this was her 1st chance.
Maybe she felt like me.
Like she wanted to change things, but
didn't know how.
What if you had to choose between saving
blue or, like, all the hive wings, Luna
asked, or your family, Blue, in a
heartbeat, Cricket said.
I promise, Luna.
Blue is my favorite dragon in all the
world.
My very favorite.
I didn't know dragons like him existed.
If it seems like I don't miss him
enough.
It's because I'm trying so hard not to
cry all the time.
It feels like my wings have been cut
off.
But I know I have to keep going.
Even on whatever stumps are left, because
I'm not going to let this happen to him.
Luna hadn't been quite ready for sharing
all their feelings.
She hadn't expected a hive wing of all
dragons to just open up her chest, pull
out all the pieces of her heart, and
scatter them around on the sand like
that.
She wanted to stuff them back in, and
wrap cricket in silk, so she'd have to
act normal again, and they could pretend
nobody here was on the verge of crying.
To her enormous relief.
Scuffling noises came from farther back
in the cave.
Luna turned toward the sound, and saw
damp little human footprints come padding
over the rocks.
I think I found something, Wren's voice
said breathlessly.
Maybe a way to find the humans here.
A flurry of sand and raindrops erupted
from where cricket was sitting.
Really?
The hive wing cried.
Did you see them?
What were they doing?
Did they have books with them?
I didn't see any people yet, Ren said, but
I found a human sized torch that was
burned at one end.
It's in this huge cave that has at least
2 passageways out of it, the dragon's
wouldn't fit into.
I figured I'd search them, but I wanted
to let Sky know first.
I think he's on the beach, looking for
turtles with bullfrog, Luna said.
Oh, Skye, Ren said with a laugh.
How did he bamboozle bullfrog into that?
While Wren went out into the rain to find
the others.
Luna tried to focus on shaking off the
fog in her head.
They had something to do finally, besides
sit and wait.
The group needed her up energy, the let's
do it, let's change things.
Let's make a difference, Luna.
Come on.
I know I'm in there somewhere.
Invisible wings came into the cave
shaking off waterfalls of wet droplets.
Ren's voice squeaked indignantly, and
said something stern to sky in their part
human, part dragon language.
I hope we see a human, cricket said.
Sundew said she saw one down here once.
I wonder if it was in the same cavern.
Ren's footprints pattered over to the
spot where they'd burned a fire the last
2 nights, and one of the long sticks
floated up into the air.
Luna or Bullfrog?
Could you light this for me?
I'll do it, Luna said.
She put one talon on the free end of the
stick, and let a coil of gold fire spiral
out of her wrist to wind around the
wood.
The silk burned in a thin thread for a
moment, and then it spread upward, until
the end of the torch was alight with
orange flame.
Thanks, Luna, Ren said.
All right, you can all follow me.
But if we see any humans, don't scare
them.
I mean, I know they won't be able to see
or hear us, but don't like, set anything
on fire or try to pick them up.
Or say, dump an ocean's worth of water on
their heads by accident.
Do you know what by accident even means?
Sky demanded.
The torch moved away to the back of the
cave and Skye's voice followed, the 2 of
them arguing affectionately.
They sound like me and sore tail, Luna
thought.
For 3 years now, she'd been part of a
pair.
Luna and Sword Tail, Sore Tail and Luna
She felt so strange and untethered
without him, like threads of loose silk
tied to a loom, but left out of the
tapestry.
The floating torch led them on a winding
path. deeper into the dark underground
labyrinth, until finally, it stopped near
an archway where the tunnel opened into a
bigger cave.
All right, everyone, shh.
Wren's voice said, from the area of the
torch.
Why?
Sky demanded at full volume.
We are not seeable and not hearable
aren't we?
La, la, la.
I could sing all day, and it wouldn't
bother anybody.
Except us, Ren said.
It would bother me and sh because I'm
talking, that's why.
This is the cave.
I'm going to leave my torch here, so the
humans don't see us coming, just in case
there are any in there now.
The burning stick floated over to the
wall, and Wren tucked the end into a
notch in the rocks.
Make sure you don't disturb anything, in
case they come back and notice and it
scares them off.
Are they really that smart?
Bullfrog's voice asked skeptically.
Luna could hear the frown in Wren's
voice.
Bullfrog?
You do remember that I'm one of them
right?
The little human retorted.
Right.
Just...
Thought you were...
Different.
Sorry.
He ended in a mumble.
She is special, but it turns out humans
are pretty smart.
Skye said suddenly, almost as smart as
turtles.
Not helping Skye.
Their voices had moved off into the
cave.
So Luna stepped forward cautiously
feeling the brush of cricket's tail ahead
of her.
It was a vast space, larger than the cave
that opened onto the beach.
Bigger even than the marketplace in
Cicada Hive.
Rock formations jutted from the floor and
ceiling, like dragon teeth, some of them
spiraled together into twisting columns
dim sunlight, and trickles of rain
spilled in from a few cracks in the roof
water falling down the craggy walls, to a
shallow pool on the far side.
Luna tucked the space into her memory, the
way she usually did.
By imagining it as a tapestry.
She pictured the silk colors she would
use for the shades of gray shadows and
golden spills of light, and how the sizes
of the stalactites would give a sense of
how far back the cave went.
She kept her talons, and poured flame
silk into them, choosing the kind that
glowed without burning.
Her father had told her about different
kinds of flame silk in the brief half day
she had had with him.
He hadn't tartered very much, but she'd
had way too much time to practice while
she sat on the beach with Treboa, and by
now, she could spend 5 different kinds of
flame silk thread.
The silk lit the area around her with a
golden glow, so she could see more
clearly into the shadows.
It wasn't visible to the others, though
or to any humans in the cave.
Not unless she lit something else on
fire.
Here's the torch I found.
Ren called from a ledge halfway up the
wall to Luna's right.
A stick, with a charred end waved in the
air.
Frayed bits of black thread clung to the
wood, as though it had once had something
wrapped around it to burn.
And see, it's near this opening, which
leads to a tunnel.
I'm going to go in and see what I can
find.
You all look for more clues out here.
Is that a good idea?
Sky asked nervously.
Couldn't I come with you if I squished?
You're not an octopus.
You big worry wart, Ren said.
There's no way.
Luna left them to their arguing and
wandered deeper into the cave, peeking
into all the dark corners.
She could see why Wren was curious about
this place.
There were holes and possible tunnels
everywhere, just the right size for the
small, soft species.
It would be easy for something Wren's
size to vanish into the wall if a dragon
came in.
What if the abyss is down a human sized
tunnel?
Luna worried?
What if it's buried in stone too deep for
dragons to reach?
She'd come to the far back wall of the
cave. and was trying to peer into one of
the little holes when she heard a faint
rustling overhead.
Luna stepped back and held up her flame
silk, trying to see onto the shelf of
rock above her.
Farther up, nearer one of the slants of
sunlight, something moved.
It felt like the sudden fright of finding
a spider pressed into a crack you thought
was just a line in the wall.
Luna gasped, and nearly stepped on her
own tail as she tripped backward.
On a ledge.
Way up by the light, lying flat against
the rocks, was a pale, soft looking
creature with a thatch of dark fur on its
head.
They had found their 1st pentalin human.
Chapter 7.
The invisible dragons were crowded so
close around the strange human's ledge
the bullfrog kept stepping on Luna's
talons.
This is amazing, cricket said, for the
900th time.
It's not running away or anything.
We can watch it for as long as we want.
Look at how cute it is.
Isn't it so cute?
Don't worry, Ren, you're cute too.
I most certainly am not, Ren's voice said
from up near the human.
She'd ordered Sky to lift her onto an
outcropping so she could study the
stranger.
What is it doing?
Cricket asked.
Is it reading?
It's looking at something, isn't it?
Please try not to lose your mind when I
tell you this?
Ren said.
This human seems to be comparing a
regular book to a dragon sized book.
Cricket gave a muffled gasp, and Luna
felt her wings fluttering in the air.
Or are reading both of them at the same
time or something?
But I don't think that's possible, Ren
said.
I mean, they're looking very closely at
the pictures in the Dragon book, but I
don't think they can actually read it.
Where did it get a dragon book?
Cricket burst out.
Which book is it?
What's the human sized book about?
I have no idea, ran answered.
A far away sound came from beyond the
rock wall.
And the strange human suddenly sat up and
turned toward it.
The sound came again.
With something that looked astonishingly
like a dragon's sigh.
The human folded its books into a covered
sort of parcel, tucked that safely
between 2 dry rocks, and then darted
through a small hole that Luna hadn't
even noticed.
Oh, no!
Cricket yelped.
Why did it leave?
I think someone was calling them, Ren
said.
I'm going to follow and see where they
go.
Back soon.
There was a little thump as she leaped to
the human's ledge, and then she was gone
too.
Ren?
Sky called nervously.
But she didn't respond.
Luna heard snuffling noises up by the
human's tunnel as though Sky was trying
to squash his snout into it.
Can we look at the books the human left
behind?
Cricket asked.
We shouldn't.
We might damage them, Luna said.
Ren said not to touch anything in case
they notice.
Remember?
Cricket made a frustrated noise.
But she said...
You're right.
Maybe Ren can get them out for us when
she comes back.
Ren was gone for a long, long time.
Bullfrog eventually went out to find food
for everyone, and Luna paced around the
cavern until she knew every corner.
She bumped into sky several times.
He appeared to be doing the same thing.
Maybe cricket was too.
But if so, she was better at dodging
them.
It is so weird to think Blue might have
found his someone, and she's a hive wing
who overshares and is obsessed with
humans and books.
Not exactly who I would have pictured him
with.
How would I even make a wedding tapestry
for them?
Their colors would totally clash.
No, they wouldn't, she admitted.
She couldn't lie to herself about
weaving.
Azure blue, lavender violet, orange gold
and black.
Fine, I bet they'd be really pretty.
She suddenly had a startling thought.
What if we somehow saved the world, but
never find sundo, or the magic
wristbands?
What if we're stuck invisible forever?
Blue and Sortail would have to learn to
live with invisible girlfriends.
That might be easier, actually.
No one would judge blue and cricket for
liking each other across tribes, and I
wouldn't have to think, back, hive wing
every time I saw her.
If I had met her as a voice and never saw
her scales, would I like her better?
She thought about the day she'd met Sore
Tail.
I'd have fallen for him no matter what he
looked like, or which tribe he was from
wouldn't I?
It had been her 1st day at Silkworm
Hall.
And it had started as a sunny season
morning in her mind.
She'd been so excited to finally go to
school, where she could learn to read and
weave, and how laws worked, and why
things just have to be this way, Luna.
And how to make big old main dragons
listen to you.
But everything started to go wrong at the
entrance to the hive.
When the guards there had roughly clamped
on her metal wrist cuff inscribed with
the name of the school.
It had been so unexpectedly heavy that
she'd yelped, and the hive wing putting
it on had sneered at her.
Too bad we're Silkworm Hall, getting a
whining little caterpillar like you, he'd
hissed.
I'm not whining.
Luna had huffed, ignoring blue when he
nudged her in the side.
I don't think it's supposed to be this
heavy.
It is.
The hive wing had snapped.
Move along.
Don't let the fog in, Luna had ordered
herself.
Don't let one mean dragon ruin your day.
But the dragons who ran Solgorum Hall
weren't any kinder.
Some of the teachers were silk wings, but
the administration was all hive wings.
There were prickly guards at the doors
and the walls were thick, with no windows
and no sunlight at all.
Students crowded the narrow corridors
quiet and listless.
She was separated from blue and given a
different schedule.
Teachers snapped at her to sit, be quiet
stop asking questions, fold in her tail
eat silently, wait for permission to
speak, which never came.
By recess, Luna was in the grip of one of
the worst sadnesses she'd ever felt.
She knew she couldn't let herself cry at
school.
And if she escaped out the front gates
and ran back to the safety of the webs
she'd only be in worse trouble later.
But her wrist hurt, and her heart hurt
and she did know how she would make it
through the rest of the day.
Recess, apparently meant standing or
marching around an open balcony on the
side of Cicada Hive.
It was boring, but at least there was
sunlight and wind.
Luna tried to breathe in all the air she
could fit into her lungs.
Bit close to the edge there, aren't you?
An older voice growled.
She turned and saw one of the high wing
guards approaching a student, who was
looking out at the savannah.
The little silk wing was not all that
close to the balcony railing.
And he blinked up at the hive wing and
confusion.
Me?
he squeaked.
His scales were light pink and lime green
with hints of darker rose inside his wing
buds.
Luna had math class with him.
Glider, if she remembered right.
Seems a little dangerous worm.
The hive wing smirked, looming over the
wingless dragonette, he inched back, and
she stepped closer.
The balcony edge was a few steps behind
him now.
Without any wings, you could tip right
over, and just think how far you'd have
to fall.
All that time to contemplate the giant
splat you'll make at the end.
I don't, don't, I didn't mean to.
Can I please go inside now?
Glider stammered.
He risked a glance over his shoulder as
she crowded him back.
The balcony railing was only as high as
the student's wing buds.
It looked like it had been built as an
afterthought.
Oh, right.
Silkwing dragonettes have no wings.
We should pretend we care about their
safety, but don't waste too much tree
stuff on this since we don't really.
It would not be hard to fall over it.
Or be pushed over it.
We lose at least one dragonette every
year, the hive wing said, in a fake sad
voice.
Poor little brainless worms who aren't
careful enough.
She took another step, and glider
squeaked with fear.
Stop that.
Luna said.
She was startled to hear her own voice
lancing through the silk fog around her.
It felt like bright little flames of
anger were burning holes in her sadness.
Why are you being so mean?
You're scaring him just to be awful?
Most of the other silkwing students
stared at her with wide, terrified eyes.
The hive wing flicked her tail.
We are dangerous looking stinger gleamed
and turned her head slowly to glare at
Luna.
A worm with a voice.
Hissed the guard.
Gross.
No one has ever taught you your place
have they?
Has anyone ever taught you basic
decency?
Luna demanded.
How to be a dragon with a heart?
Or were all your classes about acting
like a pile of poisonous sludge to anyone
smaller than you?
There were audible gasps from the rest of
the class, who started edging away as
fast as they could sidle.
The hive wing stepped toward her and
raised her tail menacingly.
Glider slipped away from the railing and
bolted back into the school, but the
guard didn't notice.
Now the little worms end up on
misbehaviors way.
The hive wing snarled.
But I get to paralyze you with my tail
toxin first.
I hear it's quite painful.
Oh, no!
shouted a voice on the far side of the
balcony.
Everyone hustled out of the way as the
guard whirled around.
The shouting dragonette was a little bit
older than Luna.
He was dark blue, with several small
white triangular scales and larger orange
splotches.
And he was standing on the railing of the
balcony.
I got you close to the edge, he yelled.
I wasn't careful enough.
I was just wandering around, exactly like
a worm with no brains, and suddenly I
ended up here on this railing.
Oh no, the horror.
I'm probably going to go splat.
I'm such a brainless worm.
Tragic day.
Poor world.
What are you going to do without sword
tail?
The hive wing guard goggled at him.
Luna could not imagine what her own face
was doing.
If only someone had warned me about going
Splat!
The dragon had howled.
If only some brilliant hive wing had
reminded me I have no wings and should be
careful in tall places.
Alas, alack, woe and despair.
Get down from there.
The hive wing snapped furiously.
Get down right now.
Luna saw a strange flare of something in
the hive wing's eyes.
And she suddenly realized that the guard
was never intending to push glider over
the edge.
The hivewing wanted to scare them and
prove her power over them.
But if any of them actually fell, she'd
be in big trouble.
Get down from here?
Swordell echoed, looking thoroughly
befuddled.
But how?
Which way do I go?
I'm much too stupid to figure this out
myself.
He took a wobbling step along the railing
and flailed around as though he couldn't
get his balance.
The hive wing charged over and yanked him
onto the safety of the floor.
What are you playing at?
She snarled.
You're going straight to the headmaster
and you too. she barked, pointing at
Luna.
I know you know the way, the hive wing
added, scowling at sword tail.
I do, Sortail said cheerfully.
He sauntered over and bumped Luna's side
with a grin.
Come along, troublemaker.
Luna glanced around the balcony, but
everyone else was studiously avoiding her
gaze.
Why hadn't any of them stuck up for
Glider or tried to stop the guards
bullying?
Were they all too scared?
The dark blue dragonette led the way into
the school and down a couple of levels
then stopped in a deserted corridor and
sat down, beaming at her.
That was wild, he said.
You are boggers.
Me?
Luna protested, but she couldn't help
smiling back.
You're the one who nearly ended up a silk
wing pancake on the savannah.
I'm surprised she didn't shove you over
the way you were carrying on.
They're getting used to me, he said with
a shrug.
Yelling at a guard on your 1st day
though?
What's the plan for day two?
Drawing trees all over the walls?
No, wait.
Announcing at lunch that you're starting
a rebellion against Queen Wasp?
He must have seen something in her face
because he added quickly, I'm just
kidding.
Don't do that.
I mean, save it for day 5 at least.
Luna giggled, and realized this was the
lightest she'd felt since stepping into
Silkworm Hall.
I'm pretty sure announcing your rebellion
isn't the best way to start, she said.
Mine will be stealthier than that.
In fact, I just recruited you. and you
didn't even notice.
Really?
he said.
I'm leading a secret rebellion now?
No, no, I'm leading it, she said.
You're the comic relief.
He laughed.
That sounds about right.
I'm SwordTail, by the way.
Oh, I know, she said.
The one this poor world would miss so
terribly.
Very dramatic.
I'm Luna.
It is thrilling to meet you, Luna.
Sortail dipped his head.
I'm so excited there's finally someone
here who might cause even half as much
trouble as I do.
Speaking of which, I guess we'd better
get to the headmaster, Luna said with a
sigh.
Let's not and say we did.
Swordell suggested.
The guards never check if we actually
make it there.
They just want us out from under their
own claws.
Have you seen the art room yet?
The art room?
Luna echoed, her spirits floating up to
the ceiling.
It's the best part of the day, he said.
I thought you might like something to
look forward to.
Yes, please, she said.
She followed him around the corner, and
threw a wide doorway into a huge room
that was covered in weavings.
Looms were set up all over the space.
Most of them with partly finished
projects, waving little rainbow and white
tendrils at her.
There were still no windows, but one
entire wall was covered with a giant
woven skyscape, bright blue, with golden
clouds and sunlight, and 100s of dragons
in flight, most of them silk wings, Luna
noticed.
She stepped closer to the skyscape, hardly
able to breathe.
This was what she wanted to do with her
life.
Make things so beautiful, they could fix
a dragon's heart.
She wanted to use her own talons and silk
to weave tapestries as powerful as
sunshine.
She wanted her art to reach into other
dragons and lift the clouds away, to give
them a reason to spread their wings and
keep flying.
This tapestry was the world as it could
be.
All these silk wings were free.
Luna knew it.
She felt it all through her scales.
Maybe the hive wings couldn't tell when
they looked at it, but Luna knew this was
the world she dreamed of.
Miss Clorin did that, Sortell said.
She's the art teacher, and a silk wing
obviously.
It's amazing, Luna said reverently.
Almost as good as mine, Sortell said
cuffing up his chest and strutting over
to a display, where a small blue and
orange tapestry hung.
It looked as though a spider had gotten
tangled in the threads and run amok
leaving trails of white zigzags all over
the blocky background.
Oh, uh, Luna said.
Very um...
Would you believe there are people who
can't read this?
Sortel said, poking the zigzags.
Luna squinted at it.
Those are letters?
she asked.
It says sword tail, he declared
indignantly.
Very clearly.
Of course, yes, clearly, she agreed.
She touched one of the empty looms, her
claws yearning to strum the chords.
When can I start a weaving?
Probably today, he said.
It's one of our daily classes.
Apparently weaving is one of the few
things we're good for, so we'd better
learn how to do it well.
Lucky for us, Ms. Clorin is great.
Don't tell any hive wings, or they'll
probably take her away.
Mustn't let those wingless dragonettes
have any fun or joy.
I hate that, Luna burst out.
Why is it like that?
Why do they want us to be miserable?
Why can't we decide for ourselves where
we go to school or what we study, or who
our teachers are, or whether we have
windows in our classrooms by all the
moons?
I don't know, he said, really looking at
her.
Because it's always been that way?
Nope, she said.
Not before the tree wars, it wasn't.
Whoa.
Didn't you start school today?
he asked.
How do you already know more history
stuff than I do?
I listen to my moms when they think I'm
asleep, Luna said.
Silkwings used to have our own queen and
our own cities in the webs between the
trees.
Huh, he said.
And then.
And then Queen Wasp said we couldn't, and
knocked down all the trees, and killed
all the leaf wings, and told us we had to
come live in these sunless termite mounds
and do everything the hive wings say from
now on, because of some stupid old book
of prophecies.
Ha, Swordtell said, you are going to be
trouble, aren't you?
I don't care if I am, Luna said.
I think they need to know how awful they
are, and we need to figure out how to fix
everything.
All right, he said, coming to lean
against her empty loom, his dark blue
eyes shining.
All right, what?
she said.
All right.
I'm in, he said.
I'm with you.
Sign me up for fixing everything.
Thinking about it now.
Made Luna's heart feel like it was made
of flame silk.
The brightest burning kind.
Soretail was on her side from the moment
they met.
He always threw himself into danger to
protect her, deflecting the punishment
onto himself whenever she made a hive
wing angry.
His noise covered her tracks, and kept
their attention while she found the
chrysalis.
That was why he'd ended up on
misbehavior's way multiple times, and she
never had.
But he couldn't stand by her now.
She was alone, and he was in danger.
And I don't have time to be sad.
I can't be an extra problem when our
problems are so big already.
Luna sighed.
She could tell by her internal clock that
it was well into nighttime when they
finally heard the patter of footsteps
returning.
Red?
Sky cried.
Ren, Ren, Ren, are you all right?
Of course I am, she answered from the
human sledge.
What could happen to me?
I am invisible, which also means it's
going to be tough to ask these humans for
help, but it makes spying on them pretty
easy.
Help me down.
Rens gets to quick map with water on the
floor for them, showing the path that
went from behind the wall, down through
some tunnels, to a central human cave
village.
There are a lot of people there, Ren
said.
I think it's actually bigger than
talisman, the village where I grew up
although it's hard to tell because it's
kind of like a rabbit warren.
A bit like valor, sky.
Oh, dear, Skye said, I hope the humans
here are nicer than Ivy's dad.
Luna had no idea what they were talking
about.
Did you see the abyss?
she asked.
No.
Ren answered ruefully.
And nobody mentioned one the whole time I
was there either.
These might not be the same humans Queen
Snowfall saw in her vision.
You mean, you think there are other
humans in Pentala?
Cricket asked.
More cave villages?
Probably, Ren said.
We are kind of everywhere, if you look
hard enough.
I'll keep spying on these ones for now
and see if they say anything about it.
The one we saw is named Axolotl.
She said the name in human.
Luna wasn't sure what the dragon
translation would be.
Is it a boy human or girl human?
Sky asked.
Neither?
Both?
We'd have to ask them, Ren said.
They use they and them pronouns.
Like that traveling librarian we met, Skye
remember?
Sage.
Oh, right, Skye said.
What's in Axolotl?
He managed the human word better than
Luna would have, but it still sounded
very weird coming from a dragon's mouth.
It's kind of a cave salamander, Ren
said.
There were a few around the village.
The creature she described didn't sound
familiar to Luna, but after a moment of
listening, Cricket said, oh, an exolotl
in dragon.
Luna still wasn't sure what that was, but
Bullfrog made an, ah, yes, kind of
noise.
Did you figure out how Axolotl has a
dragon book?
Cricket asked.
No, I think it's a secret from the other
humans, Ren guessed.
I'll follow them again tomorrow.
Hopefully someone will mention an abyss
eventually.
The others decided to sleep in the cavern
but Luna crept back out to the sea facing
cave and spent the night there, despite
the cold and wet.
She wanted to be there in case their
friends arrived.
If finding Axolotl and the cave village
meant they were one step closer to the
abyss, then they really needed sundo, and
ideally, moon and lynx and all the others
too.
She didn't sleep much.
She kept jerking awake, thinking she'd
heard sundew's voice, but it was only
ever the waves on the beach, or rain
dripping down the rocks.
The next day and the next, Wren went back
into the tunnels to study the Pentalon
humans.
Axolotl returned to their ledge twice in
that time.
It was fascinating to watch the little
human sitting for so long, peering at the
dragon book.
Cricket pointed out that Axolotl was
riding in the other human sized book, as
if they were taking notes.
I think they're trying to translate the
dragon, she whispered to Luna.
Isn't that brilliant?
I knew our pental in humans would be just
as clever as the ones in the distant
kingdoms.
Do you think Axolotl snuck into one of
the hives to get that book?
That would mean they're really brave
too.
I wonder what they think of dragons.
Do you think they'll like us?
On the 3rd day?
Still, no sign of sunduin links.
Axolotl arrived earlier than usual, and
sat down with a sigh, looking tired.
At least, Luna thought so, although they
didn't have wings to droop, or a long
listless tail, which were the signs that
might have tipped off Luna's friends
about her own emotional state if they'd
been able to see her.
At least invisibility meant she only had
to keep her voice sounding happy.
Ren had been eating breakfast with them
but they all cautiously hid or wolfed
down their food when they heard axolotl
coming.
Sky lifted Wren up to crouch on the ledge
beside the curious human.
Axolotl pulled out the dragon book and
flipped it open again, trailing one of
their long, thin appendages, like a claw
but not in the least bit dangerous, down
the page.
It looks like a book about trees, Ren
called down.
Axolotl turned the page and she added
Hang on.
In this picture, the trees are burning.
Maybe it's a history of the tree wars?
Cricket guest.
Our histories didn't have illustrations
Luna said grumbly.
Even our books couldn't have any pictures
of trees in them.
She edged as close as she could, craning
to see, and felt cricket and sky doing
the same on either side of her.
All at once, she felt a weird tingling in
her talons, as though one of the less
flammable forms of flame silk was pulsing
through her palms.
She glanced down to make sure she hadn't
unleashed some flame silk by accident.
But no, her front claws were right there
propped against the stone column she was
leaning against, looking perfectly normal
and not glowy.
Wait, her claws.
She could see them.
Luna looked up into Cricket's startled
eyes.
Cricket's face, right there in front of
her.
And right at that moment, Axolotl raised
their head and discovered Wren, suddenly
crouching next to them out of nowhere, and
4 dragons crowded around the ledge, gazing
straight at them.
Axolotl shrieked, leaped to their feet
tripped over Wren, bonked into the wall
pinwheeled backward, bounced off
Bullfrog's nose, shrieked again, and made
a run for the tunnels.
Bullfrog calmly lunged over the rock
shelf, and trapped the human under one
big talon.
Eck!
Wren shouted at the mudwing.
Stop that.
Get off them.
She ran over and grabbed Bullfrog's
massive front leg, trying to yank it up.
It's fun, Bullfrog said impassively.
I'm not hurting it.
That is a lot of yelling for someone
who's not hurt, Skye said, covering his
ears.
Because they're scared, Ren snapped.
Wouldn't you be?
If a human and 4 dragons literally
appeared out of thin air and then stepped
on you?
I'm not stepping on it, Bullfrog
observed.
I'm preventing it from leaving, that's
all.
Poor axolotl.
Tell them we won't hurt them.
Luna said to Ren, that we're friendly
dragons.
Two of us are vegetarians.
I think that would be a lot more
comforting without a giant carnivore
standing on them, but I'll try, Ren
said.
She crouched next to Axolotl and said
something in the human language.
It took a moment for Axolotl to hear her
over there yelling, but finally they went
quiet, and their expression went from
panicked, to panicked, but also curious.
Ren kept talking rapidly, waving her
hands at the dragons.
Okay, now get off them, she said to
Bullfrog in Dragon, shoving at the
Mudwings talons.
But then it might escape.
Bullfrog said placidly.
If they still want to do that, we let
them.
Ren said.
She threw her shoulder under one of
Bullfrog's claws and lifted it as much as
she could.
Underneath, Axolotl tried to wiggle
free.
Because Hugh Dragons are not actually
monsters is the point I am trying to make
and you are kind of making the opposite
point right now.
Bullfrog wrinkle just snout skeptically.
Expressions.
Luna hadn't realized how much she'd
missed seeing facial expressions.
But he lifted his talons and stepped back
down to the cave floor.
Axolotl sat up, feeling their limbs as
though making sure everything was
intact.
They looked at Wren with wide, astonished
eyes and burbled something.
What did they say?
Cricket asked eagerly.
They can't believe I can talk to dragons
Ren said.
They've always wanted to do that.
They want to know what you're saying.
Sky laughed and said something human
sounding.
Axolotl gasped, pointed at him, turned to
Ren, waved their hands around, and
pointed to sky again.
Now what did they say?
Cricket demanded.
This is going to take a while, Ren
observed, rubbing her forehead.
Wait, Luna said.
Why are we suddenly not invisible
anymore?
Maybe the magic wore off?
Cricket guessed.
I thought Lynx said that wouldn't happen
Luna said.
She jumped to her feet.
Maybe Sundu made us all visible because
she's here.
I'll go check.
Meanwhile, I will stay here and explain
my entire life to yet another strange
human.
Ren said, sitting down next to Axolotl.
Luna dashed back into the tunnels and
raced through the winding rock corridors
to the beach cave.
Outside.
It was pouring again.
Curtains of rain billowing into the open
space.
Luna ran out into the storm and looked up
at the sky, then whirled around, searching
the beach.
No sun do.
No links.
There was nobody there at all.
Chapter 8.
Axolotl says they've heard of a village
that worships an abyss.
Cricket said to Luna, when she returned
to the Dragon Teeth Cavern, wet
bedraggled, and disappointed.
Cricket's eyes were glowing behind her
spectacles, and she was practically
bouncing on her talons.
They said, they can guide us there.
If we translate the dragon book for them
Luna, isn't this wonderful?
They're willing to help us.
Maybe they'll like us so much.
They'll want to be my best friend, just
like Skye and Wren.
And then we can learn each other's
language and hang out all the time.
I mean, after we save the world, and
rescue Blue.
She finished, her expression sobering.
The human says, we can head for the abyss
tomorrow, Bullfrog added.
He was sitting by the entrance to the
cavern, as far from the humans as
possible, with a mildly grumpy look on
his face.
Lune guest he had been ordered over here
by Ren, so he wouldn't scare Axolotl any
more than he already had.
Over by the ledge, Sky and Wren and
Axolotl, were chatting away, like Silk
Wings having a day off picnic in the
mosaic garden.
Tomorrow?
Luna echoed.
But we can't.
We have to wait for the others.
Bullfrog froed his browadder.
Sundew said not to wait.
And their days late, Cricket agreed.
I wonder if maybe making us visible
again?
Was Sundew trying to tell us we should go
on without them.
She did say we should look for the abyss
if they didn't show up.
But we won't have any idea what to do if
we find it, Luna said.
She tried to keep her voice light, instead
of letting the panic seep into it.
She hoped her face looked reasonable
rather than like a tapestry of worries.
Other dragons, especially hive wings
didn't like her panic voice or worry
face.
She'd noticed in her 6 years of life
showing her nerves did not make them
kinder to her.
Too often, it made them more irritable
and impatient instead.
Not sore tail.
Sortail is never impatient with me.
And not blue.
I can't even imagine what an irritable
blue would look like.
If they were here.
They'd understand why I'm so worried.
You're right.
Cricket said unexpectedly.
She poked one claw into a crack in the
rock floor and wiggled it back and
forth.
In fact, Luna would have to say cricket
definitely had a worry face on.
She'd never seen a hive wing with a worry
face before.
I mean, I know exactly how you feel
Luna.
I didn't think I'd have to do any
decision making or fighting while we had
Sundu and tsunami and moon with us.
I wouldn't send me to save the world.
We have no idea what we're going to find
down there, and it's completely
terrifying.
Bullfrog grunted, and they both turned to
look at him.
He paused for a long moment and then said
Same.
How come cricket doesn't mind spilling
out all her worries and fears?
In front of dragons, she hardly knows.
That's not a hive wing thing?
Is this what Blue likes about her?
That she shares all her feelings before
he has to guess?
Here's what I tell myself.
Cricket went on, touching one of Luna's
talons lightly.
We're going looking for the truth.
That's something I can do.
I can't discover things.
Whatever is down there.
Moon and Snowfall think we need to know
about it.
So that's all we're doing, at least in my
head, flying into the abyss, finding
answers, flying out again.
What if the answers eat us?
Luna asked.
Then we hope the next dragons do better.
Cricket said.
Maybe we can leave a message for sun do
and links, so they know where to look for
us.
But we can't just sit here, not when Blue
needs us, right?
When we have a next step that might take
us to him?
Don't we have to take it?
Even if we can't see the end of the path
yet?
Luna covered her face with her talons.
Cricket was right, which was very
annoying, because Luna would have
preferred nearly any other dragon to pull
her back into her, let's do this state.
But it was true.
They couldn't stay here in this cave
watching the rain, waiting for someone
more heroic to show up.
Blue and Soretail and all the other silk
wings needed them to keep going.
All right, she said.
How do we leave a message?
Ooh, let's think, Cricket said, bouncing
to her feet.
She picked up a rock, put it back down
picked up another rock, tapped it on the
floor, and scratched her head.
What are you doing?
Luna asked.
Thinking.
Cricket said, unselfconsciously.
It has to be something sundew and links
will find, but nobody else.
We don't want patrolling hive wings to
see it by accident.
So, we can't paint on the wall of the
cave, Luna said.
Or a carve a giant arrow pointing
wherever we're going, Cricket added.
Because then anyone might find it, Luna
finished.
What should the message even say?
Cricket wondered.
Find a human and follow it?
I wonder if there's something more
specific we can write.
I'll tell Ren to ask Axolotl.
This was an obvious excuse for cricket to
talk to, or at least near Axolotl again
but Luna didn't stop her.
She spun out a coil of glowing flame silk
and held it in her palms, drying some of
the leftover raindrops, and wondering if
she could use it to hide a message
somehow.
They say it's not far from a giant lake
in the south.
Cricket said, bounding back to Luna with
her spectacles askew.
Must be Lake Scorpion, right?
We can put that in the message.
Did you have any more ideas?
I haven't yet.
Let's think.
Bit noisy for thinking.
Bullfrog observed placidly.
Sorry, Cricket said it once.
I'll shush.
They thought quietly for a long moment.
A code?
Luna thought.
A trail of scraps of flame silk, like
bread crumbs to follow?
Hmm.
Bullfrog said after a long time.
Leaf wings like...
Plants.
They do like plants, Muno cried, jumping
to her feet, and hive wings barely notice
them.
We need a plant to help us.
Bullfrogs squinted at her.
A plan to what now?
Sundew can talk to plants.
Cricket explained, equally excited.
If there is an unexpected plant in the
caves, she'll notice.
Then we bury the message near its roots
and hope the plant tells Sun to about
it.
The plant.
Bullfrog said slowly.
Will.
Tell Sundo?
Something like that, Cricket said.
Bullfrog looked skeptical, but he
followed them out into the rain and stood
guard, while they dug up a hearty looking
violet from a cliff top overhead.
Cricket's talons were gentle as she
extricated it and all its roots.
She cradled dirt around the flower's
tendrils as they flew down to the cave
and then they planted the little purple
flower in the wet sand near the back
wall.
Poor thing, Cricket said.
This water is too salty for it.
I don't think it's going to like it
here.
Sundew will move it somewhere safe when
she finds it, Luna said.
She'll take care of it.
Sorry, little flower.
She touched one of the leaves lightly, and
then she stepped back and brought forth a
twist of burning flame silk.
Sky and Wren had found a wide, flat piece
of driftwood on the beach, and Luna
burned their message into its smooth gray
surface.
Gone to find the abyss near Lake
Scorpion.
Meet us there.
Then Cricket dug a hole near the flower's
roots and buried the message.
Luna felt like there should be more to
say.
As though the others had been gone a 1000
years, and needed to be told about
everything they'd missed.
She wanted to tell them to hurry, to be
careful, to avoid hive wings, and be kind
to any humans they saw.
But they knew all that.
They would be here already, if they
could.
The next morning, Axolotl unexpectedly
appeared with another human.
This one wore an outer wrapping that was
almost entirely made of stolen dragon
silk.
Orange and silver strips wound around the
newcomer's pale brown limbs, and more
were tied into its long dark hair.
Like axolotl.
This human looked like it rarely saw the
sun.
The glow of Luna's flame silk made it
blink rapidly and shield its eyes.
This is ocelot, Ren explained, after some
back and forth chatter in human.
She's offered to keep watch for our
missing dragons.
If we burn another message, she says
she'll give it to them.
She will?
Cricket said.
Isn't that really brave of her?
Has she been around dragons before?
Ren repeated the question in human, and
ocelot laughed.
She held up her arms, draped in dragon
silk, and twirled as she answered.
She says, she steals from dragons all the
time.
Ren translated, sounding amused.
And she's not scared of them.
I like her.
Still, Luna said.
Tell her to stay away from hive wings, and
silk wings.
Anyone who looks like me or Cricket.
Only show herself to a green dragon or a
white dragon.
Sundew and lynx won't eat her.
Tell her only trust dragons with 2 wings
right now, not 4 Cricket agreed.
Aren't there some leaf wings under wasps
control too?
Ren asked.
Oh.
Right.
Luna's wings drooped.
She'd forgotten about that.
She'd forgotten that wasp had her claws
sunk deep into even the fiercest tribal
on Pentala.
She felt a light pat on one of her claws
and looked up to find Axolotl, giving her
what she thought might be a reassuring
expression.
Axolotl says, it'll be all right, Ren
said.
Ocelot is smart.
She'll know which dragons are safe, and
who should get the message.
Ren pointed to Skye's wings, and
bullfrog's wings, and explained something
at length in the human language.
Luna burned the same message again on a
new piece of driftwood, and tried to take
comfort in the idea that they'd left a
backup message, that sundew just had to
find the flower or the human, the violet
or ocelot, and she'd be able to follow
them.
But was it enough?
Sundew.
Where are you?
It is very wet outside, Skye said.
Bending depeared axolotl's layers of
wrapping.
Ren, this poor little human is going to
get all slippery, and slide off my back
if we try to fly right now, and sick.
Don't fluffy mammals get sick if you get
them too wet?
What do we do?
Can we wrap you both in waterproof leaves
or something?
He got a mischievous look in his eyes.
Fancy umbrella leaf hats?
You are a ridiculous dragon, Ren said
sternly.
We are not going outside.
Axolotl knows a way through the caves
that will get us most of the way there
which is safer than trying to fly with
dragons everywhere looking for us.
Sky looked disappointed.
And maybe a little nervous, Luna
thought.
We're going underground?
Like, a lot farther underground, he
said.
I'm afraid that is where most people keep
their dark, scary abysses, Ren said, with
an affectionate grin.
On the one talon, it was a relief that
they didn't have to try to fly in the
rain.
On the other.
Luna had never felt more claustrophobic
as she followed Axolotl through the
underground tunnels.
She had figured out a way to wind glowing
flame silk threads around her horns.
They cast a circle of light that
illuminated the stone pressing in all
around the dragons, which was both
comforting and unsettling.
Most of the tunnels were so narrow that
her antennae kept brushing the ceiling
and she couldn't unfold her wings all the
way.
But axolotl strode forward confidently
chatting with Ren.
They seemed to know their way, even
without any flame silk light, or Wren's
torch.
They kept one paw outstretched, lightly
brushing the walls, and occasionally
stopped to consult the notebook they had
brought with them.
Cricket also had Axolotl's dragon book
tucked in the pouch with her blowgun
darts.
She'd promised to help translate it
during their rest stops.
Axolotl seemed like a human version of
cricket in some ways, as far as
Lunicatel.
They were obsessed with the idea that
dragons could read, and fascinated by
what they might find in a dragon book
exactly the way cricket had been obsessed
with human books, ever since she found
out about them.
It's not just a history of the tree
wars.
She said to Luna, laid on their 3rd day
of travel through the caves.
As they navigated a slippery rock pile
with a small chasm off to the left.
A droplet of water splashed onto
cricket's glasses, and she paused for a
moment to wipe them dry on her pouch.
Luna waited with her, and behind them
Bullfrog stopped as well.
Cricket set the spectacles back on her
snout.
It's a whole history of the world, she
breathed.
Books like this all vanished from my
school library. especially if I ever
happened to find one.
The hive wing philosophy is that
everything started with the tree wars, and
you'd better not ask any questions about
anything before that.
Luna could imagine that had been a hard
rule for cricket to follow.
Is there anything in there about Silkwing
villages before the tree wars?
She asked, as they kept walking.
Lots, Cricket said, with illustrations.
They were beautiful.
What about Pyrea?
Bullfrog asked.
Stuff about us.
Yes, although the book calls you the
distant kingdoms, like we always have, but
there's a whole chapter about Clearsight
and another that goes further back to the
dragons that 1st came over here, and the
whole legend of the hive.
Luna shivered.
The legend of the hive was her new least
favorite story, and this shadowy K was
not a great place to be reminded of it.
She could too easily imagine clouds of
mind controlled bats swarming their faces
or hordes of cave centipedes scuttling
over their claws.
Up ahead, Sky and the 2 humans had made
it past the chasm, and were resting near
a pool in the rocks.
Strands of a weird, sticky substance hung
down from the ceiling, with a flying
insect trapped in one of them, still
flapping weekly.
Lune gave the translucent goopy threads a
wide berth as she approached the others.
It's after dark, she said, sitting down
beside Skye.
Should we all sleep soon?
Are the humans tired?
Sky twisted to stare around the cave?
With a befuddled expression, then looked
back at her.
How do you know it's after dark?
he asked.
I can't tell if we've been down here for
2 minutes or 9 days.
Oh, it's a silkwing thing, Luna said.
We always know what time of day it is.
It had taken her internal clock a little
while to adjust when she landed in Pyria
and then to adjust back once they reached
Pantala, but by now, she felt properly
synced up with the sky.
Wow, very cool, Skye said with a smile.
We can go a little farther if you can, Ren
said.
Axolotl says there's a drier cave, where
we can make a fire and spend the night.
All right, Luna said.
And cricket and bullfrog agreed.
They set off again, squeezing into yet
another tunnel that seemed just barely
big enough for dragons.
Luna could feel cricket edging along
behind her, and she turned her head
slightly to see the hive wing.
What else is in that book?
She asked. hoping to distract herself
from the tons of rock currently between
her and the sky.
Let's think.
Well, I haven't read this part yet, but
there's a short section on something
called the scorching.
Cricket answered.
Behind them, Bullfrog grunted.
Course there is, he said.
It's in every boring history book.
Not ours, Cricket said.
I've never heard of it.
Have you, Luna?
Luna shook her head.
Oh my goodness.
Bullfrog, tell me everything.
What do your books say about it?
Not much.
Bullfrog said.
After a moment, he must have felt the
waves of disapproval coming off cricket
because he added, Um, it's how we got
tribes and kingdoms and stuff.
It is?
Crickets said.
What?
How?
Weren't there always kingdoms and
tribes?
Luna had reached the end of the tunnel
and wiggled out onto a wider ledge that
sloped down to a cave floor.
She started to slide down it and bonked
her head on a stalactite.
Ow, she muttered, rubbing her forehead as
she skidded to a stop at the bottom.
Bullfrog and Cricket slid down next to
her, and they started after the light of
Ren's torch, already more than halfway
across the cave.
Bullfrog, Cricket prodded him.
Say more things.
Um, he said, sounding more stumped than
annoyed.
I don't remember much.
Not my favorite subject. history.
But, Cricket prompted.
You do remember...
What?
I guess there were more scavengers back
then?
he said.
Like.
Over 5000 years ago, and no tribes.
Dragons lived mostly on their own, I
think.
And then a scavenger made a dragon real
mad.
So the dragon ate him.
And then the dragon burned a bunch of
stuff and got some other dragons to eat a
bunch more scavengers and burn a bunch
more stuff.
And then they made a kingdom.
And that was the scorching.
He thought for a moment, and then added
yup.
Wow, Luna said, those poor humans.
Bullfrog scratched his head.
I mean, he said.
I think they started it?
One human, you said.
Luna pointed out.
One human made a dragon mad.
So the dragons ate and burned everybody
else?
That's kind of intense.
I wonder what the human did, Cricket
said.
What could make a dragon that angry?
Stealing treasure?
Scaring away prey?
Bullfrog guest, like.
Really good prey.
Probably cows.
Maybe it killed someone the dragon cared
about.
Luna asked.
Hmm.
Bullfrog said.
Pretty hard for a scavenger to kill a
dragon.
He paused for another moment, then added
I guess one managed with Queen Oasis
though.
What?
Cricket said avidly.
Who?
No, Bullfrog said. pointing at her.
No, no, no.
Not your walking history book, me.
He hurried away to catch up to Ren and
Skye.
Any idea?
Cricket asked Luna.
Then sighed when Luna shook her head.
Doesn't it drive you mad?
All the things there are to know, and how
much we don't know, and how hard it is to
find things out?
I guess, on the scale of all our problems
that one doesn't bother me so much.
Luna admitted.
They reached the bottom of a sheer cliff
and spread their wings to fly up to the
top of it, where a sky had already lifted
the humans.
It would be nice to find a book called
What's in the Abyss and what to do about
it, though, wouldn't it?
Cricket said wistfully.
Yes, Luna agreed.
And also, how to free your mind
controlled friends. 101 ways to kill an
evil queen, without, like, having to be
all mean or violent about it, Cricket
suggested, and Luna was surprised into
laughing.
Do you worry about that too?
She asked Cricket.
How to defeat bad guys without being bad
guys?
Cricket answered.
All the time.
Luna held out her talons.
How do you use a gift like fire to win a
war, but without hurting anyone?
How to care about all dragons?
The way Blue does?
Cricket said as they landed.
But fight them the way sundu would if
they hurt someone?
This was so, almost exactly the thought
Luna had been having, that she reached
out and grabbed Cricket's arm.
Once, Luna and Sortail had been talking
about the Salvation Wall, and he'd said
the exact thing she'd been about to say.
She'd gotten so excited, that she had
jumped on him, yelling, my brain words
words of my head.
That had been their joke ever since.
Whenever they agreed about something, one
of them would declare, my brain words, or
words of my head, and they'd both fall
over laughing.
She came within a breath of shouting, my
brain words, at cricket, before
remembering that was only for sword
tail.
And then she had to stand there for a
moment, eyes closed, until she no longer
felt like she'd been punched in the
stomach.
Are you all right?
Cricket asked.
Yep, Luna said, letting go over.
Still smiling.
No problems here.
Yes, just what you said, exactly.
But mostly, how to save blue and sore
tail.
She turned her wrist up to the ceiling
again, to study the fire gold dots below
her scales.
I will set dragons on fire for them if I
have to.
Me too, Cricket said.
Well, all right, no, I can't.
But I will.
I will.
Throw books at anyone who's mean to them
so there.
Big heavy ones, so watch out, jerks.
All right, Luna thought, hiding a smile.
And for the 1st time she thought, Maybe I
kind of get what Blue sees in this hive
wing.
Between those superpowers, will
definitely get them back, she said.
Today.
Now, she mostly believed it.
She could feel the rainy season fog
fading, and little cracks of sunlight
hope pushing through her brain. ironic
considering she hadn't seen the actual
sun in 3 days.
They had been walking along the cliff top
for a while, under a vast ceiling, studded
with spires and glow worms, when Bullfrog
suddenly stopped, Luna nearly stepped on
his tail.
He said, staring at the inky blackness
beyond the flame silk glow.
Luna and Cricket froze.
Ahead of them, Sky and the humans did the
same.
Was that a flicker of wind in the silent
cave?
Luna's antennae unfurled instinctively
checking for strange vibrations in the
air.
There was something.
A very still distant sound.
Like someone hidden in the spires
overhead, just... breathing.
And then, the hidden something shifted
leaned forward, and began to glide on
silent wings toward them.
Chapter 9.
The humans?
Luna shouted, lunging past bullfrog.
Sky protect the humans.
There was a flurry of shrieks and wing
beats. and muffled cries from Wren and
Axolotl as Skye threw himself on top of
both of them, covering them with his
wings.
Bullfrog rose up on his hind legs, front
claws slashing at the air, hissing.
A dark shape shot over their heads and
smashed into cricket.
She was thrown back against the stone
wall with an awful thud.
Luna whirled and raced over to her.
As the light of her flame silk got closer
she realized the dark shape was a
dragon.
A leaf wing, a large, furious leaf wing
who now had cricket pinned to the floor
with his talons around her neck.
Stop!
Luna yelled.
Don't hurt her.
She's with us.
We're friends.
We're all on the same side.
By all this silk stop it.
She rammed her shoulder into the leaf
wing side, but he only lifted one wing to
glance at her sternly.
Have to make her unconscious, he said.
A little out of breath as Cricket
struggled and kicked at him to protect
us.
No, no, Luna said, understanding what was
happening.
She doesn't have Queen Wasp inside her.
She's the one hive wing who isn't mind
controlled.
Haven't you heard about her?
This is cricket, the one who stole the
book of Clearsight.
Hmm, he said. rings a bell.
He glanced down at her without moving his
talons.
Better saved than sorry, though.
You'd really better stop now, Bullfrog
said, looming up behind Luna.
Or I will have to do some hitting.
The leaf wing looked skeptical.
He was about the same size as the mudwing
and then confused.
He squinted at Bullfrog in the flame silk
light, but didn't stop leaning on
Cricket's throat.
Her flailing was getting weaker, Luna
noticed, with a touch of panic.
What are you?
The leaf wing asked bullfrog.
We're friends of Sundoo, Luna blurted.
Oh, really?
Said the Leaf Wing.
Immediately releasing cricket and taking
a step back, Cricket rolled onto her side
gasping.
Should have mentioned that sooner. he
said, looking down at the high wing
reproachfully.
When?
Cricket managed to croak.
The leaf wing rubbed his chin for a
moment.
Hmm, he said.
Should wear a sign, maybe.
Listing all our friends?
Luna demanded.
Who are you anyway?
How do we know you don't have Queen Wasp
inside you?
He stared at her, and then sat down
heavily.
So it's true, he said, closing his eyes.
The devastation on his face nearly sucked
away all of Luna's anger at him.
That she can infect leaf wings now?
She said gently.
Yes.
And silk wings.
Not us, though, Cricket said, with a
faint wave of her wing at the group of
them.
Not just anyone.
You have to be exposed to the breath of
evil first.
He still looked confused, so Luna added
either by being stabbed with her tail
venom, or breathing in the smoke from
this awful plant.
It's a long story.
Why are you down here?
Cricket asked.
Why aren't you with the other leaf
wings?
Was on a mission, he said morosely, hid
got stuck here.
He pointed at bullfrog.
What is that?
Bullfrog looked as ruffled as Luna had
ever seen him.
I'm not a that, he said.
I'm a mudwing.
This is bullfrog, Luna explained.
He came from the distant kingdoms to help
us, and so did they.
She pointed to where Skye was still lying
flat on top of the humans.
The noises coming from under his wings
sounded decidedly grouchy now.
Skye, you can let them out, she called.
He won't eat them.
You won't eat them, will you?
Eat what?
The leaf wing's eyes went as big as the
moons, as the 2 humans scrambled out from
under Sky's wings.
You.
You have an underground monkey.
Two underground monkeys.
Huh.
Rather think you could spare one, don't
you?
Seems selfish not to share when we are so
hungry.
His teeth gleamed.
They're not provisions, Luna cried.
They're not for eating.
We're not monkeys either.
Wren added in Dragon, sauntering up and
putting her paws on her hips.
The leaf wing flapped his jaw for a while
in a very gratifying way.
It...
You taught it to talk.
He finally managed.
How did you do that?
Oh.
Why did you do that?
Oh, it was quite hard.
Skye said. years of training.
They're very clever mimics though.
Watch this.
Not funny Sky.
Not funny, Skye, Ren said, at almost the
exact same moment.
She frowned at Skye.
Then at the leaf wing.
I'm not a parrot.
I can speak dragon, and you shouldn't eat
any humans.
We're just as smart as you are.
Ha, said the leaf wing.
Ha!
Huh.
This is very odd.
I think I should take you to Hemlock.
He'll sort this out.
He gave Axolotl a measuring look.
What about that one?
You sure I can't eat that one?
You're thick, aren't you?
Ren said.
The Leaf Wing growled resentfully.
Doesn't seem fair, he said.
There's hardly anything I can eat down
here.
Now you're taking a whole species off the
list.
Rude, that is.
I'm pretty sure it's more rude to eat
something that can talk to you, Ren
said.
No earring.
No.
Axolotl suddenly shouted in dragon
popping out from behind Sky's leg, and
then immediately ducking bag.
Sky collapsed in giggles, nearly landing
on the small human, who looked
affronted.
The leaf wing blinked at them.
What?
They mean no eating, Ren said.
Clearly try not to laugh.
We're working on it.
No eating, she growled at Axolotl.
No eating. they growled back.
In a pretty decent dragon accent, Luna
thought.
She'd noticed that Axolotl picked up
written language more quickly than things
they heard.
Cricket had been looking at the book with
them each night, and Axolotl was already
recognizing several letters and a few
words.
If they actually had more time to sit and
study.
Axolotl might be able to communicate with
dragons in writing. more or less within a
month or so.
Wait, Cricket said, struggling to her
feet.
Did you say hemlock?
Sundu's dad?
Are you with Bryony?
and the silk wings that fled bloodworm
hive?
He blinked at her a few times.
How do you know all that?
A dragon in the distant kingdoms had a
vision about all of you, Cricket
explained.
I don't think she mentioned you, though.
The leaf wing drew himself up and looked
annoyed.
I'm pokeweed, he said.
I'm essential to the mission.
Pokweed.
Cricket echoed.
Huh.
Nope.
We are heading for a human settlement
near an abyss, Luna said.
This one is guiding us.
She waved one wing at Axolotl, who was
staying as close to Skye's side as
possible, and making little muttery
dragon like noises.
Oh, what?
Nero what?
Pokweed scratched his head.
An abyss?
A really big dark chasm, Cricket told
him.
Have you seen one of those down here?
Pokweed waved his wings around.
Saw one big dark chasm, isn't it?
This one would be bigger and darker and
more...
Down, Luna said, like way down.
Seems weird.
Pokweed said.
Weird thing to look for.
Unless it's for hiding.
Is that what it's for?
Hiding from WASP?
No, Cricket said.
I mean, we're not sure.
We're hoping there's something in it that
can stop her.
Hmm.
Even more weird.
Pokweed shrugged and turned, waving one
wing.
You explain it to Hemlock.
He won't believe me if I try.
Ren and Axolotl chattered for a moment
inhuman, then climbed on disguise back
and they all flew after Pokweed, through
the vast open cave.
It was a bit hazardous, dodging the
stalactites, but it was a relief to be
flying again after 3 days of walking and
climbing and sliding.
Luna stretched her wings as wide as she
could and shook out her tail.
Pokweed had evidently ventured a long way
from the rest of the group in search of
food.
Luna felt like they were following him
for hours.
Half the time they could fly, but for
much of the journey, they had to crawl
through tunnels or climb through
passageways in the rock.
Pokweed radiated a distinct air of slow
and unimaginative.
But if he'd been willing to explore this
far alone and memorize the way back, Luna
thought he must be braver and smarter
than he seemed.
He wasn't a very good listener though, at
least not to silk wings, hive wings, or
humans.
Maybe he paid more attention when other
leaf wings were talking.
As they dropped down a shaft into a damp
tunnel, Luna's antennae picked up
movement, and murmuring vibrations ahead
of them.
From a distance.
It sounded like wind in a forest, leaves
brushing and whispering ahead of a
storm.
They emerged from the tunnel into a cave
that surrounded an underground lake.
Odd crystalline shapes jutted from the
walls, like tapestries made of
translucent gems instead of silk.
Glow worms dotted the ceiling, like
strange blue constellations, and a faint
phosphorescent glow came from deep under
the surface of the lake.
But those were the only sources of
light.
The murmurs resolved into dragon voices
hushed and flat, and echoing in the
cavernous space.
She couldn't see them all, but Luna's
antennas sensed there were over a 100
dragons in this cave alone, with more
scattered in caves and tunnels that
branched off this one.
I'd weave this place with black silk
thread.
A tapestry all dark from far away.
But with little circles of light in gold
silk, and up close, around each gold silk
circle, you'd find outlines of wings or
tails or dragon faces, maybe in dark gray
silk, hovering all around the lights.
A quartet of small silkwing dragonettes
was sitting near the tunnel on the shore
of the lake, dabbling their talent
listlessly in the water.
They looked up as Pokweed stepped into
the cave, and then they saw Luna, and
their eyes went huge.
Mommy!
The little pink one shouted, leaping to
her feet.
Mommy, there's a dragon with fire on her
head.
Mommy, mommy, she has a fire hat.
I want a fire hat, cried the small orange
one beside her.
Nobody ever lets me set a hat on fire and
put it on my head, not fair.
It's not a hat.
The lime green one barked imperiously.
It is obviously a crown.
I bet she is a fire queen.
The 4th dragonette, who was lavender with
speckles of dark blue and turquoise
bolted straight out to Luna's feet, sat
down, and stared up at her.
He looked a bit like her earliest
memories of blue, between the colors of
his scales, and his trusting expression.
Um, Luna said, hello?
Hi.
The dragonette said softly.
The reflection of the flame silk glowed
in his awestruck eyes.
Luna realized more dragonettes were
cantering her way, all of them with
similar bedazzled expressions.
Behind them came several grown silk wings
who looked more tired than anything else
but at least a few looked happy to see
her, she thought.
Thank the moons, said one of the older
dragons, clasping her front talons
together.
The last of the flame silk we brought
with us faded days ago.
And it's been so dark, said the Pink
Dragonette.
I do not like it's so dark.
Yes, you do, said the orange one.
You said yesterday that it wasn't so bad
and you called me a Freddy slug.
I'm the one who doesn't like the dark.
If anyone's getting a fire hat, it should
be me, because you're mean.
You were mean first, shouted the pink
dragonette.
Mommy, tell him he's the mean one.
The dark is whispery.
Breathed the dragonette at Luna's feet
inching a bit closer to her.
She noticed that he had a little star
shaped white scar on his forehead, over
his left eye, and another on his shoulder
near his right wing bud.
Poor little dragon, she thought.
What happened to you?
He also wore 2 of the heavy wrist cuffs
instead of just one.
She gently lifted one of his talons to
read the inscription on the cuff, Weaver
Hall.
That must be his school.
The other said, construction apprentice.
Apprentice.
He can't be more than 2 years old.
How could a dragon this tiny be part of a
construction crew already?
She knew, from Swordtail's stories, that
it was a dangerous, exhausting job
working with the tree stuff on the
hives.
Maybe that was how this little dragon had
gotten his scars.
He gazed up at her hopefully, as she set
his talon down again.
I have never met an actual flame silk
said another dragon, who had wings, but
didn't look much older than Luna.
Did you really make that?
I did, Luna said.
Um, hi, I'm Luna.
Luna.
A pale yellow dragon limped forward, and
the others stepped back respectfully to
let her through.
The ones Sore Tail and Blue were looking
for?
Tao?
Cricket yelped.
She bounded past Luna, and threw her
wings around the startled yellow silk
wing, the closest dragons in the crowd
saw her hive wing scales, and jumped back
hissing.
Cricket?
Tao cried.
No way.
How are you here?
She turned to the other silk wings
putting one wing protectively around
cricket.
This is the hive wing who found out the
secret of the mind control, the one who
told everyone the truth about the Book of
Clearsight.
Remember the paint on the posters in
Jewel Hive?
She's been fighting Queen Waspel longer
than most of you.
Luna felt a weird little stab of guilt
that this silk wing was quicker to defend
cricket than she had ever been.
Then again, it was reassuring to see that
Blue wasn't the only Silkwing who liked
and trusted cricket.
You've read the Book of Clearsight?
One of the silk wings asked Cricket.
Did you really see Queen Wasp stabbing
eggs in the hatchery?
asked another.
She can't get inside your mind at all?
All this excitement about us, Luna said
ruefully to Cricket.
And they haven't even seen the humans or
the Pyria dragons yet.
She looked down and saw that the
dragonette at her feet had, in fact
noticed sky and bullfrog.
He had edged close enough to her that he
was almost sitting on her talon, and he
was now staring past her at the other 2
dragons, who were hanging back in the
shadows of the tunnel.
What we really want to know is what's
happening up there.
Tao said, taking one of cricket's talons
in her own.
Is anyone else alive?
What happened to the leaf wings?
We have a lot to tell you, Cricket said.
Is there someone in charge of everyone
here?
Depends on who you ask, Tao said, rolling
her eyes.
The leaf wings think they're in charge.
Morpho keeps insisting he should make all
the decisions.
The bloodworm hive silk wings have their
own chrysalis, which it turns out was way
bigger than ours, and Lady Jewel and Lady
Scarab are here too.
But we don't have to listen to any hive
wings anymore.
A green gray dragon said mutinously.
Now that they don't have their wide-eyed
stinger clawed goons to push us around
Lady Jewel is the reason we all escaped.
Tao said stiffly.
She's not our queen, but we don't have to
be rotten to her.
Chrysalis?
Luna said hopefully.
I was going to join the cicada hive
chrysalis after my metamorphosis.
Are any of them here?
Tao shook her head.
Sorry, little dragon.
No one from Cicada Hive, as far as I
know.
Pokweed suddenly appeared, with 2 other
leaf wings and a feather gray silk wing.
Luna hadn't even realized he'd been
gone.
Oh, wow.
Hello, said the smaller leaf wing.
Visitors from the outside world.
Please tell us you come with good news.
I'm Bryany.
This is Grayling, and this grumpy face is
hemlock.
Stern face.
Hemlock corrected her.
Not grumpy.
This is an intimidating face.
Pokweed says you know sundu, he said
turning to Luna.
Is she all right?
She...
Was when we left her.
Luna said honestly.
She was supposed to meet up with us a few
days ago, but she didn't show.
We left her a message.
We were hoping she follows us here.
We've been to the distant kingdoms
Cricket said.
We came back with dragons to help us, and
underground monkeys who can talk, and a
vision about an abyss that we have to
find.
Tao looked too astonished to speak.
Bryony and Hemlock exchanged bewildered
glances.
Let's sit, Bryany said, waving to a
circle of boulders nearby.
We want to hear everything.
Luna started to turn towards Sky and
Bullfrog, but the little dragonette
suddenly jumped forward and wrapped his
tiny claws around her leg.
He pressed his face into her scales and
whispered something.
Oh goodness, Luna said.
Um, hey, cutie, can I have my leg back?
Please let me stay with you, he mumbled.
I'll be really good.
I promise.
I won't be any trouble, and I won't
complain about anything, I promise
promise.
Luna felt a stab of sad, familiar
sympathy.
Won't someone be looking for you?
she asked, touching the top of his head
lightly.
The dragonette shook his head.
No, they are gone.
Luna wondered if that meant dead, or
captured by hive wings, or just out
gathering food.
It was hard to tell from the dragonette's
quiet voice.
She wondered if a dragonette with parents
would have been forced onto a
construction crew though.
Poor little guy.
It's only me, he said, in an even smaller
voice.
Just dusky.
I can be really quiet, really, you won't
even notice me.
Please?
He hesitated, then added softly.
I don't want to be alone in the dark
anymore.
I'm afraid I'll get lost, and no one will
ever find me.
Luna thought about being a small dragon
with no family, in a giant cave in the
dark, because your home burned to ashes
in the sky, hiding from monsters, who
were suddenly even scarier than they had
already been your whole life, because now
you could be turned into one of them.
She curved one of her wings around him.
Of course you can stay with me, she said
and it won't be dark.
Don't worry.
I can make lots and lots of flame silk.
Here, look.
I can make a kind that gives light, but
won't burn you.
Hold out your talons.
Dusky warily held out one small talon, and
she uncoiled a little thread of glowing
silk into his palm.
He brought it close to his eyes, took a
deep breath, and then clutched it to his
chest.
Will it make the whisper stop?
He asked softly.
The whispers?
Luna echoed.
In the dark.
Dusky said.
There are whispers all the time in the
dark.
Luna felt a chill run all through her
scales, like trickles of icy water.
What?
What do the whispers say?
She asked.
Although she wasn't sure she wanted to
know.
Dusky tipped his head up to look at her
with large, dark eyes.
His voice, when he finally spoke, was so
faint that it seemed to come from the
clustered shadows outside her light.
They say, You're mine now, little
dragon.
Chapter 10.
Luna slept poorly that night.
In fact, she wasn't sure she slept
properly at all.
And in the morning, she didn't know if
she'd really heard whispers all night
long, or if she'd dreamed them.
It probably didn't help to have a twitchy
little dragonette curled up against her
side.
But she couldn't bring herself to send
Dusky away.
He'd looped the flame silk she gave him
around his wrist, like a talisman, and he
stayed so close to her, that she'd
tripped over him 3 times on her way to
the lake and back to her sleeping spot.
He didn't say very much.
But he did jerk awake several times
during the night, startling her out of
any almost sleep she might have been in.
She had hoped that making so many coils
of flame silk would have tired her out
enough to sleep through anything.
They'd spent hours sitting with Briony
hemlock, Tao, Grayling, and Lady Jewel
explaining everything that had happened
in the poison jungle, and the distant
kingdoms.
The humans had fallen asleep before the
end of the story.
Both of them tucked protectively under
Sky's wing.
And that whole time, Luna had burned off
wrist cuffs and made flame silk for the
hidden silk wings, while Dusky sat on her
tail.
She'd decided to name the 5 kinds she
could make and give the dragons options.
The simplest ones she called gold silk
which was much like the silvery silk most
of her tribe could make, except that hers
shimmered with a golden color.
But it didn't glow or burn, and it could
be used in normal tapestries.
It wouldn't be much use to these dragons
except for adding another color to
anything they were weaving.
The next kind she called firefly silk, it
gave off a little bit of light, like
holding a firefly in your talons, but it
didn't burn.
Then there was glow silk, the kind she'd
given to Dusky.
It felt a little warm, and it glowed
brighter, closer to a normal fire, but
anyone could hold it.
When she demonstrated that kind, all the
watching silk wings asked for some.
They delightedly wound it around their
own horns.
A few wove it into necklaces or
bracelets.
As Luna was helping one little dragonette
tie it around her ankle, she realized
that Lady Jewel was hovering right over
her shoulder, peering at it.
I've never seen flame silk like that.
The hive wing said.
She held out one talon.
May I?
Luna felt a little flare of anger.
This was one of Wasp's relatives.
Jewel had happily ruled her hive with
Wasps' power behind her, keeping
Silkwings as servants, and enforcing
Wasps' terrible rules.
She'd never tried to make anything better
for Silkwings before.
And the only reason she was here now was
because she knew WASP might try to mind
control her if she were caught.
Maybe Joel saw some of that in Luna's
face, because she added more humbly.
Please.
Dal says she helped all her silk wings
escape, Luna thought, and that she's not
as bad as other hive wings, and that
Queen Wasp took her children too.
Tal trusts her.
That doesn't mean I have to.
But she doesn't have to be my enemy
either.
Luna gave her a small curl of the glow
silk.
Thank you.
Jules said, peering at it.
This is extraordinary.
I thought there were only 2 kinds, one
that neither glows nor burns, and one
that burns like regular fire.
But this kind would be so much safer for
the lanterns.
Can all flame silks make this?
I don't know.
Luna said.
Your cousin keeps them all imprisoned in
a cavern, where they spend their lives
slaving to make her as much flame silk as
they can, so I haven't had much
opportunity to get to know any others.
Jewel ducked her head, looking
chastened.
Right, she said.
Of course.
Sorry.
But you can make the kind that burns
too.
Hemlock asked.
I can make 2 burning kinds, Luna said.
I call this one Blaze silk.
I think it's what you'll find in most
lanterns.
She made a little curl of the thread that
burned and glowed like a normal fire, and
held it up over Dusky's head when he
reached for it.
No, little one, this will hurt you.
Hemlock held out a stone jar, and Luna
carefully slid the blaze silk into it.
And this is the last kind, she said, which
I wouldn't use very often.
The thread that came from her wrist was
so bright that everyone near her shielded
their eyes.
It looked like a bolt of lightning
sizzling in her palm.
I call it sun silk, she said.
I can only make a little bit at a time.
She shook her head as Hemlock produced
another stone jar.
It can burn through that too.
I have to drown it.
The dragons all moved aside.
Even dusky.
As she placed the silk lightly on a
corner of her wing, and carried it down
to the lake, where she held it under the
water until the fire went out.
Blaze silk is more useful, if you're
trying to start a normal fire, she said
returning to the circle of boulders.
Do you want some of that or just glow
silk?
Both, please.
Bryani answered.
If we can start a fire and keep feeding
it, it'll last beyond when the flame silk
fades.
Should have thought of that when we had
Flame Soak before.
Pokween muttered.
We didn't think we'd be down here that
long then.
Bryany reminded him, which made all the
faces of the dragons around them go very
gloomy.
The silk wings here were from Bloodworm
Hive, Jewel Hive, and Mantis Hive.
They knew Cinnabar had gone to warn the
silk wings and other hives, but none of
them had shown up in the caves.
Nobody knew what that meant.
Were they safely in hiding somewhere
else?
Or were they all captured by Queen Wasp?
They'd seen silk wings flying in
formation with hive wings on a few
foraging expeditions, so they knew at
least some of them had been captured.
They hadn't known about the breath of
evil plant, or the other mind, though.
Luna could tell that several of them
didn't really believe that there was
another controlling malevolence out
there.
They thought it was still Queen Wasp.
Despite cricket's strange story about the
possessed leaf wing in the eye of the
poison jungle.
Everyone was fascinated by Moon's
prophecy though.
Luna saw a shiver of hope go through
them.
All these starving, homeless dragons
suddenly sitting taller, and touching
their glow silk or brushing their
neighbor's wing.
They'd lost their faith in the book of
Clearsight, but not their belief in the
magic of prophecies.
I don't know about any abyss, Tao said
but there is a colony of, what's the word
you said?
Humans, living not too far from here?
I know a cave where they go to gather
water.
You do?
Pokweed huffed.
You never told me about it.
Well, I was afraid you might eat them, Tao
said, in a reasonable voice.
Yes, exactly.
Pokweed snapped.
That was the whole point.
And if you had, you'd be feeling very
horrified right now, Tao pointed out.
I would hope.
Pokweed subsided, muttering, Wouldn't be
quite so hungry, though.
Several of the silk wings gave him a
disgusted look.
Wren and Axolotl were lucky that the 1st
giant crowd of dragons they'd met were
mostly from Pentala's vegetarian tribe.
None of the silk wings had had any
trouble accepting that humans were clever
could communicate, and shouldn't be
eaten.
Of course, that was how they felt about
zebras, wildebeests, lobsters, and
meerkats too.
As Guy pointed out to Wren with immense
glee.
Lady Jewel, on the other hand, had looked
decidedly green around the gills when
they introduced the humans.
She kept staring at Wren and Axolotl, like
she hoped they would suddenly throw off
their mammal skins and turn out to be
dragons in disguise after all.
Can you take us there?
To the human colony?
Cricket asked Tal.
Tao nodded.
Tomorrow, she said, after you sleep.
Are we near Lake Scorpion?
Luna asked.
Could you send some dragons to watch the
sky there?
In case sundew and links and the others
come looking for us?
Yes.
Hemlock said immediately.
I'll go myself.
It's not far.
We'll send some of the bloodworm hive
chrysalis with you, Grayling said.
It's a huge lake.
You want dragons stationed all around it
so you don't miss them.
Hemlock flicked a glance at Bryony, her
green tail crisscrossed with graylings
and nodded.
Luna's flame silk filled the caves with
light and warmth, and a fire crackled in
the center of the circle of boulders.
It was noisier too.
The light seemed to bring the dragons
back to life, and the caves were full of
voices.
But were they all dragon voices?
Was Luna just imagining it?
Or could she hear the whisper that Dusky
heard, threading underneath them all?
Come to me, little dragon.
You're mine.
Find me.
Around sunrise.
Luna groggily opened her eyes and found a
pale brown and gold silk wing crouched
beside her, looking at dusky.
The dragonette was finally truly asleep
flopped out in the curve of Luna's side
with his flame silk bracelet still curled
close to his chest.
Sorry.
The brown silk wing whispered, when he
saw Luna's eyes.
I didn't mean to wake you.
I'm Whitespeck.
I just wanted to check on Dusky.
Are you his family?
Luna asked.
He shook his head, his wings drooping.
They're all dead, or missing.
He said, even more softly.
He hesitated, then said, Dusky's mother
was shipped off to Vinegaroon Hive before
Dusky even came out of his egg.
And then Dusky's father died, in a tree
stuffed construction accident a year ago
when Dusky was one.
Oh no, Luna breathed.
But his wrist cuff said, White Speck
sighed.
Bloodworm hive's rules were very strict.
One member of each household must be
employed on Lady Bloodworm's pet projects
even, if that household consists of only
one small orphan.
The day after his father died.
They came and dragged him off to work on
the same construction side.
He has to split his time between there
and school.
That's awful, Luna whispered.
It's why I joined the chrysalis, he
said.
Dusky's father was my friend.
So, I've been trying to watch out for
Dusky ever since.
But I don't have a partner or anyone else
to help.
I was sent to Bloodworm Hive from Tetsi
Hive, and left my whole family behind, and
they won't let me adopt him.
So, I can't do as much as I would like
to.
He paused. took a deep breath and added
Sorry, too much information.
No, I'm glad you told me, Luna said.
I was wondering about him.
But I didn't want to make him talk about
it if he didn't want to.
I'll get you both something to eat.
White spec said, standing up.
I'm all right, Luna said.
She knew there wasn't much to go around
and these dragons had been hungry a lot
longer than she had.
But if there's anything for Dusky, that
would be great.
Thank you.
As they prepared to follow Tao to the
human colony.
Luna tried to talk Dusky into staying
behind, but he clung to her and wouldn't
let go.
I think it's all right.
Ren said, patting the little dragon on
the head.
He shied away from her hand, and buried
his face in Luna's scales.
The dragonette seemed to have no problem
with any of the strange looking newcomers
or cricket, but he was absolutely
terrified of the humans.
We are just going to look at the cave and
see if we can find any people.
No abyss today.
He can come along for this fact finding
part.
Please.
Please let me come with you.
Desky asked.
He gave Luna giant, sad eyes.
I won't be any trouble.
I promise.
All right.
Luna relented.
She lifted him onto her back.
But be really careful, okay?
I will be the best, quietest dragon
ever.
I promise, promise. he said, snuggling
into her neck.
They found axolotl surrounded by
dragonettes, who were arguing over who
would get to keep the clever human as a
pet.
I saw them first, said the pink one.
And look, they like me best.
Axolotl held out their hand for her to
sniff.
Instead, she seized their hand in her
talons, and yanked them down so she could
climb onto their shoulders.
Not fair, bellowed the orange one.
Dad!
I want a pet human.
Nobody ever lets me adopt weird looking
cave mammals.
Um, no eating?
Axolotl said cautiously.
They patted the tail of the little pink
one where it draped across their
collarbone.
Eee, look how clever they are.
The pink one cried, wrapping her arms
around Axolotl's head, and squishy.
I just want to love them and cuddle them
and smush them.
Oh, dear, Ren said.
I didn't realize I'd have to teach
Axolotl how to say, no smooshing as
well.
She waded into the pile of squabbling
dragonettes, and firmly peeled them off
axolotl, who looked disheveled, bewildered
and a little enchanted.
Not a pet.
She scolded the little dragons.
Humans can be friends, but not pets.
Friend.
Axolotl cried in dragon, latching onto
one of the words they'd been practicing.
They crouched and clasped one of the pink
dragonette's talons.
Friend, Axolotl said again, with a
smile.
The pink dragonette beamed.
Desky, look, this human likes me best of
anyone.
Dusky shivered, and buried his nose in
Luna's neck.
Probably because I am not a brat, like
some dragons.
The pink dragonette stuck out her tongue
at the orange one.
Aww.
The orange one grumbled to Ren.
But why?
We want a fluffy human to play with.
That one said you were his pet.
He pointed at Guy, who did an extremely
terrible job of trying to look innocent.
Sky, Rand stamped her foot.
Don't make that mad face, he protested.
They would have tried to keep you
otherwise.
I wanted them to know we go together, you
and me.
You could have said best friends, Ren
suggested, or that I saved your life like
multiple times, or that nobody gets to
keep any humans, by all the moons.
I mean, really.
No, humans for you.
Sky said sternly to the dragonettes.
Ooh, but I bet you could find some really
cute cave snails.
He lowered his voice and whispered, They'd
probably be better behaved than she is
anyway.
You are so lucky you're cute, Ren said
shaking her head.
She said something to Axolotl, then added
in dragon to Luna.
Dusky kind of reminds me of Baby Sky.
Totally different scales, but the sweet
face, and Skye had no family either.
Except you, Skye said, poking her
affectionately with his tail.
Well, you lucked into me, Ren said with a
grin.
Tal led them out of the main cave, and
for a while, they climbed and walked
through the winding rock passages.
At one point in a high ceilinged cave
Luna wondered why they weren't flying, and
then she remembered noticing that one of
Tao's wings looked different from the
others.
She wanted to ask how Tao had made it all
the way here from Jewel Hive, but she
wasn't sure if that was too nosy.
Tao seemed like someone who was good at
both solving her own problems and asking
for help when she needed it.
They had to splash through a long river
for a while.
Pale, eyeless fish darted between their
claws.
Cricket and Briny tried to catch one but
failed, and then Bullfrog tried, succeeded
and snarfed it down with a very self
satisfied expression.
The frigid water came up to Luna's wings
ribald around her stomach, and
occasionally splashed up her nose.
Eventually, the river narrowed, and
curved through a thin gap between 2 walls
of rock.
They squeezed through one by one, Tao, Sky
with the humans, Luna with Dusky, Bryony
and Cricket.
It took more wiggling and squishing to
get bullfrog through, but eventually he
flopped into the shallow water on the
other side with an oof of
disgruntlement.
This is it.
Tao said.
She flipped her tail at the cave below
them.
The river swept past their talons and
over an edge, water falling down about
the height of 2 dragons, into a wide
rippling pool.
Luna could see more pale fish flickering
in the dark water, but she didn't see any
humans.
Cricket splashed out of the water and
crouched to the edge of the rock, peering
down.
You've seen humans here?
She asked Tal.
A couple of times.
Tao answered.
Can't you smell them?
Luna sniffed, but it was hard to separate
out any new furry smells from the sense
of wren and axolotl right beside her.
There's something else.
Tao turned to Bryony, who offered one of
her wings to support Tao's shorter wing
as they glided down to the cave below.
Luna and the others followed as Tal
stepped around the shore, to the far side
of the pool and reached into the water.
She pulled out a small contraption.
It took Luna a moment to realize it was a
sort of cage.
It was designed so fish would swim in, but
couldn't swim back out, and it currently
held 3 squirming fish.
Whoa.
Cricket breathed.
She hurried over to study it, blinking
behind her spectacles.
This, humans made this?
Ren can make things like that, Skye said
sounding hilariously defensive.
She can make anything.
She catches fish with weird inventions
all the time.
There are several of these, Tao said.
She lowered it back into the water.
I believe the humans come from there, she
added, pointing to a hole higher up the
wall.
Now that she was looking, Luna could see
an odd sort of path, descending from the
hole to the shore of the lake, made of
stairs, chiseled into the stone.
Maybe Axolotl and I should stay here for
the rest of the day.
Ren suggested, so we can meet anyone who
comes to the lake?
Without a bunch of giant drooling dragon
faces looming around to scare them off.
Sky snorted huffily.
A small scuffing noise came from behind
them.
Luna whirled around, accidentally
splashing dusky, and stared into the dark
corners of the cave.
The stalagmites cast along shadows and
the light from her glow silk, and for a
moment, she thought she saw movement.
There.
No, there.
No?
Maybe it was nothing.
And then something glinted overhead
catching the light.
She lifted her gaze, and locked eyes with
a gaunt, shaggy, eerie thing.
It saw her see it, but it stayed
perfectly still, without a flicker of
movement or muscle tension, as though it
was not afraid of her at all.
It was shaped like a human, she thought
but it held itself in a weird, spider
like way, knees and elbows bent at
painful, sharp angles.
Its arms were as thin as her antennae, and
when it crouched, as it did now, its
matted hair and beard brushed the
ground.
Its skin was as pale as the eyeless fish
but less natural, as though all the blood
had been sucked out of it.
And its eyes.
They seemed to be covered in a green film
like algae, but they also seemed to be
staring straight into Luna's soul.
She couldn't help crying out in alarm and
jumping back, stumbling farther into the
pool.
The human still did not flinch, but a
crack opened in its hairy face, then
widened to reveal rotting teeth, and
something like a cruel imitation of a
smile.
What is it?
Briony asked, splashing over next to
her.
Luna pointed, and all the dragons turned
to look up at the strange creature on the
ledge.
Wren held out her hands and said
something calm and soothing and human.
When there was no reaction, she added in
dragon, Do you understand this language
instead?
They won't hurt you.
The creature lunged to its feet suddenly
hissed at them, and bolted away through a
crack in the wall.
Chapter 11.
That was so creepy.
Bryney said. looking down at Wren and
Axolotl with a shiver.
I didn't know humans could be that
creepy.
Was?
that a human?
Cricket asked.
For sure?
Not some other weird thing we haven't
discovered yet?
I think he was human, Ren said.
But I have no idea what was wrong with
him.
She said something to Axolotl and they
raised their hands, looking equally
puzzled.
Dusky had his face buried in Luna's neck
again, trembling.
She rubbed her wings together uneasily
then reached up and tugged the dragonette
into her arms, partly to comfort him, and
partly to comfort herself.
She'd expected tiny wrens and daffodils
and axolotls and ocelots, calm, smart
little creatures.
She'd never pictured an unsettling
dangerous looking version of them.
She felt her hope shiver, like thin glass
that could shatter at any moment.
Don't fall into the fog, Luna.
Don't let the worry win.
Humans are scary.
Dusky whispered in Luna's ear.
His breath smelled like the wild carrots
he'd eaten for breakfast.
Not all of them, she whispered back.
Ren and Axolotl are friendly, and kind of
cute, aren't they?
I have bad dreams about humans, he said.
So quietly she could barely hear him.
Wait till you get your wings, she said
patting his head.
You won't be scared of anything then.
I've only had mine for a little while, and
look how tough I am.
It's all right to be scared too, Cricket
said unexpectedly.
Luna hadn't even realized she was close
enough to hear them.
Cricket offered one of her talons to
Dusky, and he touched his nose to it
blinking up at her.
Everyone gets scared sometimes, she said
or sad, or worried.
That thing scared me too, Dusky.
You can always talk to one of us about it
whenever you feel that way.
What would that be like?
Luna wondered.
Telling someone anytime I felt sad.
Is that normal for other dragons?
Should we follow him?
Ren asked, starting toward the ledge.
No way.
Sky objected instantly.
I'm not letting you near that thing.
It looked like it would eat you in a
heartbeat.
He made what he seemed to think was a
stern, determined expression and glared
down at her.
I'm also not leaving you here alone.
That thing could come back and get you.
And so I am staying here to guard you, no
matter what you say.
Ren put her hands on her hips.
No one is going to approach me if they
see you looming around pretending to be
scary, Skye.
Well, good, he said.
I am scary.
They should think about that.
What if all the Abyss worshipers look
like that?
Briony asked, flicking her tail
worriedly.
Maybe the abyss makes them creepy.
Sky lunged forward and cupped his front
talons around Wren, just as she was about
to climb the wall to the ledge.
Ren, he said, with desperate
seriousness.
If the abyss can do that to humans, you
can't go there.
I won't let you turn into a scary hair
monster.
She put one hand on his nearest claw and
looked up at him for a long moment.
Like they were communicating entire
libraries with their eyes.
Finally, Ren said, You'd better not.
I like my hair the way it is.
We could turn around.
Skye said, hopefully, and go home.
You wanted to help, Skye?
She reminded him with a gentle nudge.
Listen, you protect me from becoming a
scary hair monster, and I'll protect you
from becoming a wide-eyed murder zombie.
Deal?
He sighed.
All right.
But if there are any reckless heroics
involved, it's my turn to do them.
As they talked, Cricket had flown up to
the ledge where the hair creature had
been hiding.
She paced along it, touching the rock
wall and studying the shadows.
There is a gap here that some of us might
fit through.
She said thoughtfully.
Let's think.
Should we try?
Just to look?
What if it leads to the abyss?
Bullfrog asked.
Then what do we do?
Turn around, Skye said promptly.
Go back to the cavern with all those nice
rainbow dragons and have another bonfire
party.
Let's spend the night telling each other
whatever the opposite of ghost stories
are, like, once there was a turtle, and
then it met another even cuter turtle.
And then they had the absolute most
adorable turtle babies, and they lived
forever in a sunny place, and no one ever
thought about eating them even once their
whole lives.
The end.
I'll fly into the abyss.
Bryany said.
I do it right now.
I want to know what's down there that's
where the whole prophecy.
Cricket rubbed her forehead and scrunched
up her eyes.
We have to, don't we?
she said.
A secret buried far below may save those
brave enough to look.
It's right there in the prophecy.
We have to go look.
But, Sundew, Luna said.
And tsunami, and moon, and lynx and
pineapple.
How can we go without them?
Face a great evil with talons united.
That's in the prophecy too, isn't it?
If we only have half the tribes
represented?
Aren't we doing it all wrong?
That's true, Skye said, hopefully.
We could give them a couple more days to
find us, couldn't we?
More sitting and waiting.
Bullfrog grunted.
No thanks.
What if we look?
Cricket suggested, but we don't face
anything yet.
We scouted out carefully first.
I'll just go through this gab and pick
around and come right back.
I'll come with you.
Luna heard herself say. to her own
surprise.
No, no, no.
Dusky whispered.
The dragonette was trembling so hard.
Luna could feel the vibrations echoing in
her bones.
You stay with Tao, she said, unwrapping
him from her shoulders.
I'll come right back, all right?
He made a sad little noise as she tucked
him into Tao's arms, but he didn't argue
with her.
I hope I can make a weaving for him one
day.
Luna thought.
Something comforting.
Maybe of what he'll look like with wings
to remind him of what he has to look
forward to.
It would have dusky in the center, flying
looking happy instead of frightened, with
dragons he trusts behind him, keeping him
safe.
Maybe I could put wren and axolotl in it
waving from the ground, or flying with
his friends, to remind him that some
humans are safe and friendly.
She felt her worry, sadness lift a little
as she pictured the tapestry, and
imagined the possible colors and
composition.
It distracted her enough to get her on to
the ledge with cricket.
And it helped squash down the fear enough
so she could squeeze through the small
gap right behind the hive wing.
Her flame silk illuminated a long, dark
tunnel, stretching away in either
direction.
The roof was low enough that Cricket and
Luna both had to crouch.
There was no sign of the hairy, hissing
creature.
Which way?
Cricket whispered.
Something glinted off to the left
reflecting in the light of the flame
silk.
Luna pointed, and Cricket nodded, and
they crept toward it, with cricket in the
lead.
The shiny thing turned out to be a
diamond, several diamonds in fact, plus a
few rubies and emeralds, embedded in the
wall in a design that framed the archway
into a new tunnel.
Cricket brushed her claws over the
design.
Do these look like vines to you?
She whispered to Luna.
Luna nodded.
Emerald vines, diamond flowers.
Dark and blood red rubies throughout.
I guess the humans made this.
I wonder if that means the village is
close.
I don't see any humans down here, she
added softly.
But there's something on the wall in this
tunnel.
They went through the archway.
In the light of Luna's flame silk, the
stone walls came alive.
Shapes flickering across them like
darting shadows.
She nearly yelped, thinking the hair
creature was running toward them, but
after the 1st moment of panic, she
realized it was only paintings, paintings
covered the tunnel walls on either side
of them, and the ceiling as well.
Pictures, Cricket said. in an awe struck
voice, leaning closer to study them.
It's a story, I think.
The humans must have done these, right?
There's so many of them.
The walls and ceiling were covered in
little drawings of humans.
It was strange to see a story with this
many humans in it, and no words to help
figure out what was going on, and no
dragons at all, as far as Luna could
see.
No, wait.
There was one.
A little farther along the passage.
Tucked up near the ceiling.
There was a drawing of a dragon curled in
a cave, smoke rising from its nostrils.
Luna followed the tunnel, watching the
pictures as she went.
The walls seemed to mirror each other, and
were covered mostly with humans doing odd
little human things.
But here was the dragon again, this time
flying low over a group of crouching
stick figures, and farther along, here
again, back in its cave, but now, with
little bones scattered at its feet, Luna
shuddered.
The idea of eating any animals gave her
the heebie-jeebies, eating animals that
were smart and self aware, made it so
much worse.
These dragons didn't know who they were
eating, she told herself.
But to see a story like this, where
dragons like her were the scary, dangerous
villains.
It made her feel strange and inside out
like she didn't know who she really was.
The drawings got more unsettling as they
continued along the passage.
More dragons appeared.
Most of them chasing the tiny stick
figures, and more bones filled the empty
spaces on the wall.
A few dragons had little human legs
poking out of their mouths.
Next, came several small human houses on
fire, and a few small humans on fire
too.
My art won't be like this, Luna thought
touching one of the paintings.
Other dragons can do these kinds of
stories.
I want my tapestries to make dragons
happy.
I'll show dragons and humans side by side
communicating, and living in peace, and
maybe if enough dragons see it in a
tapestry, they'll want to live it for
real too.
These aren't pental and dragons.
Crooked said softly.
Did you notice that?
They all have 2 wings, and they're
breathing fire.
Oh, Luna said, studying the dragons more
closely.
She had to admit, that was smart of
cricket to notice, and admitting that to
herself made her realize she hadn't had
any angry thoughts about cricket in a
while.
Somewhere along the way, she'd become
cricket in Luna's mind, an individual
dragon who was not so bad, instead of a
hive wing, representative of her entire
cruel tribe.
You're right.
What does that mean?
How can there be drawings here?
on Pentala, of Pyrean dragons.
I think they're very old, Cricket said.
Brushing one claw lightly over a small
drawing of a shrieking human.
Maybe they're from a time when the same
dragons flew over both continents.
Hmm.
Luna said doubtfully.
That didn't entirely make sense to her.
If this continent used to have 2 winged
dragons who breathed fire, why weren't
they here anymore?
More and more little squares on fire?
Trees on fire?
Painted flames covering wide swaths of
the wall, with only a circle peeking out
here and there that might have been a
screaming human face.
Luna really didn't love this story
whatever was happening in it.
Oh, Cricket yelped.
She grabbed Luna's talon and pointed to
the fire paintings.
Luna.
What if this is the thing Bullfrog was
telling us about?
The smoking?
The burning.
The scorching.
Luna gasped.
Could that be it?
And this is how the human saw it, she
cried.
Lots of burning and death, Cricket said.
Sounds kind of like how the dragon saw it
too, actually.
But wasn't the scorching 1000s of years
ago?
Luna asked.
Maybe there have been humans down here
all that time.
Cricket said.
Maybe this is how some of them survived
by hiding in the caves and living
underground.
I wonder who this is, Luna said, pointing
to a little figure all by himself in a
space on the wall, with a circle of
figures at a distance around him.
He was slightly bigger than the others
with a halo of light drawn around his
head, and he was pointing toward the far
end of the tunnel, the direction they
were walking.
A little ways on, she saw him again.
Standing alone on a small crescent on top
of what looked like waves.
Lots of other humans were behind him
following him, stuffed 10 apiece in their
own crescents.
She could tell it was the same figure
even if he hadn't had the halo, because
in both paintings, he was holding a green
box and wearing thick black gloves.
At least, she thought that's what it
looked like, either that, or he had giant
paws.
Crossing the ocean.
Cricket murmured.
Darting along the wall.
Coming to Pantala, and look, way along
here.
They've reached land again, and are going
into a cave.
She paused, and touched the painting
lightly, then turned to look at Luna with
worried eyes.
Does it seem like there are a lot of
plants painted around this cave?
It did look very leafy.
There were vines curling around the
entrance, and under the human's feet, as
they followed their hero into the mouth
of the cave.
The leaves and vines were streaked red
and green, with little white flowers
scattered around them.
Muna knotted.
Lots of one particular plant.
She said slowly.
Cricket let out a long breath.
That's not just any plant, she said.
I'm pretty sure that's the breath of
evil.
Luna!
A little voice screamed from the tunnel
behind them.
Fire dragon, Luna.
I'm here.
Luna called, recognizing Dusky's voice
with a jolt of alarm.
She ran back along the painted tunnel.
Dusky, stay there.
I'm coming.
Luna!
He shrieked again.
She flew through the archway and around
the corner into the 1st tunnel.
She saw Dusky's flame silk bracelet first
glowing warmly in the dark passageway
moving away from her.
Then she saw the human holding Dusky.
And a thick, twisted net Dusky was caught
in, his little claws pinned to his sides
and the other human, standing between her
and the captured dragonette, holding a
torch, and a sharp, gleaming knife.
Neither human was the hairy, hissing
creature, but they were not wren or
axolotl either.
These looked spiky and dangerous in their
own way.
The closer one had short, straight, dark
hair, and black feathers woven into the
leather of her outer wrappings.
Her face was thinner and sharper than
Wren's, and she had a tiny emerald
embedded in the side of her nose.
She called something to her partner, who
wrapped his arms more firmly around the
net and dusky, and took off running.
No, Luna yelled.
What are you doing?
Stop.
Ren, Ren, help.
She ran full tilt toward them.
But the feathered human flung down her
torch in a blaze of flames, and darted
after the other one.
They were gone.
And they'd taken Dusky with them.
Chapter 12.
Wren!
Luna shouted again, as she reached the
gap she'd squeezed through only a moment
before.
Help!
There were humans here, and they took
Dusky.
She kicked aside the burning torch
flinching at the stab of pain in her
foot.
Through the haze of panic around her, she
heard Tao crying something like, he
promised he would just look, Luna, I'm so
sorry.
They came out of nowhere.
And bullfrog, grunting, it's too small.
Can't get through.
And Brian yelling, then get out of the
way, you big thick crocodile.
And Skye shouting, Ren, don't you dare.
Wren, stop.
It's not safe.
And then Ren was there, in the passageway
with her, seeing the look on Luna's face
turning toward the sound of Dusky's
shrieks, still echoing along the stone
and running, and Luna ran with her.
She thought she heard cricket's talon
steps behind them, maybe Bryonies, but
she didn't look back, only forward, at
the distant light of Dusky's bracelet
moving away from them.
She wished she could run faster.
But the 3rd time she ran headfirst into a
stalactite, she forced herself to slow
down and watch the passage ahead.
She'd be no use to dusky if she knocked
herself unconscious.
What did the human say?
Ren asked as they ran, why did they take
him?
I have no idea, Luna cried.
They said, herbal cheapsqueak. and threw
a net over him and ran away.
Purple.
Cheap, Ren muttered.
Not literally.
Luna interrupted.
I don't know.
It just sounded like squeaking to me.
I sorry.
I think one of them said, abyss.
Cricket panted behind them.
Luna remembered that the hive wing had
been trying to study human with axolotl
Wren, and Sky during their rest stops.
Luna had been too tired to pay
attention.
She should have paid attention.
She could at least have learned the word
abyss, or maybe something actually useful
like how to say, stop, or, don't you dare
take that dragonette, or, I will give up
vegetarianism just to eat you if you hurt
that dragonette.
It is weird, Ren said breathlessly, that
they would grab a baby dragon with a big
dragon right there.
I mean, if they assume you're his mom
they should guess, you'll chase them and
probably eat them.
And so if they were smart, they would
drop him, and then they'd have a better
chance of escaping.
So it's...
Weird is all.
The tunnel zigged and zagged, and the
humans kept turning off into other
branches, and a few times, they nearly
lost sight of Dusky's light at places
where the path split, but then, it would
always appear again.
If the humans know these caves well, they
should have been able to lose us by now.
Ren pointed out, pausing to rest one hand
against the wall, clutching her side.
Sorry.
Ow.
I'll catch up.
Luna crouched beside her.
I'll carry you.
If I catch them, I need you to
communicate with them.
Wren clambered onto Luna's bag without
arguing, and they set off running again.
The ground kept slanting downward.
And each turn took them lower and lower
into the earth.
Luna wondered for a moment how they would
ever get back to the others.
Sky was going to kill her for taking Ren
off to get lost in this underground
labyrinth.
Suddenly Luna realized.
There was a faint green glow coming from
up ahead.
And maybe the sound of distant whispers
too?
It was hard to hear for sure over her
running footsteps, but the glow became
brighter as she ran closer, until she
emerged into a sepulchral, echoing cavern
and found herself on a plateau scattered
with boulders.
The plateau overlooked a jagged slash in
the heart of the planet, a stab wound in
the stone that plunged down and down and
down, so far, it hurt Luna's eyes to look
at it.
The abyss.
They'd found it.
Luna had no doubt.
There couldn't be any place deeper or
creepier in the whole world.
There couldn't be anywhere else where
someone might stand and say, oh, this is
much more of an abyss than that one.
It felt like a place a prophecy would
point to.
It felt like it had been carved out of
generations of dragons nightmares.
And the humans were there.
Standing near the edge with Dusky.
As Luna spotted them, she realized the
feathered one was crouching beside the
baby dragon and sawing through the net
with her knife.
Don't hurt him.
N cried, skidding to a stop.
The one with the knife looked at her, then
yelled something at the other one, who
shook his head.
She told him to run.
Ren murmured to Luna.
But he won't leave her.
Luna, I think Dusky was bait.
I think this is a trap.
Luna jerked her head around, but there
was no one else nearby.
The glow from the abyss, and the light
from her flame silk illuminated the
plateau.
No other humans, not even the hairy
creature.
No hidden nets, or anything that looked
like it might trap her.
If Cricket and Briony had been behind
her.
They hadn't caught up yet.
It doesn't matter, she said.
We have to get Dusky back.
It made her sick with nerves to see him
so close to that awful hole, knowing he
had no wings, if the worst happened and
he fell in.
Wren slid off Luna's back and stepped
toward the humans, holding her hands with
palms out.
She called to the menhuman, and both
humans froze, staring at her.
Here we go.
Wren said with a sigh.
Luna, look as fierce as you can.
I'm going to try talking them down, but
it'll help if you could look a bit more
threatening.
She took another step toward the humans
and said something else, and the one in
black feathers responded.
Look fierce and scary.
Luna fluffed up her wings, hoping that
would make her look bigger, and frowned.
She always found frowning dragons a
little scary anyhow.
What else could she do?
Oh, right.
My terrifying superpower.
As the human said bristly sounding things
back and forth, Luna lifted one talon and
let a smoking thread of blaze silk spill
into her palm, it wound into a ball, and
she cupped the fire between her claws.
She never tried throwing flame soap
before, but maybe holding it menacingly
would be enough.
The feathered human looked around the
plateau and shouted something.
Her partner shook his head, and responded
in a quiet, sad voice.
What's happening?
Luna asked Wren.
Why aren't they giving Dusky back?
They're waiting for someone, Ren said.
They called him the Guardian of the Abyss
but his name must be Vol because that's
what that one just shouted.
I think her name is Raven.
She says the guardian told them to bring
the abyss, a dragon, or the abyss told
them, speaking through the guardian
something like that.
She listened to the conversation the
other humans were having for a moment.
Apparently he's always here.
It's creepy that he's missing.
He's never left before.
They didn't even think he could.
Luna felt a horrible chill, like Arctic
spiders tiptoeing down her spine.
The abyss talks to them, she said.
It asks for things.
Do they know what's down there?
Ren spoke to the humans, and the one
without feathers answered her.
They don't know.
Ren relayed to Luna.
Only the guardian can go into the abyss.
I'm not sure how.
But they get instructions through him.
Ren shook her head.
I'd say it's all a made up cult thing, but
since it's in your prophecy, then I guess
there really might be something down
there.
The breath of evil.
Luna thought.
The source of the other mind.
It has to be, doesn't it?
Well, it can't have Dusky, she said
firmly.
Tell them no.
Tell them I will set them on fire right
now if they don't give him back.
Ren put her hands on her hips.
And whatever she said in human, it
sounded very commanding to Luna.
Raven and the other human looked at each
other for a long moment, and then Raven
sighed, knelt down and cut the rest of
the net off Dusky.
Luna, he yelped, as soon as his snout was
free.
He wriggled away from the robes as the
humans stepped back and pelted across the
plateau toward her.
Dusky?
Luna cried with relief.
It's all right.
We're here.
She set down her ball of flame silk, and
stepped forward, talons outstretched to
catch him.
But he was still a few steps away, when
something dropped from the ceiling.
Something that had been hiding among the
stalactites overhead, waiting to pounce
like a vicious predatory insect.
Something hairy, and leggy, and hissing
giving off a stench, almost as bad as
Lady Scarab's weapon as it fell.
The guardian of the Abyss landed on Dusky
knocking the dragonette flat.
He seized the little silkwing in his
spindly arms and sprinted sideways
darting away from Luna, while her brain
was still screaming, creepy things
falling from the sky.
And then, before anyone could blink, or
scream, or move.
The terrifying human hurled himself, and
the wingless dragonette, over the edge
into the abyss.
Part two.
A secret buried far below.
Chapter 13.
Desky.
Luna shrieked.
No, no, no, no, no.
This couldn't be happening.
The little dragon couldn't be gone just
like that.
The abyss could not have him.
She didn't stop to think.
She ran to the edge and threw herself
after them.
I can catch them.
I can save Dusky before they hit the
bottom.
I can get him back.
Below her.
She could see the tiny dark silhouette of
the guardian falling, framed against the
weird glow. behind her.
She heard Wren shouting, but she couldn't
make out anything the human was saying.
I guess I am a dragon who can fly into
the danger when I have to.
She thought as she plummeted.
I never knew for sure.
Sortell always did it for me, before I
ever could.
Please be okay, Dusky.
The flailing stick figure below her
looked as far away as before, and the
fall felt endless.
Luna tried pumping her wings to descend
faster, but it didn't seem to help.
Why would the guardian do this?
Why would he take Dusky?
Why would the abyss want a baby dragon?
The light was getting brighter.
Bright enough to dazzle her eyes, and
suddenly she couldn't see the human and
dusky anymore.
They were swallowed by the green glow
which filled her field of vision
shimmering fold of eerie light, consuming
everything else, and blinding her, so she
didn't know how much farther she had to
fall.
And then all at once, she was there.
Luna had to swerve the last moment, to
avoid landing in the morass of vines that
carpeted the abyss floor.
They were thick, and wound together like
an angry nest of eels, and she thought
the whole tangle might be dragons deep.
The phosphorescent light came from the
leaves, and from a moist, mossy coating
on all the walls around her.
It was bright enough here, that she
wouldn't have needed the glow silk on her
horns, but she was glad she had it, and
its warm golden light.
There was no sign of Dusky, or the
wretched human.
Tusky!
Luna cried.
Dusky.
Maybe the vines had cushioned their fall
but then, where were they now?
How could they have vanished so quickly?
Wait.
There.
There was a section of the tangle that
looked partly crushed.
This had to be where they had landed.
Luna hovered as close as she dared and
peered at it.
She didn't want to land on or touch the
vines.
She could too easily imagine long
tendrils, wrapping around her ankles
dragging her down, so the plants could
dissolve her into bone mulch.
And she was pretty sure, this was the
breath of evil.
She'd never seen it in real life before
but it looked like the plant in the cave
paintings, and it matched the description
from cricket and sundews stories.
Muna!
Dusky's voice shrieked.
Luna whipped around.
There was a trail across the vines if she
squinted.
The path of a small creature running full
tilt, leaping from tangle to tangle like
a fearless squirrel, and it led in the
direction of Dusky's cry for help.
She shot over the vines, swooping around
the curves of the abyss.
Maybe the abyss monster could fall faster
than she could catch him, but he could
not run her wings, especially while
carrying a baby dragon.
As it turned out though, he hadn't had to
run far.
The vines and the trail converged on a
cave in the wall of the abyss, or rather
the vines seemed to be exploding from it
swarming out in both directions.
The cave entrance was full of plants.
But there was a gap near the top where a
small dragon, or a human and a tiny
dragon could fit through.
Luna held her breath and dove toward the
opening.
Her wings and talons brushed the vines as
she glided through, and she felt the
tendrils shiver, as if a 1000000
gleefully venomous wasps were waking up
somewhere nearby.
On the other side, there was a room.
That is, it still felt like a cave.
Stone walls, chili, dark.
But it was the size and shape of a throne
room, square, with 4 matching columns, and
corners.
And most importantly, a throne on the far
end, up against a perfectly smooth, flat
wall.
The vines were coming from the thing on
the throne.
Luna tried to make the scene into a
picture in her memory instinctively, the
way she always did, but she couldn't.
She couldn't figure it out.
She couldn't get her brain to fit around
what her eyes could see.
Her 1st thought was, This would be such a
disturbing tapestry.
Her mind desperately wanted to see it as
a tapestry instead, as a picture, not
real, not really right in front of her.
She'd expected a plant, and yes, there
was a plant.
A stem as thick as the columns rose from
the earth below the throne, winding
around the pedestal.
But on the throne was a man.
And sitting on his knees, captured
between the thick black gloves on the
human's hands, was a young dragon.
For a horrible moment, Luna thought it
was dusky.
But as she flew closer, her light
reflected off green and orange scales, and
she saw that this dragonette had wings.
It also could not possibly be alive.
The plant was growing straight through
the dragon's skull.
Emerging, horrifyingly, from a split at
the top of its head and then continuing
on through the human's skull.
Behind a human's head, the vines divided
and cascaded away, like a parody of
ocelot's hair, like tentacles, exploding
outward.
Some of them swarmed toward the cave
opening, while 100s of others clambered
up the walls and disappeared into cracks
overhead.
What?
Luna breathed.
At the foot of the throne, on the vines
that covered the floor, a hairy shape
twisted around to glare at her, in his
arms, dusky flailed, whimpering.
Dusky, Luna said, starting forward.
Stay back.
Hissed voice in dragon.
The voice came from the guardian's
mouth.
It sounded like the possessed silkwing on
the island where they'd been attacked.
Luna froze.
Who is talking to me?
The other mind?
Who are you?
Luna said.
She focused her gaze on the throne.
On the grotesque tableau of the
dragonette, man and plant fused
together.
Their blank, staring eyes seem to be
fixed on her.
Both the human and the dragon had a white
film covering their eyeballs, with a
shimmer of mossy green overlaying it.
But they couldn't still be alive.
They just absolutely could not be.
I am the emperor of the world.
You're so not, Luna said.
How can you be emperor if no one even
knows you exist?
Hissing filled the room.
Coming from the throne, into shivering
plants, and the guardian of the abyss all
at the same time.
They will know, said the voice.
They will all know soon.
I am the ruler of everything.
All of it is mine all.
Okay.
You're deranged and sinister.
Got it, Luna interrupted.
But who is talking right now?
What is that?
She pointed to the throne.
What happened to that little dragon?
There was an offended silence for a
heartbeat.
Two.
Three.
And then, with a wrestling, the voice
finally answered.
Give yourself to the vines, and we'll
show you the whole story.
Ha!
Luna said.
No, easy no.
I will never let you take my mind.
It's inevitable now, the voice said
calmly.
As soon as you entered this chamber
eventually your wings will tire, and
you'll drop from the air with exhaustion
and then my vines will have you.
Luna scoffed.
I can leave whenever.
She turned toward the cave entrance.
It was entirely barricaded with vines.
Muna shot over to the tangle that now
blocked the exit.
She nearly grabbed one of the vines to
rip it away, but she pulled her talons
back at the side of wicked thorns
bristling along the edges.
If they scratched her, would she
instantly be lost to the other mind?
Or would it happen if she touched the
sticky sap?
Or the jagged leaves?
How did this work?
Was it more dangerous here?
This close to the roots, to its origin?
How did you do this?
Loonan demanded.
I thought you needed a dragon with leaf
speak to move the vines.
Oh, I have one.
Luna's gaze went to the mystery
dragonette on the throne.
Was it a leaf wing?
But the orange scales.
It didn't look like any tribe she'd seen
so far.
Unfortunately, my lizard is not strong
enough for everything we want to do.
Her leaf speak works for the vines close
to us in the abyss, but not in the
overworld.
Which is why this fool was supposed to
bring me sundew.
The voice suddenly roared.
At the foot of the throne, the guardian
coward, baring his teeth.
He whined something inhuman, and shook
poor little dusky.
That is obviously not the dragon I need.
The voice abruptly cut off.
There was an odd, strangled sound, and
then it returned.
Suddenly soft and whispery.
But it's the dragon I want.
A few of the vines slithered toward Dusky
like curious snakes.
The guardian took a step away from them
and snarled something else.
Pathetic. the voice said, back to its
previous cadence.
You're not much use to me either, Silkwing
but I'll keep you just for fun.
Maybe sundew will come looking for you.
That would be convenient.
I'm not afraid of you, Luna said.
She turned her wrists upward and gestured
at the vines all around.
I'm a flame sulk.
All I have to do is burn my way out.
Maybe this is the reason I'm a flame
silk.
Maybe I'm supposed to use my sun silk to
burn all these vines to ashes.
Maybe this is always where I was supposed
to end up.
Oh, said the voice gleefully.
Oh no, no, don't.
Anything but that.
Luna hesitated.
Why did it sound so delighted?
That would be just terrible.
The voice went on.
You fiendish monster.
Because...
Wait.
Because burning it would release the same
smoke that got the silk wings and leaf
wings of the snarling river.
It would be toxic.
It would go straight into my brain, and
if I burned too much.
The smoke could rise and get the others
beyond the abyss as well.
She clasped her front talons together
suddenly terrified.
Cricket!
Luna shouted at the blocked exit.
Ren, Bryany.
Oh, yes.
Please do bring them closer.
The voice chuckled.
I would like all those pretty dragons to
play with.
And the sparky humans too.
This guardian is the worst.
It suddenly roared again.
I demand another, and nobody listens.
My worshipers have betrayed me.
The guardian shrieked, dropped dusky, and
threw his hairy arms over his head.
Dusky scrambled away from him, and pelted
across the vines that covered the floor.
He stopped below Luna, and reached up
toward her, with a heartbreaking look on
his face.
Muna, help me, he wailed.
She swooped down to pick him up.
But as her talons touched his, vines shot
up from the tangle, snapping around her
wrists and ankles.
Dusky's eyes went blank, and he yanked
her down toward him, and more vines
surged up to ensnare her neck, her tail
her wings.
Luna tried to scream for help, but a vine
looped around her snout and pinned it
shut.
She was trapped, like an insect in a
spider web, and the spider was casting
its poisonous haze across her mind, and
all around her, the throne room faded
away.
Chapter 14.
Luna opened her eyes.
She was standing on the slope of a
mountain, in bright daylight, surrounded
by pine trees.
What?
She blinked, but the pine trees were
still there.
She held up her talons.
They looked like hers.
She felt like herself.
She did not feel like she was drowning in
evil vines.
Is this an evil vine hallucination?
It felt awfully real.
If it is a hallucination.
Why is it happening?
For a moment.
She stared at the trees, but they didn't
seem to have any sinister intentions.
They swayed gently, looking the very
opposite of suspicious.
Their whole aura radiated, nope, not
interested in eating your brain.
Something was sitting on her foot.
Luna glanced down.
It was dusky.
But he had his eyes squeezed shut, and
his little arms and tail clamped around
her leg.
He was so small, smaller even than most 2
year old dragonettes.
Any idea where we are?
She asked him.
He shook his head mutely.
She thought about pointing out that he
might have a better chance of guessing if
he actually opened his eyes and looked
but she decided he was already stressed
enough.
And this certainly didn't look like the
Pentala they knew.
It looked more like the dragon colony
Luna had visited in Pyria, the one called
Sanctuary, which was surrounded by pine
forest like this.
Except here, there were no dragons in any
direction, as far as she could see.
She spotted an overlook beyond the
trees.
Luna paced over to it, dragging Duske
along with her.
Which was not difficult.
He seemed to weigh no more than a pine
cone.
They gazed down at the land below them.
Muna had expected to see a continent
choked with vines.
She'd thought she'd find the breath of
evil plant spreading from here to the
horizon.
She wouldn't have been surprised to
discover that she'd been unconscious and
mind controlled for years, and this was a
future where the plan had won and taken
over everything.
But what she saw instead was far more
mystifying.
The landscape below her looked.
Strangely organized.
It was partitioned into squares and
rectangles and ovals, with long, flat
lines running between all of them.
Many of the sections contained cubic
structures, giant boxes with ornate roofs
or taller, tower like things.
It's like a hive, Luna realized, spotting
an arrangement of roofs around an open
square that might be a market.
Except all the layers are spread out next
to each other, instead of stacked on top
of one another.
Some of the areas were for growing food
plants, as far as she could tell, like
the hive greenhouses, but open to the air
and much bigger.
Those seem to be arranged around the
outer edges, while the intersections were
crammed with cubes and towers, and
stepped temples, and stone paved
courtyards.
Dusky?
Luna said, nudging him with her snout.
What are we looking at?
Does this look at all familiar to you?
He shook his head again.
Luna scanned the sky.
I still don't see any dragons.
Isn't that odd?
Did they all live in the flattened out
hives?
She dropped her gaze again, and realized
that there were shapes moving among the
structures, and along the long, flat
lines.
They were so small from here that they
looked more like ants than anything
else.
But she didn't think they were dragons.
They didn't move like dragons.
None of them were flying, and they
weren't shaped right.
She tried extending her antennae all the
way to see if she could pick up any
clues.
The only vibrations in the sky overhead
came from birds.
The largest was a hawk, drifting lazily
far above them.
But somewhere nearby.
Were those voices?
They were pitched a little too high and
fast, not dragons.
Humans.
Luna scooped Dusky into her arms and flew
up into one of the trees, perching on a
branch where the needles were thick
enough to hide her from the ground.
Not that she was afraid of the humans
exactly.
But after seeing the guardian, and the
one on the throne, she thought she might
want to keep her distance until she could
tell which kind of humans these were.
There were 4 of them, slouching and
swaggering up the mountain, balking into
one another, and shouting, and breaking
twigs off the trees they passed.
One of them stopped, picked up a rock, and
hurled it at a nearby tree.
When it thunked against the bark, he
shouted, that's right.
And then 2 of the others scrambled around
to grab rocks and do the same.
The last human rolled his eyes and sat
down on one of the boulders, stretching
out his legs.
So impressive.
He said, you can hit trees with rocks.
Someone should make you all emperor.
The 1st rock thrower grinned and strutted
in a circle, holding out his arms to the
watching trees.
Not all of us, he said, just me, Emperor
Coyote.
Wait.
A shock is zipped through Luna from snout
to tail.
I can understand them.
They're speaking human, but I can
understand them.
This had to be a hallucination then.
She hadn't magically learned human while
flying around under the vine's mind
control.
Such a weird hallucination, though.
I'd be a better emperor than you, shouted
one of the other humans, leaping on the
1st one's back.
They tuzzled for a moment, yelling
Emperor Coyote, and no, Emperor Argyle
and ended up on the ground in a flailing
pile of limbs.
These humans were so loud.
Luna had not seen any like these before.
The other humans she'd met were careful
and quiet, slipping around the edges of
the world so they wouldn't get caught or
eaten, even Wren, who seemed fearless
still held herself in a watchful, cautious
way, as though she might need to dart to
safety, or fight off an attack at any
moment.
These 4, though, took up all the space
and all the air, and filled it without
hesitation.
They never checked the sky.
They never looked around to see if
anything was coming for them.
They acted like it had never occurred to
them that something might eat them.
As though dragons didn't even exist.
Luna shivered.
Do dragons exist in this strange place?
She wondered.
Why haven't I seen any?
The one on the rock rolled his eyes at
the scuffling humans on the ground.
Very regal behavior, he said.
The 1st one shoved his friend away and
bounced back to his feet again.
There are 3 empires, he said with a
shrug.
We can each have one.
He waved at the other two. casually
excluding the one on the rock.
If this plan works, said his seated
friend, coldly, Luna thought, then there
will be only one empire left, and only
one emperor over this whole continent.
He stood up, brushing pine needles off
the long, silky outer wrapping he was
wearing.
They all wore similar wrapping, Luna
noticed, fancier, cleaner, and more
elegant than anything the humans she knew
wore.
Little swirls of silver thread decorated
the edges of the wrappings and delicate
filigree patterns.
These wrappings did not look like they
would work very well for climbing trees
in a hurry.
This plan is ridiculous cottonmouth, said
the bossy one.
He started to lead the way up the slope
again.
Nobody's seen a dragon in at least a
year.
Nobody has any idea where they live.
Luna barely stopped to gasp from escaping
her.
They're looking for dragons.
Why haven't they seen one in a year?
Where is everybody?
She wanted to follow them, but she was a
little nervous about what these humans
would do if they saw her.
She thought for a moment, then climbed
higher up the tree and along a branch
into the next one, with Dusky clinging to
her neck.
Her childhood in the webs around Cicada
Hive meant she had no trouble clambering
and leaping nimbly from one tree to the
next.
And the absolute racket the humans
generated made it easy to follow them.
She was pretty sure they wouldn't hear
her, even if she slipped and crashed all
the way to the forest floor.
The humans hiked for a long time, arguing
cheerfully about some kind of ball game
before finally stopping to rest, not far
from the mountain's peak.
This was one of the shorter mountains in
the range.
Luna could now see.
Much taller ones extended off to the
north.
Some with snow visible on the jagged
claws they reached toward the sky.
From here.
She could also see more of the unfolded
hives down below.
They covered everything.
Every spot of land seemed to be cordoned
off, built on, growing something in
straight lines or swarming with the
little ant figures.
Definitely not dragons.
Luna was pretty sure they were humans.
Human cities.
Just out in the open, where anyone could
swoop down and eat them, like a giant
buffet set up for dragons.
She wasn't even sure she was in Pyrea
after all.
She remembered a mountain range like this
bisecting the continent, near sanctuary.
But they'd flown over a vast desert to
get to it, the whole kingdom of sand
covering most of the territory west of
the mountains.
And yet, from up here, she couldn't see
any sign of a desert to the west.
She could see the sun slowly sinking
toward the horizon, but everything in
that direction was either green, or the
gleaming white and gray stone of the
human cities.
We should get back to camp, said one of
the humans.
The 4 of them were sprawled around to
clearing, leaning against the trees and
eating snacks from the bags around their
waists.
There obviously aren't any dragons up
here, like you predicted coyote.
I know, right?
said the bossy one.
He tossed a net into his mouth and
stretched.
But we can say we checked it out, as the
commander ordered.
I wouldn't call this the most thorough
scouting expedition.
Cottonmouth said, in his flat
disapproving voice.
Feel free to carry on alone, Coyote said
grandly, waving one hand at the rest of
the mountain left above them, but I'm
telling you, if there were a dragon, this
close to the emperor city, we'd know
about it.
I bet they've run off to hide in the far
north.
Around the edges of the Diamond Empire.
That's where they are.
Fine with me, said one of the others.
Maybe they'll eat the diamond army, and
save us the trouble of fighting them. said
his friend.
I'm not scared of the diamond army.
We smashed them the last time they tried
to come through the pass.
And they smashed us, the last time we
tried to cross to their side.
Cottonmouth pointed out.
And they're stuck at the river border
with Empress Jaguar.
None of the empires can expand.
We're all trapped, pushing and shoving
each other back and forth, over the same
few miles of territory.
That's why we need a new advantage.
That's what makes the emperor's plan so
genius.
You keep calling it the emperor's plan.
Coyote scoffed.
But everyone knows you're the one who
slithered it into his ears.
Blah, one of the others cried, throwing
an orange at coyote.
The human deftly snatched it out of the
air, produced a knife from his boot, and
started peeling it.
The emperor is very wise.
Cottonmouth said calmly.
It is a credit to his wisdom that he
listens to even his lowliest advisors.
Well, I don't see how this genius plan is
going to work if we can't find any
dragons, said the 4th human, yawning.
We will find them, Cottonmouth said.
I am quite sure of that.
And then, he looked up into the trees
straight into Luna's eyes.
Chapter 15.
Luna squeaked and ducked back into the
branches. her heart hammering.
Dusky squeezed her neck so hard, she felt
dizzy for a moment.
What will they do to us?
What do they want a dragon for?
There was a moment of silence down below
and then one of the humans laughed and
said something mocking, imitating
Cottonmouth's pretentious tone.
Coyote and the other one laughed as well
and Luna heard the sound of them getting
up and bumping around noisily.
She risked a peek through the needles, and
saw that Cottonmouth was standing up as
well.
His gaze focused back on his companions.
But surely he had seen her.
Why hadn't he reacted?
or told the others.
Cheer up, Cottonmouth, Coyote said
slapping him on the shoulder.
I'm sure the emperor will let you chase
imaginary dragons for the rest of your
life if you want to.
You can avoid the front line for years
that way.
That is not, Cottonmouth began frostily.
Sure, sure.
Coyote waved away his protests, and
bounded off down the slope, with the
other 2 close behind him.
Race you back to camp, he shouted.
And with another cacophony of crashing
and hollering and noise, they were gone.
Cottonmouth let out a soft, hissing
breath and turned.
Silently scanning the trees around him
but not looking up.
One human.
Luna could take one human if she needed
to.
She had flame silk to defend herself
with.
What she really needed was answers.
If she could understand human in this
hallucination, could they understand
dragon?
Hello?
She called.
Cottonmouth didn't respond.
He prowled away from the clearing
stepping quietly over fallen branches.
Luna gently tucked Dusky into a sturdy
triangle of branches and whispered, stay.
Then she spread her wings, and floated
down from her hiding place.
Hello, she called after him.
Aren't I the thing you're looking for?
He kept walking, as though he couldn't
hear her at all.
Even if he didn't understand dragon.
Surely he could tell the difference
between a dragon growl, and the other
noises of the forest.
She padded forward, and poked him in the
back with one talon.
Zero reaction.
He didn't turn, didn't flinch, or jump.
Can you not see me?
Luna asked, or hear me?
Really?
She darted around in front of him and
waved her wings.
He walked straight through her.
Yar!
Luna shouted.
It didn't hurt, but it was so weird.
She held up her talons and examined them
frantically.
They were there.
She could see them.
And she could touch things like trees and
dusky.
So how did she not exist at all for this
human?
It was like being invisible, but a
different kind of terrible.
She hurried back to Desky and sat in the
tree for a moment, cuddling him in her
arms so at least something would be
real.
Dusky, where are we?
Luna asked.
Why is this happening?
Dusky looked up at the sky.
And when Luna followed his gaze, she saw
a dark shadow, descending rapidly from
the clouds.
It rolled over them like fog, like the
entire world blinking, and when it
cleared, they were somewhere else
entirely.
It was still a mountain, but a higher
colder one above the tree line, with
scatterings of snow dusting several of
the boulders.
They materialized nearly on top of a
mountain goat, but like cotton mouth, it
stared right through them, chewing
placidly.
Humans were also scattered throughout the
boulders, and for a moment, Luna thought
they were all dead because they were
lying so still.
But then one raised his head briefly
before ducking back down, and she
realized they were hiding from
something.
Oh.
Probably from the giant cave, they were
all looking at, or rather, from the thing
inside the giant cave, that was rumbling
and growling and emitting trails of
smoke.
They found a dragon.
I wonder if the dragon will be able to
see or hear me.
The growls grew louder, as the dragon in
the cave approached the entrance.
She poked her head out, yawned, and
sniffed suspiciously.
She wasn't a very big dragon, not very
much bigger than Luna.
She had 2 wings, and her scales were
orange, with lemon yellow under scales.
Small flames flickered in her mouth as
she yawned.
She seemed muted somehow, like an
undercooked version of a dragon.
I hope they don't hurt her, Luna thought
anxiously, glancing at the humans.
They were all holding sharp, pointy
things, and looked very intent on
something.
Be careful, Luna called.
Dragon, can you hear me?
There are humans here, and I think
they're planning something.
But the dragon's eyes passed right over
her, and nobody reacted to her voice
except Dusky.
He burrowed into her neck and whimpered.
I told you humans are scary.
The orange dragon stretched her wings and
lifted up into the sky.
She circled for a few heartbeats, while
the humans stayed frozen, and then she
flew off toward the east, lit by the
rising sun.
Now, one of the humans called in a low
voice.
The 3 humans nearest the cave, leaped out
from their hiding places, and ran full
tilt into the dark opening.
Luna realized that one of them was
coyote.
But he looked older, more aligned and
grizzled.
Several long moments passed.
The human who'd spoken climbed over his
rock and darted closer to the cave
staying near cover, and Luna saw that it
was cottonmouth.
He also looked older, with a new scar
cross one temple and longer hair.
The wrappings on these humans looked
rougher too, like they'd been dragged
through thorn bushes, with no silver
filigrees this time.
But Cottonmouth had new gold medallions
on each shoulder of his cloak, and a
bright green feather tied into his brown
hair with gold thread.
He stared at the cave, as though he could
drag something out of it with the force
of his eyeballs.
And then, finally, the 3 humans came back
out of the cave.
Two had their swords drawn, watching the
sky.
Coyote walked between them. carrying a
dragon egg in his arms.
A slow smile spread across Cottonmouth's
face.
He waved another trio of humans forward
carrying a box, and Coyote slid the egg
into the padded interior.
I knew it.
Cottonmouth said, bending over the egg.
He brushed his paws over the eggshell.
Yeah, yeah.
Coyote said.
You were right.
The emperor will be thrilled.
How many eggs were in the nest?
Cottonmouth asked.
Three, answered one of the other humans
missing the warning look coyote shot at
him.
Cottonmouth stood up and looked into
Coyote's eyes.
Go get the other two.
Whoa, Coyote said.
I thought the plan was to start with
one.
I want them all, Cottonmouth said.
Go get them, now.
But, sir, said the human on coyotes
left.
Won't that make the dragon angry?
I thought the scholars said they might
not miss one, but...
Cottonmouth turned and stabbed him
through the stomach in one swift
movement.
The human gurgled and fell over.
Luna covered Dusky's eyes just a moment
too late.
She could feel him shuddering all through
her scales.
Fine, Coyote said, throwing up his
hands.
He turned and stalked back into the
cave.
Cottonmouth gestured, and 3 other humans
ran after him, while the rest of the
troop produced 2 more boxes.
Luna closed her own eyes, as the 2
remaining dragon eggs were lowered into
the boxes.
That poor orange dragon, she thought.
She'll come back from hunting, and all
her eggs will be gone.
I wish I could save them.
What are the humans going to do with
them?
Dusky, she whispered.
I think this has something to do with the
human and the dragonette we saw.
But I don't understand how it's connected
to the plant and the other mind.
Maybe the shadow would take them to the
next part of the story, if they kept
watching.
She took a deep breath and opened her
eyes again.
They were on an island beach now, their
talons sinking into hot sand.
The island was small, curving around a
bright little bay, the water blue and
shimmering.
In the shallows, 2 dragon eggs rested in
a rock pool, mostly underwater.
Oh no, Luna whispered, pressing her claws
to her snout.
It was already too late.
A group of humans were gathered around
the rock pool, lifting the eggs into snug
jars full of seawater and padded with
kelp.
Cottonmouth and Coyote were not with
them.
These humans looked slightly different.
They wore sleek dark fur pelts over their
seal brown skin, and their hair with
shades of blue and green.
One wore a simple silver headband, with a
jaguar symbol in the center of her
forehead.
Quickly, she snapped.
That sea dragon could return any minute.
That's what all these warriors with
spears are for.
Grumbled the human next tour.
There's no need to kill them if we don't
have to, said the Jaguar lady.
The empress said stealth.
She said, don't let them know it was
humans who took them.
She pointed to the sand near the rock
pool.
Wipe away those footprints before we go.
Luna thought this was fairly ridiculous.
Surely any dragon could smell the heavy
scent of human this many would leave
behind, even hours later.
Are the other empires being this
careful?
asked one of the humans.
We don't know, said the leader grimly.
The spies found out they're stealing
dragon eggs, but not much else.
We don't know if they've succeeded in
taming the dragons after they hatch, or
what else they might be trying to do with
them.
Stirring up trouble they can handle if
you ask me, said one of the others.
And then the shadow flickered down
again.
When it lifted.
Luna and Dusky were in a rocky, sandy
area at the base of a reddish stone
cliff.
Halfway up.
A group of humans were hastily passing
eggs out of a cave into boxes, then
lowering them to the ground below, where
an army of soldiers on horses waited.
Cottonmouth and Coyote were there.
Coyote scanned the sky, while Cottonmouth
kept his eyes fixed on the eggs.
If it hasn't worked yet.
Coyote growled.
Why do you keep trying?
This is a pointless waste of soldiers and
scientists.
All we've gotten so far is mauled faces
and burned out laboratories.
I will figure out how to control them
Cottonmouth said.
There were 2 more feathers woven into his
hair alongside new strands of gray.
The grooves in his face were deeper now
especially along his forehead and between
his eyes.
We have to scare them into submission.
They will be my weapons once I break
them.
Coyote looked at him uneasily.
You mean the emperor's weapons?
Cottonmouth smiled tightly, leaning
forward to watch the last of the eggs
reach the ground.
There were 6 of them this time.
Luna saw with dismay.
Let's go.
Cottonmouth called.
As soon as the boxes were lashed to their
horses.
He turned his own horse, and Coyote
caught the reins to stop him.
What about the soldiers still up there?
Coyote asked.
They can catch up.
Cottonmouth said dismissively.
He twitched the reins out of Coyote's
hands and kicked his horse into a
gallop.
Coyote looked back at the figures, slowly
inching down the cliff on the long
dangling ropes.
But after a moment, he sighed, turned his
horse, and followed the others.
So only Luna was left to see the dragon's
return.
This dragon was bigger, sandy tan flecked
with black, and Luna thought she glimpsed
a barb at the end of her tail, as the
dragon swooped into her cave.
She exploded out again a moment later
roaring with fury.
The last few soldiers on the cliff didn't
stand a chance.
Luna covered Dusky's eyes and closed her
own as fire blasted from the dragon's
mouth.
The next moment, they were standing in a
stone pyramid with a sand pit in the
center of it.
Windows high in the wall illuminated
words painted in gold on the ceiling.
The odd human letters rearranging into
language in Luna's brain.
Obedience, said one wall.
Self preservation, said another.
The emperor protects us all.
Human soldiers lined the walls too
bearing heavily padded leather armor and
bristling with spikes and sharp weapons.
In the center of the sand pit, a dragon
egg was hatching, all alone.
Luna could remember a few details about
her own hatching.
The gentle rocking of the silk hammock
that cradled her egg, the talons that
lifted her free of the eggshell, her
mother's wings enfolding her, and a
feeling of light, warmth, color
security.
There was none of that here.
In this cold stone room full of spiky
humans.
One human stood close to the egg, but his
face was shielded with a metal helmet, and
armor plates covered his entire body, so
Luna couldn't tell if it was cotton
mouth.
He held a long metal stick in his paws
hovering over the egg.
As the tiny hatching dragon pushed the
shell aside and wobbled out onto the sand
the human pounced, a wire circle at the
end of the stick closed around the
dragonette's neck.
The dragonet squeaked with fear and
surprise.
It tried to turn, looking for a
comforting figure, but the human used the
stick to force it to the ground.
I don't need to see this, Luna said, as
Dusky buried his face in her neck again.
She covered his ears, so he wouldn't have
to hear it either.
I don't want to see this.
Show us something else, please.
The human prodded the dragonette with a
different stick, then shoved it back onto
its feet.
The dragonette staggered in the sand
hissing, and snapped its teeth at the
human.
Brave little dragon, trying to fight back
already.
Luna thought.
She remembered Coyote's words about
mauled faces, and she hoped many humans
here had been clawed by their small
captives.
But it was awful too, that the
dragonettes climbed out of their shells
directly into violence and pain.
They shouldn't have had to use their
teeth and claws yet.
They should have had time to be taken
care of first.
Finally, the shadow flickered through.
And now they were in a clinical box of a
room, long and lined with tables on
either side.
On top of the tables were cages, each one
with a dragon egg in it.
Luna hissed in a breath.
There were so many, 20 at least, with 10
more cages containing broken eggshells
where those dragonettes must have
hatched.
The door at the far end was flung open
suddenly, and Cottonmouth stormed in, with
a man behind him carrying another
eggbox.
In here, Cottonmouth said, throwing open
one of the cages.
I don't believe there was only one egg in
that nest.
That dragon was enormous.
Biggest I've ever seen, the man said
anxiously, unpacking the stuffing around
the egg.
How could a dragon that size have only
one egg?
Cottonmouth demanded?
And why would it hide it so carefully?
Are you lying to me?
Did my stupid brother decide to leave the
rest behind?
I'm not lying.
The man cried.
He stopped short of touching the egg, and
clasped his shaking hands together.
I promise you sir.
We had the hardest time getting to it.
I promise, we wouldn't have risked being
sent back.
Cottonmouth snorted.
That I can believe.
Well, it had better be worth it then.
He leaned closer to the shell.
Glaring at the faint shimmer of orange
scales underneath.
At least it's a big one.
When I break this dragon, it will burn
the diamond empire's armies to ash for
me.
I heard the other man began, then broke
off unhappily.
What?
Cottonmouth snapped.
I heard the Diamond Empire, and the
Jaguar Empire, are both trying to tame
Dragons too.
The man mumbled.
Cottonmouth laughed bitterly.
Yes.
No one can keep a secret around here.
But most of the dragons in their
territories are those swimming ones.
Can't breathe fire, according to the
scholars.
Our dragons will be the most dangerous
once we get them to work.
Get them to work, Luna thought.
With a shiver of outrage.
As though dragons are nothing more than
defective looms, or broken carts, as if
baby dragons just need a little prodding
and fixing to be useful.
The shadow again, this time casting them
into darkness for long enough, though
Luna wondered if that was the end of the
human story.
But at length, it lifted again.
Now she was in a field of tall green
plants.
All around her.
Humans picked interestingly small
tomatoes and pea pods, filling baskets
and chatting as they worked.
The blue sky soared overhead, sunlit and
peaceful.
Dusky lifted his snout and took a deep
breath.
Through their scales, she could feel his
heartbeat slow a little bit, despite all
the humans around them.
Then, a terrifying roar split the air.
A wordless howl of fury that felt like
all of Luna's worst days rolled together
and set on fire.
Three dragons burst out of the forest.
They flew low to the ground.
Close enough that Luna could smell the
smoke rising from their snouts.
Close enough that she could look into
their eyes as they shot past.
One of them was the dragon from the red
stone cliff, whose 6 eggs had been
stolen.
The one in the lead was nearly 5 times
that size, a huge orange dragon with
rusty copper green underscales, lashing
her enormous tail as she flew.
The 3rd was a black dragon, speckled with
red scales.
His face was set with grim
determination.
The humans around Luna screamed, dropped
their baskets, and fled toward the
buildings in the distance.
The dragons opened their mouths and set
the fields ablaze.
Luna clutched Dusky closer, but the
flames burned around them without
singeing their wings.
The plant shriveled and turned to ash as
the fire raged across the whole area, but
Luna and Dusky stood unscathed.
I knew it, Luna whispered.
She looked up as the dragons circled, now
breathing their fire on the closest human
dwellings.
Stealing the dragon eggs.
That's what the humans did to make the
dragon so mad.
Dusky.
This is the beginning of the scorching.
Chapter 16.
Luna was not sure why or how she was
watching these slices of the past, but
she could see how the story had changed
over the 1000s of years that had passed
since the scorching.
Dragons had poured it into a myth.
Covering it, like layers of tree stuff
keeping the memory that a human had done
something terrible, but wiping away the
details of what had happened to their
eggs.
Perhaps over the years, dragons hadn't
believed that humans could steal so many
or that humans could have built a society
this advanced, or that humans could be
dangerous at all.
And the humans had changed it too.
If the story in the cave paintings was
their version.
Those paintings hadn't shown the cause of
the scorching.
They hadn't included any greedy humans
stealing eggs, or torturing newly hatched
dragons.
In the human version, the dragons
attacked them unprovoked.
Luna remembered the little drawings of
dragons eating humans and burning
everything.
The humans had painted themselves as
victims, dragons as barbaric monsters.
But it was the other way around, Luna
thought angrily.
Bullfrog was actually right.
The humans did start it.
The shadow rolled them into the next
moment. leaving them standing atop a
towering stepped temple, under the 3
moons, in the center of a city that
wasn't cotton mouths.
Luna guessed they were on the other side
of the mountains, somewhere in the north
given the cold temperatures.
The humans below them were heavy furs
over snow white wool wrappings.
They screamed in a different language
from cotton mouths, but they burned just
as quickly.
This time there were 10 dragons attacking
together, burning every corner of the
city.
And this time, Dusky didn't hide his
face.
He pushed his snout through Luna's talons
peeking out to watch.
I am glad they're burning those humans.
He said softly but fiercely.
I want them to burn every single human, so
they're all gone forever.
Dusky?
This happened a long time ago.
Luna said.
And listen, I know you're upset about the
dragon eggs.
I am too.
It's awful.
But I still don't think killing every
human would be the right response.
I do, he said.
They deserve it.
Luna understood that.
There were days she felt that way about
the hive wings.
When dragons, or humans, did something
unforgivable.
Shouldn't they be punished?
Shouldn't the punishment be equally as
terrible?
After the hive wings tried to wipe out
the leaf wings, didn't they deserve to be
exterminated in response?
And if the humans stole the dragon's
children, shouldn't the dragons?
Didn't it make sense to?
But she couldn't finish that thought.
She couldn't look down at the burning
city.
All these 100s of humans, and really
believe it was right.
Even after what she'd seen them do to the
newly hatched Dragonette.
She couldn't think of Wren and Axolotl in
which they'd never existed.
Now that she'd met them, she believed
that some humans were worth saving.
Just like, now that she knew cricket, she
couldn't wish for the destruction of all
hive wings.
Maybe Sunday was right.
That silk wings are too soft, too
forgiving.
But I don't forgive them.
I just want the punishment to fit, and to
go where it's deserved.
I don't want to be one of these dragons
burning everything, and hurting everyone
for revenge.
With an awful lurch, she wondered if
anyone had saved the dragon eggs in the
human cities.
Perhaps the dragon sought their
dragonettes were already dead.
In their rage, they didn't realize, they
were also destroying any hope of finding
them again.
Luna shivered.
The burning city faded, and she was on
another beach.
But it was still nighttime, a different
nighttime.
The moons were in different phases now
and it was raining.
A wet, trembling group of bedraggled
humans were gathered by the water
climbing into things that looked like
large wooden bowls, floating on the
surface of the ocean.
Luna had seen them in the cave paintings
the crescents that carried the humans
across the sea.
Several of the humans had long sticks
with flat ends that they used to push the
bowls forward, out into the waves.
Other humans were watching the sky, armed
with swords and spears, that Luna thought
would not be much help against the fiery
vengeance of the dragons she'd seen.
The humans were probably more protected
by the rain than by those tiny, sharp
things.
One human in a long cloak, with the hood
pulled up, stepped into the largest bowl
and turned back, reaching as a box was
passed to him.
Luna caught a glimpse of thick black
gloves, and she darted closer to see his
face.
Yes, it was cotton mouth.
He must be the one leading them all
across the ocean in those paintings.
Him and this box.
Luna was sure the box held a dragon egg.
The largest one, she guessed.
The one she'd seen him bring into his
cage room.
Even after all this, after all the burned
cities and death and destruction, he
hadn't given up on his plan.
What is wrong with you?
She thought furiously at him.
If you're so clever, couldn't you imagine
a better world instead of a worse one?
Why did you work so hard on something
that would cause so much misery?
For power?
Couldn't you have put all that energy
into making peace with other humans?
Instead, and left the dragons alone?
Don't you realize you destroyed your own
world?
Cottonmouth looked up at the cliffs
looming over the beach.
Any sign of my brother?
He asked one of the humans near him.
The human shook her head.
Sorry, sir.
No word from coyotes since he rode to
warn the southern villages.
Cottonmouth pressed his lips together.
Then we leave without him.
He strode to the front of the floating
crescent and sat down, tucking the box
between his knees, and setting his hands
flat on top of it.
Other humans scurry to get in behind him
and push off from the shore.
Not quite the heroic story of the cave
paintings, Luna noticed.
He wasn't standing alone, nobly leading
them across the ocean.
He was crouched, filthy and wet, muttering
to the box, as other people did all the
work to get him out to sea.
But he did have a lot of other humans
with him.
Luna stepped back to watch as they all
paddled away into the surging waves.
Maybe they'll drown on the way, Dusky
said hopefully.
Luna knew at least some of them would
make it.
If the cave paintings were right
Cottonmouth would be one of them, still
carrying that box.
Is there more to this story?
She asked this guy.
Are we almost done?
It was depressing, being trapped in
cottonmouth's spiteful life at the end of
a whole world.
The shadow flickered over them again and
lifted, leaving them in a sunlit jungle.
They were standing beside a sheer rocky
cliff face, pockmarked with caves, and
all around them, the muggy air buzzed
with insects.
Lana turned slowly.
There were so many trees here.
Could this possibly be Pantala?
Was this what it looked like before Queen
Wasp and the tree wars?
Through a gap in the vines, she glimpsed
a huge, sparkling stretch of water.
It was still and calm, not roiling with
waves.
So if it wasn't the ocean, Could it be
Lake Scorpion?
Voices approached, chatting quietly in
human.
As Luna turned toward them, suddenly a
figure surged up from the ground very
close to her talons, he'd been so hidden
by the undergrowth, she'd nearly stepped
on him, not that he would have noticed.
Stop!
The figure shouted, don't move.
Luna found herself freezing, along with
the 2 humans who'd just stepped into the
glade.
They glanced at each other.
Then back of the man flapping his hands
frantically at them.
He was wrapped in leaves in an odd leaf
hat, but Luna realized that under all of
that, was cottonmouth.
Sorry, sir, said one of the humans.
We were going to check the caves for a
place to hide.
One of the night guards thought she saw a
dragon fly overhead, said the other.
She said maybe they followed us, and not
even crossing an ocean will keep us safe
from them.
She's wrong.
There are no dragons here, but it doesn't
matter.
Cottonmouth said, one of his hands
shaking as he pointed at the others.
I found the answer.
I know what to do.
I know how to get the dragons to bow down
to us.
He sounded insane to Luna.
But the humans heroically managed not to
look too skeptical.
After a moment.
One of them politely said, Oh?
This plant.
Cottonmouth crouched on the jungle floor
and stared intently at something.
Look, it takes over the minds of
insects.
It controls them.
These ants will carry the seeds to a high
place and then die.
So the plant can grow out of their
bodies.
These caterpillars will go wherever it
tells them to, swallow the seeds, and
then feed the plant with their own body
as it grows.
Isn't that magnificent?
The plant spreads and survives by ruling
other creatures.
By dominating them, it's perfect.
Now the humans did look at each other
again.
One looked worried.
The other disturbed.
That's...
One of them started trailing off.
Unnerving. finished the other.
Sounds like a pretty creepy plant.
Sir.
Cottonmouth made an impatient gesture.
Don't be absurd.
I can make it work on dragons.
It's exactly what I need.
He snatched up a metal implement and
began digging up one of the plants, an
eerie glint in his eyes.
Luna felt dusky bury his head in her
scales again, as the flicker came and
went, and now they were in a cave, lit by
oil lamps.
The walls were rough, and the stone
beneath her talons was damp.
Out in the tunnels, she could hear
clanging and muffled shouts, as though
the humans were busy building or digging
or whatever busy thing they were up to.
The air smelled faintly of rotting
greenery, and the place was a mess.
But something about it still reminded her
of the cold, smooth room, with all the
cages.
Perhaps that was partly cotton mouth
stepping briskly between the piles of
vines and pots of dirt.
Or maybe it was the small creatures
trapped in makeshift cages around the
room.
Most of them were lizards of various
kinds, but there was a monkey too, and a
long feathered blue green bird.
And there was the dragon egg.
Luna caught her breath.
A small crack had appeared near the top
of the egg.
The shell was edging toward translucent
and below the surface, she could see
movement.
It was almost ready to hatch.
Running out of time.
Cottonmouth muttered.
Why didn't that one work?
This one was interesting.
He tapped a sheaf of papers, and bent
over one of the chameleons, which was
lying still and listless on a large red
veined leaf.
Hmm.
He poked it with his riding implement, but
the chameleon just blinked.
Get up.
Cottonmouth snapped.
Move.
The chameleon did not move.
Cottonmouth muttered a few curses and
squinted at the dragon egg, then hurried
over to the largest pot, where several
breath of evil vines rose from the dirt
and twined together.
The egg rocked slightly, and another
crack appeared around the middle.
Cottonmouth hissed and sprinted across
the room.
He returned with the same kind of metal
choker stick that Luna had seen used on
the other newly hatched dragonette.
She watched him tug on those huge black
gloves. lift the stick and prowl closer
to the egg.
I don't like this part, a voice said
suddenly, high and clear, and all at once
the makeshift lab swirled away, leaving
Luna and Dusky in a featureless gray
mist.
Luna glanced at Dusky, who stared back at
her with wide eyes.
Who said that?
She asked cautiously.
There was no response.
Hello?
It was the little dragon.
Dusky whispered.
The little dragon?
Luna echoed.
The one in the egg?
The mist lifted abruptly, and they were
back in the throne room.
Luna had a weird moment of vertigo.
Was this real?
Were they back in reality?
Out of the hallucination?
As she realized that it was the same, but
different.
No plants covered the floor or blocked
the archway.
The throne and the columns were there
looking newly chiseled and smooth, but no
one sat on the throne, and no plant grew
from the base of it either.
This room seemed brand new, untouched by
the rustling terror Luna associated with
it.
Now that she could see the floor, she
realized it was dirt.
Not stone, as she might have expected.
Her claws sank into it, and she was
surprised by how soft and rich it was.
This will do.
Cottonmouth said, sweeping into the space
and nearly walking straight through Luna
before she jumped out of the way.
Three humans crowded in behind him.
They each carried something, a pot
overflowing with vines, a bag that
clanked ominously, and a large wooden box
with holes in the top that was making
some very worrying noises.
Luna had an awful feeling about what was
in there.
All is as you ordered, my lord, said one
of the humans, setting down the bag and
gesturing at the room.
Is this really going to work, sir?
Another human said reverently.
She was the one carrying the box, and she
lowered it to the ground in the center of
the room with gentle caution.
Of course.
Cottonmouth waved one hand.
He was dressed regally again in head to
toe robes embroidered with silver, plus
the gold medallions and the feathers in
his hair.
But I must not be disturbed.
You will stay at the top of the abyss, and
ensure that no one comes down here while
I work.
If I need anything, I will speak through
you.
Yes, my Lord, said the 1st two.
The 3rd human, who had not yet spoken, set
down the pot of vines without a word.
He looked slightly different from the
others, more like the ones Luna had seen
stealing the sea dragon eggs.
His hair was a pale shade of lime green.
Cottonmouth narrowed his eyes at the
silent human.
A moment later, that human jerked upright
and turned to face cottonmouth, his eyes
had an eerie white glaze over them, and
his gaze was stiff, petrified, in a blank
expression.
He awkwardly fell to his knees, bowed his
head and said, That's better.
Cottonmouth smiled coldly.
The human slumped, as if he'd been
released.
He staggered to his feet and backed out
of the room, bowing as he went.
The other 2 bowed as well and followed.
Yes.
Cotton Mouth mused, looking around.
This will do.
A perfect place to finally get what I've
always wanted.
He took the pot over to the throne and
transplanted the vines into the dirt
there, patting them down like a gardener
who actually cared about his seedlings.
At last, he stood up and stalked over to
the box.
He unlatched the top, and threw it
aside.
A small dragon head popped out and hissed
at him.
She didn't look like any of the 10 tribes
Luna had met, or rather, she looked like
a combination of a few of them.
Her orange scales could have come from a
hive wing or a sky wing.
But her 2 green wings curved like leaves
and something in the shape of her eyes
reminded Luna of Queen Glory.
Don't you hiss at me, lizard.
Cottonmouth growled.
He unhooked a chain from inside the box
and tugged her out.
The other end wound around her neck.
He calls her lizard, Dusky said softly.
But she doesn't like that.
She wants a real name, one that comes
from dragons, not humans.
I can speak for myself, the dragonette
said, and dragon, looking straight at
Dusky.
Chapter 17.
For a brief, frozen moment, everything in
the room stopped breathing.
No, you can't.
Cottonmouth growled at the dragon inhuman
breaking the spell.
Stop interrupting.
Our guests asked for our origin story.
And I haven't had a chance to show my
genius to anyone, since the last guardian
so you shut up.
I won't.
Lizard snapped at him.
I have been stuck with this story in all
these memories for 5000 years, and it's
boring, and I hate it, and I hate you.
Well.
He snarled.
As you well know, the feeling is mutual.
It is not though, she said, because you
did this to us.
So I am entitled to hate you way more
than you hate me.
Movement beyond them caught Luna's eye
and she realized that the vines were
growing visibly, sprouting new tendrils
and starting to climb the base of the
throne.
Is that supposed to happen?
She wondered.
I mean, did they really grow that fast?
Yes?
Lizard said venomously.
Stupid weed.
Oh, wow, Luna said.
You really can hear us now?
This part is actually happening like
right now?
Lizard rolled her eyes and stomped over
to Dusky, dragging Cottonmouth behind
her.
We gave you hours.
Now give me your memories, she ordered.
She reached out and tapped Desky on the
head with one of her claws.
Um, he said.
I...
Don't want to?
And I don't know how.
You just say yes, she said impatiently.
When I ask for them, you say yes, and
then I can see them.
Give me them.
No, he said, a little more firmly.
She scowled at him.
You're doing it wrong.
Why would he give you his memories?
Luna asked.
Because I want them, Lizard exploded.
And I am the most miserable dragon who
ever lived, and then died, and then had
to half live, half be dead forever, all
stuck together with a hateful human and a
desperate weed, so I should get to have
anything I want.
Give them.
Dusky widened his eyes at Luna.
But how did that happen?
Luna asked.
She looked up at the throne.
And the vines slowly curling around it.
What's the end of the story?
What happened?
Is he was stupid and accidentally let the
plant get us both.
Lizard hissed.
She pointed at the throne, and the scene
around them shifted.
For a gray, falling moment, Luna could
see the plants again all around her.
And the horrible tableau of the vines
growing through the human and dragonette
and then the newer room shivered back
into place.
The sensation of vines wrapped tightly
around her wrists and neck lingered
though, like the ghost of a strangling.
No, said Cottonmouth, what happened?
Is that lizard was insufferable and
rebellious and ruined everything?
He inhaled and exhaled slowly.
But who cares?
I made it work.
So what if this meat shell couldn't move
anymore?
He waved dismissively at his body.
I couldn't walk or climb the abyss or go
outside, but I soon realized that with
this plant, I could take anyone, be
anywhere I wanted.
I could be a 1000 different creatures at
once.
The whole continent was mine.
I was emperor at last of even more than
I'd expected.
Ha!
Emperor of bees and seagulls, Lizard
snorted.
There were no dragons here then.
No one anywhere except your little band
of shivering cave dwellers, and you kept
them scared so they wouldn't go outside.
Cottonmouth curled his fists.
I kept them safe.
Otherwise, when the dragons came again
they would have died, just like everyone
did last time.
Dragons, he spat, burning my vines
destroying my seeds, cutting me back, and
taking my continent, ruining everything
like they always do.
This old wine, Lizard said, rolling her
eyes.
You poor human.
Can't summon a cloud of possessed bats
anymore?
What a tragedy.
I should have wiped out your whole
species from the start.
Cottonmouth said grimly.
You should have left us alone, Luna
cried.
The scorching wouldn't have happened if
you hadn't stolen all those eggs.
That's where you're wrong.
Cottonmouth said.
Swinging around to glower at her.
Dragons are dangerous by nature.
They're too big and powerful.
They would have crawled out of their
caves and attacked us, and taken our land
eventually.
I knew we had to find a way to control
them before they became too much of a
threat.
Well, great job, Luna said.
Seems like that worked out really well
for you.
He glared at her, drawing himself up, and
twitching the chain with lizard on the
end of it.
You seem to have forgotten that I am
winning this war.
I have 3 tribes of dragons in my grasp
and soon, I will reach across the ocean
and take all the ones on my home
continent as well.
Thanks to you and your friends.
I'll figure out how to get there.
I'll get sundew, and spread my plant
across the whole world.
I'll inject myself into every brain until
every dragon. and every human belong to
me.
You will all be my fingers, my little
playthings.
Nothing more.
Luna paused.
I'll get sundo.
He said, I'll get sundew.
Which means he doesn't have her yet.
She's still safe from him, wherever she
is.
Luna felt a wave of relief.
As long as sundew was free, there was
hope.
There was still someone out there who
could save blue and sore tail.
For those all your memories we just saw?
she asked.
They couldn't be.
You weren't in all of them.
Some of them were lifted from humans.
I absorbed long ago, he said. ones that
escaped to this continent with me, and
then offered themselves to my service.
Yikes!
Luna thought.
Let's just breeze right past the word
absorbed there.
I thought the plant couldn't get into our
minds, she said slowly.
Cricket said wasp controls the hive
wing's bodies, but can't hear their
thoughts or see their memories.
That is true.
He said, with a satisfied smile.
I never told her she could get those.
She's a clever instrument, but it never
even occurred to her to try burrowing
into her puppet's brains.
Okay, ew, Lizard interjected.
She wrestled the chain off her neck and
threw it on the floor.
Why do you insist on phrasing everything
in the grossest possible way?
It doesn't even work like that.
He can't just dig them out.
It's like I told you.
One of us has to ask, and the dragon, or
human, or scorpion, or slug, or whatever
has to agree to let us in.
It's not easy.
Mostly they say no, and there's nothing
he can do about it.
Ha ha.
My human worshipers tend to be more
amenable than my dragon toys.
Cottonmouth said, tapping his fingers
together.
But I am about to have 100s of silk wings
and they are a weak, fearful tribe.
I'm sure most of them will say yes
without a moment of resistance.
Luna hoped that wasn't true.
Her tribe was gentle, but that didn't
mean they couldn't be strong.
Blue was the gentlest, sweetest dragon
she knew, but he would put up a fight
when it mattered.
She was sure of it.
They were like strands of silk.
Soft and insubstantial on their own, maybe
but when you wove them together, they
could support 100s of dragons.
I don't understand how this works, she
said, turning toward lizard.
If you're all stuck together.
Do you control anything?
Does the plant?
Or is that human the one doing
everything?
The plant just wants to spread as far as
it can, Lizard said, wrinkling her nose.
It doesn't have thoughts exactly, and it
can't do anything on its own, but I feel
it inside me all the time.
Wriggling and starving and grasping for
any hold it can get.
Any scrap of dirt in the world where it
can slither another root.
It's more alive than we are.
But it uses our brains to scheme and plan
and spread, and to control anything
smarter than it is, which is most
everything.
My brain.
Cottonmouth corrected her smugly.
You are pointless here.
A flare of rage seized Lizard's face, and
she darted toward him, lashing out with
her claws.
A long, sharp stick appeared in his hands
he jabbed her with it, knocking her back
toward Dusky, and she tumbled into a ball
and lay there growling.
I control some things.
Lizard said, breathing in short gasps.
I got myself a new toy.
She flicked her tail at Dusky.
That was an accident.
Cottonmouth hung lizard's chain on a loop
on the wall, folded his arms, and frowned
at Dusky.
And a distraction.
We should probably kill it right now.
No, Lizard shrieked.
He's mine, mine, mine.
You're a hateful bag of worms.
If you hurt him, I'm going to let her
go.
She pointed at Luna.
I don't need your tantrums right now.
Cottonmouth hissed.
We are this close to taking over the
world, brat.
I want them!
Lizard yelled, stamping one of her feet.
I want to play with them.
You go stuff your nostrils with
mushrooms.
Cottonmouth rubbed his eyebrows
grimacing.
If you can shut up and stay out of my
way.
He growled, you can keep them, for now.
But I have a lot of work to do, so they
had better not be a problem.
They won't be, Lizard said, suddenly calm
again.
Go away and do your boring things.
Cottonmouth snorted, and strode across
the throne room.
He climbed a set of steps carved into the
side of the base, settled himself on the
throne, rested his hands on his knees, and
closed his eyes.
There was a pause.
Lizard glared at the oblivious human.
Switching her tail furiously back and
forth across the floor.
What's happening?
Luna asked.
He's checking on all his creatures.
Lizard rolled her eyes.
He thinks he's so great, controlling a
1000 bodies at once, but it gets way
harder the more there are, especially
when they're smarter than like mice or
centipedes.
Usually he has Queen Wasp helping him, but
she only manages the ones she injected.
So he has to control all these new silk
wings and leaf wings himself.
If he doesn't, keep his boot pressing on
them all the time, they try to escape.
I mean, they can't, but they'll try.
And then he'll have to focus on them and
fly them back.
It makes him tired and grouchy, and it's
very funny to watch.
How are you able to speak dragon?
Luna asked.
And why do we understand him and the
people in the story, who were speaking
human?
I learned it from the dragons he's taken
over the years.
Lizard said, as if that were so very
obviously obvious.
And you're in our mind space now, so you
see and hear and understand anything we
want you to.
Mind space?
Dusky echoed.
Lizard waved impatiently at the walls.
The place we are stuck.
Where our minds go so we can talk to each
other.
We can make it look however we like.
Luna glanced to the cold, empty walls of
the throne room.
You both can?
If you have a choice, why would you make
it look like the place where you're
actually stuck?
I suppose we could do this instead.
Lizard said, in a bored voice.
And suddenly they were standing in a
silkwing playground, outside a school
that said, Weaver Hall on it, with a
balcony open to the clear blue Savannah
sky off to their right.
The only incongruous part was Cottonmouth
who was now sitting in the same position
with the same expression, at the top of a
slide.
Dusky yelped with surprise.
This is my school, my playground.
Boring though, Lizard said.
It's not real, and I can't really play
here or have real friends.
So what is even the point?
Dusky gave Lizard a wide-eyed look?
How do you know this place?
Did you get my memories?
Not yet.
She snapped.
You have to let me have them, you bozo.
But I've seen this place through hive
wing eyes.
I saw you here.
I used to watch you whenever I wanted
to.
That's heebie jeebie, Dusky said, frowning
at her.
That gives me the heebie jeebies.
Luna corrected him, and he transferred
his frown to her, with an extra dose of
what on earth are you talking about on
top?
So, you can see through the eyes of
anyone who's been infected by the plant?
Luna asked Lizard.
Like, right now, you could jump into
someone and see what they see.
Yes, she said, in that same bored tone.
Fine.
Who?
His name is SoreTail, Luna said
hopefully.
He's a silkwing.
In cicada hive right now?
With my brother, Blue?
Hmm, Lizard said.
She shot Luna a sly sideways look.
If you give me your memories, I'll know
what he looks like, and it'll be easy to
find him.
I don't think I should do that.
Luna said.
Not if that means Cottonmouth can have
them too.
Besides, you definitely know blue and
sword tail.
They've been part of all the trouble
lately.
Yeah, I do.
Lizard said, dropping the act.
I've never seen Cottonmouth so angry.
I hoped he would have some kind of
apoplexy attack and die.
She closed her eyes and put one claw to
her temple.
What would happen to you if he did?
Luna asked.
Knowing my luck, it would be too much
happiness for me to handle, and I would
probably immediately also die.
Of joy, Lizard said.
Here they are.
Luna felt dizzy from the sudden
transition to another new place.
It took her a moment to recognize the
market in cicada hive.
She'd never seen it from up on one of the
guard balconies before.
The murals and posters of Queen Wasp
still loomed overhead, and the flame silk
lanterns glowed as they always had, but
an eerie quiet filled the cavernous
space.
All the shops along the outer wall were
closed and barricaded.
From here, Luna could see the empty
windows of The Sugar Dream, where she and
Blue had gone to get honey drops on her
metamorphosis day.
The last normal day will maybe ever
have.
Instead of busy stalls and bustling
shoppers.
The center of the market held 100s of
quiet, seated silk wings, their heads
were bowed, and their wings were folded
down.
Several had tiny wingless dragonettes
sitting between their front talons
leaning against their legs.
A few silk wings were walking between the
dragons, handing out dried seaweed, and
packets of nuts tied up in twists of
silk.
Beside Luna on the balcony, Lizard
flicked her tail, staring down at the
dragons below.
Dusky stood on her other side, clutching
the railing nervously.
Across the hive, Luna could see
Cottonmouth sitting on another balcony
eyes still closed.
Are you inside sore tail right now?
Luna asked.
Lizard scoffed.
No, I'm in hive wing.
It would be stupid to jump into him
because then you'd only see me.
No, your dopey dream boat is down there.
She pointed to the exit across from them
which led to the spiraling tunnels that
connected the hive levels.
Standing in the entryway, holding a spear
looking burly and blank, was sore tail
and right next to him, looking much less
burly but equally blank, was blue.
Luna gasped.
It was bad enough to know they were
possessed by the queen, or by cotton
mouth and lizard, and the breath of evil
however that worked, but it was
heartbreaking to see it.
Soretail, she breathed, leaning over the
edge.
He looked thinner, and so tired, but so
perfectly himself.
Even zombie sword tail looked like he
might tell a funny story, or start
laughing at any moment.
It wasn't completely gone, the spark in
his eyes, or the tiny smile at the corner
of his mouth.
Unless Luna was imagining things from a
distance.
But she kind of had to. so that she
wouldn't fall apart.
Don't bother flying over there.
He can't hear you, Lizard said, guessing
Luna's thoughts.
Not unless I come along and make this
hive wing say whatever you want to say
which would freak him out and be so
funny.
Imagine, a hive wing guard suddenly
proclaiming, oh, sore tail, I love you
look at your dreamy snout.
Ha.
This is a great idea.
Let's do it.
Yeesh.
Luna said with a shudder.
Maybe as a last resort.
Can't you bring him into this mind
space?
Like the 2 of us?
She gestured to Dusky.
Lizard sighed for an unnaturally long
time.
I could, she said finally.
But it would be so exhausting.
It's easier when you're already in the
same room as me.
He's like, all the way across the
continent.
Blech, not worth it.
Please, Luna said.
I just want to talk to him for a moment
to let him know I'm all right.
This earned her skeptical, assessing look
from the small dragon.
You're really not, though.
Lizard pointed out.
You're trapped in vines in an ancient
throne room at the bottom of the abyss
and you've been infected by the plant, and
you're definitely going to die down here
and then your bones will decompose and
feed our roots.
Won't you find that pretty depressing?
Luna had no idea what to say to that.
She hadn't quite accepted the idea that
she was really trapped in vines, or even
infected by the breath of evil.
She felt like she was really here, not
really there.
She felt entirely herself, not possessed
by anyone else.
But she knew these weren't really her
talons.
She knew this was only her mind, floating
in the weird vision space that Lizard and
Cottonmouth had created.
She had been fiercely avoiding the mental
image of her body trapped in the vines.
Asel?
I'm not sure we could even reach your
brother to get him here.
Lizard went on, in such a, this is a
totally normal conversation voice, that
Luna almost wanted to throw her off the
balcony.
He's buried himself way down, even when
we're not inside him, he barely reacts to
anything.
Sortell is making sure he eats.
I thought Blue was boring before, but now
he's like a piece of furniture.
Pretty but super boring furniture.
Lizard side.
All these dragons are boring.
Look at how sad and mopey and pathetic
they are.
I thought everything would be more fun
once we had some shimmery silk wings to
play with.
But instead, it's going to be exactly the
same.
That's really mean.
Dusky said out of nowhere.
Lizard gave him a surprised look.
Not in, oh no, I didn't realize I was
being a jerk, kind of surprise.
More like, oh, you talk and have
opinions?
That's disappointing.
Kind of surprise.
Yeah, I agree, Luna said.
Really mean.
Don't you feel bad for these dragons?
Bad for them?
Lizard suddenly yelled.
Are you kidding me?
Her rage shot them back into the throne
room.
Luna felt her real body slammed sideways
into a wall, vines tightening around her
throat.
Her vision flickered from the mind space
to the real room and its swarm of
tendrils, then back to the empty room
again.
Don't hurt her, Dusky shouted.
He tried to grab lizard, but she kicked
him away from her and hissed, flaring her
wings.
Why would I ever feel bad for anyone
else?
Lizard shrieked.
Those dragons can fly and have friends
and breathe real air and eat actual food
and have their own thoughts with nobody
listening.
They aren't trapped with a narcissistic
monster human for all of eternity.
My life is the most unfair and the most
sad.
They should feel bad for me.
I do.
Luna managed to choke out, as the real
throne room appeared again.
Looming around her like rustling gray
death.
The pressure on her neck lessened.
She took in a gasping breath, and then
she was back in the false mind space
throne room, facing Lizard and Dusky.
You agree?
My life is the worst.
Lizard asked her suspiciously.
Luna nodded, trying to breathe her racing
heartbeat back to normal.
Can't we get you out?
Desky asked the furious dragonette.
Lizard lashed her tail and narrowed her
eyes at him.
Is there a way to set you free?
A low chuckle came from the human on the
throne, and lizard shot a glare at him
too.
We're only alive.
If you can call it that.
Because of the plant, she said.
We'd all die if we were separated.
Anyway, I don't need to be set free.
Here, I get to make his life worse.
She stuck out her tongue at Cottonmouth.
You are insignificant to me, he said
coldly, without opening his eyes.
He can say whatever he wants, but I can
feel what he's feeling, Lizard said.
I torment him, just existing alongside
his brain, having a dragon clawing around
in his head, listening to me talk all day
and he can't do anything about it.
All this power, and all these creatures.
But he can never get away from me, and
how much I hate him.
Perhaps you could not be a brat.
For one solitary shining minute of your
life, said Cottonmouth.
He stood up and shook out his robes.
I think Luna would enjoy a little show
don't you?
Ooh, ooh, Lizard said.
Do we get to watch all your stupid
memories again?
Could we be so blessed?
If only you had any interesting memories
of your own?
He said dispassionately.
Oh, that's right.
You died before making any.
Lizard snapped her jaw shut, and clenched
her talons.
It's time for a lovely experiment.
Cottonmouth said, coming down the steps
from the throne, rubbing his hands
together.
I know we're all wondering whether the
mind control will work on dragons from
what is it you call my old home?
The distant kingdoms?
Let's find out, shall we?
He snapped his fingers.
The room folded away, and a new scene
flickered up around them.
They were inside a hive.
Luna realized by the patterns on the
walls.
The view out the windows also told her
they were on one of the highest levels of
this hive and near a coastline.
The savannah was gold and rust colored in
the sunset light.
A flight of swallows swept in arcs around
the sky, like in a tapestry Luna had
woven for art class long ago.
Queen Wasp sat coiled on a polished
obsidian throne.
Lizards stood on one side of her
cottonmouth on the other, and crouched in
front of them, bound with the breath of
evil vines, were tsunami, pineapple, and
Kibli.
Chapter 18.
Oh, no.
Luna breathed.
She darted forward, but none of the 3
Pyrean dragons reacted to her presence
and when she reached for their talons
hers drifted through them, like she was
made of smoke.
We're not really here.
Lizard said, almost pityingly.
Except him.
He's inside one of WASP's attendants.
She flicked her tail at Cottonmouth, who
was holding his head in a weird, bird
like way, tilting it back and forth and
sideways to glare at the prisoners.
Can you do something?
Luna begged. crouching beside Lizard.
Can't you take overcontrolled and set
them free?
No, Lizard said sulkily.
And even if I could, why would I?
I don't care about those dragons.
They have nothing to do with me.
They're my friends, Luna said.
So?
Lizard yawned, showing off bright white
little teeth.
I don't have any friends, remember?
Besides, maybe they'll give me their
memories.
Luna turned back to her friends, feeling
a wave of despair crash down around her.
She couldn't just watch this happen.
There had to be something she could do.
At last.
Queen Wasp hissed, taking her long claws
against the bowl she was holding.
It was made of white porcelain, and when
Luna edged closer.
She could see a layer of green residue at
the bottom.
I have my power again.
Time to add to my army, starting with
these unusual hideous worms.
She set down the bowl, and a vicious
looking stinger slid out of the end of
her tail.
Wait, Cottonmouth said.
Wasp whipped her head around to glare at
him.
No one gave you permission to speak
malachite.
It's not malachite.
Cottonmouth said harshly.
It's me.
I'm here to speak to these dragons.
Stand down, or I will make you cut your
own throat.
Luna realized that the queen and everyone
else in the real world still saw
Malachite, the dragon.
Only she, Dusky, and Lizard, saw
Cottonmouth in his place.
The queen's wings buzzed, an almost
inaudible vibration in the air as they
rubbed together.
After a long moment, she said, You can't
do that.
I can, he said.
I don't need you anymore.
Shall we find out what I can make you
do?
Queen Wasp bared her teeth, inflict one
talent toward the prisoners.
Very well.
Speak to them if you must.
Unbind their mouths.
Cottonmouth ordered one of the guards.
Wasp twitched slightly, her claws
flexing.
That seems unwise.
I need answers from them, Cottonmouth
said.
They won't do anything stupid.
They know how outnumbered they are.
The guard looked from wasp to cottonmouth
and then the white film slid over his
eyes, and he hurried to the prisoners to
pull the bindings off their snouts.
Cottonmouth stepped forward, and the
Pyrean dragons looked up at him.
Tsunami defiant.
Pineapple, pale greenish blue with
anxiety, Kibley managing a mask that was
cheerful, curious, and faintly bored at
the same time.
Tell me where sundew is, Cottonmouth
commanded.
We'll never help you catch her, tsunami
snarled, at the same moment as Kibley
said, who?
There was a brief pause, and then tsunami
said, I mean, who?
Right.
Who?
No idea who you're talking about.
Never heard of a son, what's it?
Good save.
Kibley said to her.
Did she go all the way to the distant
kingdoms to get you?
Cottonmouth asked, his eyes glittering.
Are there more of you?
I'm told one is quite enough of me, Kibley
said.
It's a vicious lie, though.
I think 500 of me would be adorable
actually.
Three moons, tsunami said.
I cannot imagine anything more
exhausting.
Pineapple agrees with me, Kibley said.
Nudging the rain wing's tail with his
own.
He's survived a lot already.
He's never even used all his skills
against another dragon before.
He can handle however many Kibley's life
throws at him.
I am thinking about throwing you at
something, tsunami muttered.
Pineapple blinked, and gave Kibble a
small sideways smile, and some of the
green faded out of his scales.
He took a deep breath, and shimmers of
purple appeared around his ears.
Queen Wasp stirred slightly behind cotton
mouth.
There are more of them.
Someone stole the invisible one.
Moon, Luna thought.
Sundew and Lynx must have rescued her.
She wondered if there was any chance the
other 3 were here in this throne room
right now, invisible.
Maybe they would swoop in and rescue
everyone.
There were a lot of hive wings lurking
around along the edges of the walls.
That would be a problem.
But maybe sundew could smash some
poisonous flowers into their noses and
knock them out.
That would be very awesome.
Was that Sundu?
Cottonmouth asked the prisoners.
Was she here in this very hive?
And did the incompetent dragon behind me
let her get away?
Kibli and Tsunami exchanged glances.
I feel like You're not actually talking
to us anymore?
Kibley offered.
You took that silk wing guard off to do
something else.
Wasp spat at Cottonmouth.
My hive wings aren't equipped to watch
for invisible dragons.
It's your fault.
Cottonmouth suddenly vanished from his
spot in front of the prisoners, leaving a
bewildered looking orange hive wing with
red wings in his wake.
The hive wing blinked, reaching for the
spectacles on his snout, as the human
reappeared where Wasp had been sitting.
Cottonmouth reached up and clamped one
hand around his own throat.
A brief, silent struggle played out on
the throne.
This is always weird, Lizard said
conversationally to Luna and Dusky.
When he's punishing someone, he has to
jump into them to do it.
So inside the mind space.
It looks like he's doing it to himself.
He'll stop when it starts to really hurt
though.
He's a total coward about feeling any
pain.
The hive wing that Cottonmouth had been
in a moment before.
Malachite, Luna remembered. looked down
at the prisoners, then back at the
throne.
A moment later, he was crouching beside
tsunami, trying to slice through the
vines with his claws.
What's happening?
he whispered to her.
Do you know Katie did?
How long have I?
How long has it been since?
Cat and mouth?
Lizard said in a bored voice.
You're getting distracted again?
The human glanced over at Malachite, spat
out a curse and let the queen go.
She reappeared on the throne as he jumped
back into Malachite.
The hive wing barely had time to whisper
no, under his breath, and then he
vanished, and all Luna could see was
Cottonmouth again, standing over tsunami
with a disgusted expression.
See, lizard said to Luna.
Like how mad he is.
So funny.
Tsunami strained at the vines, but
Malachi hadn't managed to saw through
enough of them for her to break free.
Let's get this over with.
Cottonmouth said, before you let any more
of them escape.
From the throne.
WASP glared at him with deep, glittering
eyes.
Thin trails of dark, greenish blood oozed
down her neck, from where her own claws
had dug into her scales.
I have your permission to go ahead now, do
I?
She snarled.
Yes, Cottonmouth said brusquely.
Start with the annoying one.
Start with me, tsunami growled, if you
dare.
Hey, hang on, Kibley said.
Who else do you think he meant?
Hey granddadder.
Queen Wasp slithered off her throne and
stepped toward them, raising her tail
stinger high.
No, no, no.
Luna thought.
Sundu, where are you?
Lizard, she pleaded.
Please, do something.
Please help.
Stop bothering me.
Lizard snapped at her.
I'll give you my memories if you help set
them free.
Luna blurted.
Lizard eyes narrowed.
Calculating.
Suddenly, Kibley shouted, Pineapple, now
the queen.
Opened his mouth, and roared fire in
cotton mouthed face.
Cottonmouth shrieked and vanished, leaving
Malachide writhing on the ground, trying
to beat out the flames.
Beside Kibley, pineapples jaws hinged
open farther than anything Luna had ever
seen a dragon do, and a black spray of
liquid shot from his top fangs.
It splattered all over wasp's face
hissing like acid against her scales.
Chaos erupted, wasp screaming, hive wings
shouting and crashing into one another
the fire spreading from malachite, to the
woven carpets on the floor, to the
tapestries and tree stuff of the walls
Dusky bolted over to Luna and climbed
onto her back, burying his face and her
neck.
Through the rising smoke, Luna saw
Cottonmouth flicker into one hive wing
guard, then another.
One moment, they would all snap into
synchronized motion, eyes white.
And then, a moment later, they'd fall out
again, stumbling and blinking.
Oh, this is perfect, Lizard cried
gleefully.
He controls those hive wings through WASP
but when he tries to reach them through
her, he has to feel her face melting off
ha, ha. amazing.
Luna saw Kibbly roll under Wasp's
flailing wings.
A heartbeat away from the stingers she
was whipping in all directions.
He came up on the other side. stabbed his
own tail barb into the nearest guard, and
wrestled the spear out of her talons as
she collapsed.
Still wrapped in vines, he ducked and
rolled back to pineapple, who was staring
at WASP with an expression of blank
shock.
Luna knew exactly how he felt, and she
wished she could shake him, and hug him
and shout, pineapple, you had to.
She deserved it.
Stop feeling bad about it, and escape
right now.
She wished she could grab the spear from
Kibley and cut the vines for them.
She wished she could do anything helpful
at all.
On the other side of the room.
Tsunami was roaring and swinging her tail
around, smacking away guards as they
tried to approach her.
The flames were licking toward her talons
but when she tried to get to Kibley and
Pineapple, she nearly ran her face into
Wasp's tail stinger and had to jump back
in a hurry.
Kibble's sawed awkwardly at the vines
around pineapple with the tip of the
spear.
Luna saw him glance at the trail of fire
spreading across the carpet.
With a shiver of horror, she thought, Now
Kibley, don't burn the vines.
But he turned away from them.
So either he remembered about the smoke
on his own, or he didn't want to risk
burning pineapple.
Wasp staggered back to her throne
clutching her face.
She flickered.
Cottonmouth, wasp, Cottonmouth, wasp, and
then, for a moment, Cottonmouth was there
his human face contorted in agony.
The hive wing guards all froze, and their
eyes went white, marble, white.
Oh, no.
Luna wrung her talons together.
He's going to fight through the pain.
He can't let them escape.
Lizard appeared at her side and looked up
at her speculatively.
Did you mean it?
She asked.
You'll give me your memories?
Yes, Luna said.
If you help them get free, I'll give you
all of them, whatever you want.
Me too.
Dusky whispered.
Lizard grinned fiercely.
She blinked out of sight. and then
suddenly reappeared across the room, where
Amalachite had been lying.
She lunged to her feet, grabbed a
discarded sword, bolted over to tsunami
and sliced through the vines around her.
It was not carefully done.
Luna could see blue blood welling up
along tsunami scales from the cut lizard
made, but tsunami was free.
And now she could find her way through
the hive wings with her claws.
A moment later, Tsunami and Lizard were
at Kibli's side, cutting away the vines
around him.
As the vines fell away from pineapple
next, the rain wings scales shimmered
into camouflage, and Luna could only see
him in flickers of movement and changing
color.
The 3 Pyrean dragons ran for the window.
White eyed hive wings blocked their way
and they fought, outnumbered 10 to 3, as
thick smoke filled the room.
To her horror, Luna saw the fire reach
the discarded vines, and a greenish smoke
start to rise from them.
Get out quick, she prayed.
I think that was pretty helpful of me
Lizard said, appearing next to Luna again
with a self satisfied smile on her face.
You're welcome.
Across the room, Malachite staggered
shaking his head.
He looked around at the burning throne
room with a bewildered expression, then
turned and ran out through the archway to
the rest of the hive.
But they're not.
Luna started.
And then Kibley sent out another blast of
flames, and another spray of black venom
splattered over the hive wing guards.
Everywhere a droplet fell, a hive wing
screamed and jumped aside.
His or her eyes flicking back to normal.
A path opened to the crowd of guards.
Tsunami charged into it, battering hive
wings aside with her tail and wings and
talons, and then she whipped around.
Grabbed Kibley's arms and threw him into
the sky.
A rush of camouflaged wings shot over her
head, and tsunami turned and leaped out
into the air too.
They shot away over the savannah, into
the falling night.
After them.
Cottonmouth screamed from the throne, and
then he vanished, leaving only Wasp, who
dug her claws into her face, and roared
with fury and pain.
Half the hive wing guards launched
themselves after the escaping prisoners
but 5 of them lay howling on the floor
clutching burns or venom wounds, and 3
others had fallen elsewhere in the room.
Someone should get them out of here.
Luna said to Lizard, they'll die of the
smoke or the fire.
The whole hive could burn if someone
doesn't do something about it.
Lizard wrinkled her snout.
What do you care?
she asked.
This is Wasp Hive, not Cicada Hive.
There aren't even any silk wings here
right now.
She cocked her head as if listening.
Oh, lots of leaf wings are coming now.
Cottonmouth went to get the dragons he
can control without going through WASP.
What if Wasp dies?
Luna asked.
Would he lose all the hive wings?
No, Lizard said contemplatively.
I think then he'd control them directly.
He's already got the ones who breathed
the smoke at the poison jungle.
It wouldn't be hard to make extra sure
yet, everyone, especially if you could
find stupid sundo and grow more of the
plant.
Luna crossed to the window.
Walking straight through some of the hive
wings on the floor.
Tsunami, Kibble, and Pineapple were
almost out of sight, but dragons were
streaming toward them from every corner
of the sky.
How will I know if they're all right?
she said, twisting her front talons
together.
They're not.
Said Cottonmouth's voice in her mind.
I absorbed one of them before they
escaped.
He chuckled mercilessly.
They'll all be here soon enough.
Part 3 Talons United.
Chapter 19.
You're lying, Luna said fiercely, turning
in a circle.
They got away.
There wasn't enough smoke to infect them
before they escaped.
Perhaps, said Cottonmouth.
But one of them also accepted a drink
from the guards while in prison, a
special, slightly greenish, bitter
tasting drink, not very clever.
I mean, of your friend.
It was extremely clever of me.
This guy in front of Luna shifted, and
slowly melted away, until she was back in
the throne room again.
This was the real one, in the present, she
realized, as she saw the vines covering
the walls and blocking the door.
The husks of Cottonmouth and Lizard, sat
in their eternally petrified spots on the
throne.
Thick, thorny vines pressed into her
scales, pinning down her wings and arms
and tail and neck.
She felt like a stone knotted into a
tapestry, or an insect, wrapped up for
later in a spider's web.
When she rolled her eyes sideways, she
could see Dusky, tangled up beside her.
He had his eyes closed, and he looked
fragile and breakable, as though the
vines only needed to tighten a hair's
breadth to crush him.
Luna.
Luna, where are you?
Cricket.
Luna tried to wriggle around.
She was able to move the smallest amount
but only enough to see the doorway more
clearly.
Cricket's voice was coming from the other
side of the vines.
Don't touch those.
That was Bryony.
See the thorns?
Touching them is exactly what it wants
you to do.
But I think Luna is in there, Cricket
said.
She could be trapped.
Luna?
Luna, can you hear me?
Luna strained to lift her head.
And then, suddenly, the vines slipped
away from her snout.
Cricket, she yelled.
Cricket, be careful.
The vines.
Something seized hold of her throat.
She tried to look down before she
realized, it was her own muscles locking
around her voice, and she couldn't move
her head anymore.
Luna!
Cricket was shouting.
Luna, are you all right?
She heard her own voice say, Cricket, you
have to get sundew.
Sundew is the only one who can get in
here.
But we don't know where she is, Cricket
called back.
Can't Briny and I help?
Luna, what happened?
Is Dusky in there too?
Is he all right?
There has to be something we can do.
Please, Cricket.
Luna's voice, but not Luna said.
It has to be sundew.
Go find her, and tell her to hurry.
I can't hold out much longer.
The plant will have me soon if sundew
doesn't come.
Oh, no, Bryney said softly.
Hang in there, Luna.
We'll try, Cricket called.
And then there was a flurry of wing beats
and silence.
The pressure eased on Luna's throat, and
she gasped for air as she flickered back
into the mind space version of the throne
room.
Cottonmouth stood at the base of the
throne, with a chain wrapped around
lizard's throat and his boot on her neck
pinning her to the dirt floor.
Dusky hovered beside them, wringing his
talons.
Luna dropped into a crouch, and buried
her head in her claws.
She felt like a tapestry, with a 1000
holes stabbed in it.
Was any part of hers still real?
Did she have any control?
Was anything still connected?
Could her mind reach her talons or her
wings?
Or would it be drifting in a nowhere
space forever?
I can't believe he used me to trick
cricket.
My voice, sending her to bring sundew
into this trap.
She stood up abruptly.
That was horrible, she said to
Cottonmouth.
You're a horrible creature.
What is wrong with you that you would do
that to someone?
You say that, but you wish you had this
power.
He said.
Anyone who had the chance to be me would
take it in a heartbeat.
That's not true, Luna said.
I don't know anyone who would want to
control other dragons like this.
Ha, he spat.
Just look at Queen Wasp.
She was thrilled about this partnership.
And don't forget Hawthorne and Queen
Sequoia, who tried to do it to her.
They wanted it to work.
Oh, yes, they did.
Not to mention this little snake here.
He jabbed his foot harder into lizard's
neck.
She's a precocious little puppeteer
aren't you?
You'd love it.
If I took a long nap, and everyone was
yours to play with.
Please, please stop hurting her.
Dusky said.
He's not hurting me.
Lizard said.
She yawned.
This is all theater.
He can't actually do anything to me.
So he's acting out his frustrations by
pretending he's so menacing.
But I can't feel anything.
So it's totally pointless.
Wake me when he's done.
She closed her eyes and let out a snore.
Cottonmouth stepped off her, and threw
the chain violently across the room.
He stormed up the steps to the throne and
sat down, closing his eyes as well.
Lizard lay where she was for a moment
longer.
Stretching and snuggling into the stone.
Then she opened one eye, confirmed that
Cottonmouth was gone, jumped to her feet
and shook out her wings.
I guess we're done with cottonmouth plays
emperor for today.
She said, with a toss of her head.
Now he's going to be busy chasing those
funny looking dragons around for a
while.
She reached out her front talons, curling
her claws in.
Time to give your memories to me.
Give, give, give.
Wait, I need to ask some questions first
Luna said.
No, Lizard shouted.
You promised.
I did, Luna said.
I will give them to you.
I just want to understand some things.
Gah!
Fine.
Hurry up.
Lizard stomped impatiently around Dusky
flapping her wings.
If we give them to you, will we lose
them?
Luna asked.
I mean, do we disappear?
Or forget everything?
No, Lizard said, stupid question.
It only means I can watch your memories
the way you watched stupid cotton
mouths.
You will barely even notice.
What is the problem?
But then, he'll be able to see all our
memories too, Luna asked.
Can he wander through them and see any
memory he wants to see?
Yeah, but why would he?
Lizard asked.
He's the kind of person who's only
interested in pictures if he's in them.
He might shuffle through your memories to
see if there is anything about him, but
he will not care about your friends or
family or crushes or anything you care
about.
I'm not sure that's quite true, Luna
thought.
I care about a few things he probably
would be very interested in.
What about the chrysalis, she asked.
What if he uses my memories to catch
everyone who was in the chrysalis in
cicada hive?
Lizard rolled her eyes, and gave Luna a
look that was somehow extremely pitying
yet not at all sympathetic at the same
time.
There is no more chrysalis, she said.
Soon, all those silk wings will be
exactly like the hive wings, and we'll
control all of them.
Who cares about your little rebel group
when we've already crushed them into
dust.
Besides, only Queen Wasp would be
interested in that, and she won't get
your memories.
She won't?
You are so dense.
Lizard barked.
She is not in here with me and
Cottonmouth and the ravenous plant.
She's only a puppet, who can control some
of the other puppets because she eats the
plant, and it combines with her venom in
a useful way.
She paused, thinking, Hmm.
Your chatty friend has tail venom like
that.
I wonder if we could use him the same
way.
Luna shivered.
She could not, in any universe.
Imagine Kibley becoming another queen
wasp.
Lizard shrugged.
Anyway, she's only in charge of the hive
wings when he lets her be.
She thinks she's his equal, but she is
basically one of his big toes.
Luna thought it was fascinating.
How sometimes lizard said he, and
sometimes she said we.
Do you have, um, big toes of your own?
she asked.
I mean, do you each have separate dragons
you control?
No.
Lizard lay down on the floor.
They all belong to all 3 of us, me, him
and the plant.
But he does most of the active
controlling because he is an enormous
jerk when I do anything, and it's not
worth it.
And the plant is too stupid to do
anything on its own, except to make more
of itself.
Dusky.
I hate this conversation.
It's so boring.
Make her stop.
Almost done, Luna said.
Although really she suspected she could
have asked questions for years.
She felt like cricket must feel all the
time, overwhelmed by everything she
wanted to know.
This is important, Lizard.
If I saw something in one of my
memories.
Would Cottonmouth be able to go into that
memory and study it?
That is, like a book I opened or
something?
Could he go in and read the pages?
Even if I didn't read them or don't
remember them word for word?
She hoped that was vague enough, but
would give her a clear answer.
She needed to be sure that Cottonmouth
couldn't use her memories to copy the map
from Pentala to Pyrea.
She'd only seen it briefly a few times.
And she definitely wouldn't have been
able to draw it herself.
But what if Cottonmouth could freeze one
of those moments in her mind and memorize
it?
Lizard thought for a while, flicking her
tail.
Luna was glad she didn't give a flippant
angry answer.
The little dragon could probably guess
that Luna needed the answer to be no, and
the fact that she didn't just say that
right away meant that hopefully she would
be truthful.
Luna wasn't sure what she would do if the
answer was yes.
She'd promised Lizard her memories, but
she also could never, never, let
Cottonmouth get his tendrils on that
map.
I don't think he could, Lizard said.
I haven't seen him do anything like that
with the memories the humans have given
him.
Could you try it?
With some of the memories you already
have?
Luna asked.
Choose a dragon holding a book or a
scroll, and see if you can read it?
Lizard scowled and scuffed her talent
through the dirt.
I can't do that, she muttered finally.
Why not?
I don't have any dragon memories, all
right?
Lizard snapped.
No dragon has ever said yes before.
They just won't give them to us, and I
don't know why, and it's so aggravating.
Luna blinked at her.
But you said, The humans give them up all
the time, Lizard growled.
They think he's some kind of god, and
will give him anything.
We've only had 4 guardians say no in all
these centuries, including the useless
one we have now.
But we haven't absorbed that many dragons
actually.
There weren't any here for the 1st 3000
years, and then the ones that arrived
figured out the hive mind, and cleared
the plant from the land.
They nearly got rid of us entirely.
The few dragons we had before WASP came
along always thought Cottonmouth was
creepy, which he is, and that I'm just a
baby, or worse, his pet, like some kind
of traitor to my species.
So they never, never say yes.
And I've wanted dragon memories of my own
for so long.
She rubbed her snout, ducking her head
away from them.
You promised.
Luna didn't know what to think.
She wanted to be sure the map would be
safe, but she also felt so sorry for this
awful little dragon.
She's never known what it's really like
to live a dragon life.
She's never been part of the tapestry.
She's like a thread of silk that didn't
get woven in anywhere.
Take mine 1st then, Dusky said.
See if you can read any of my books.
Lizard turned to him eagerly, her eyes
sparking.
That's a yes?
I can have them.
He nodded, and she grabbed his front
talons, lacing their claws together.
A long, hushed silence followed, and then
lizard exhaled, let go of him, and
pressed her talons to her temples.
Wow, she whispered.
Luna was about to ask what it felt like
when suddenly she was surrounded by
brilliant sunlight.
Lizard stood beside her, blinking
rapidly.
They were high up in the web canopy, with
silk wings peacefully climbing or
sleeping or weaving in cells and hammocks
all around them.
My tribe.
Luna's heart skipped a beat.
She'd almost forgotten what normal life
had been like in the webs, away from the
hive wings, the shimmering scale colors
the soft silk under her talons, the quiet
murmurs of dragon families all around
them, the sunlight.
She'd missed this.
It was only hours and snatches, though
she reminded herself.
These dragons didn't get to choose their
homes or families or work assignments.
They're finding happiness where they can
but they should have freedom too, and a
chance to be truly happy.
She didn't recognize the nearby hive.
But if this was Dusky's memory, she
guessed it was bloodworm hive.
She turned, balancing lightly on the
canopy, and spotted a version of Dusky so
tiny, she almost couldn't believe he was
real.
He lay curled between the front talons of
a lavender and silver silk wing, tangling
a ball of silk thread with his claws.
The silk wing smiled down at him.
Try again, Dusky.
Dada. said Baby Dusky.
No, no, I'm Dada.
You're Dusky.
Dada.
He ha.
Dusky batted the ball into his dad's
nose.
And his dad snorted and shook his head
with a laugh.
The baby beamed with delight at the funny
noise.
I, dada, he said confidently.
You can be Data, his father explained
wrapping the thread around one of Dusky's
little talons.
Data is the boss.
That's me.
Data makes all the tough decisions, like
what we're having for dinner.
Bye, bye, boss.
Deske shouted.
I don't have any bananas.
You little barbarian.
It's yams or garbanzo beans again.
I'm afraid.
Dusky wiggled out of his dad's talons and
bounced across the silk web to a pile of
leaves in the corner of the cell.
He threw himself into the leaves, and dug
furiously for a moment.
Finally, he emerged in triumph.
Brandishing a very brown, rather squashed
banana.
Oh dear, his dad said, laughing again.
I guess we do have one dead banana.
Did you hide that?
And how long ago troublemaker?
Bye, bye, bye, Dusky said happily.
He pointed to himself.
Ah, da da.
Hmm.
All right.
I bow to your impeccable logic.
His dad said, nodding thoughtfully.
Dusky trotted over and sat between his
dad's talons again, cradling his mushy
banana.
His dad leaned down and nudged him with
his snout.
I love you, Dusky.
The scene vanished as quickly as it had
begun.
Flinging Luna back into the throne room
mind space.
Yuck!
Lizard declared.
Arrr!
Why?
So boring.
Boo, hiss.
She threw herself down on the floor and
covered her face with her wings.
Dusky stood staring at his face.
His claws trembling slightly.
Luna crouched beside him and tucked 2 of
her wings over his back.
Did you see that too?
She whispered.
He nodded, and a tear slipped down his
nose.
Oh, dusky.
She hugged him close.
Your dad was wonderful.
He nodded again, and leaned into her.
Crying silently.
Maybe, after all of this is over, we can
find his mom, Luna thought.
White Speck said she was shipped off to
Vinegaroon Hive.
Maybe we can look for her there.
She realized with a jolt that she was
still thinking about an after, as though
they had a future.
The image of her and Dusky, snarled in
vines, shoved its way into her head.
Lizard said we would die here.
But Cricket wouldn't let that happen.
She would find Sundew, and they would get
Luna and Dusky out.
Somehow.
It was so strange to realize that she
believed in cricket.
She knew for certain that, hive wing or
not, cricket wouldn't abandon her there.
But we'll still have the other mind in
our heads.
Even if we do escape the throne room.
I know so much about it, them, now.
But I still have no idea how to free the
dragons they've absorbed.
I wish I could talk to SoreTail.
She glanced at Lizard, but the small
dragon was clearly having some feelings.
And Luna guessed this would be the wrong
time to ask for another favor.
I wonder what's happening with the
others.
Will cricket find sundoo?
Are Kibli and Pineapple and Tsunami all
right?
Where are sundoom links and moon?
It seemed like a long time past before
Lizard finally lifted her wings and sat
up again.
She rubbed her face violently and turned
toward Luna and Dusky.
Must be weird having a parent who cares
about you, she said dismissively.
Not very dragon like.
Luna tilted her head.
Is that really what you think?
She asked.
The dragons don't care about their
dragonettes?
Lizard Meda.
Yeah, obviously, face.
We are reptiles, she said, with startling
vehemence.
Lizards don't care about their eggs.
Reptiles don't love anything.
That sounds like something Cottonmouth
has told you, Luna pointed out.
Maybe even something all the humans have
always believed.
But you've been watching dragons like
Dusky through hive wing eyes.
You must have seen that dragons can love
each other.
Lizard snorted.
Maybe fluffy little stilt wings can.
Most dragons don't, not dragons like me.
Lizard!
Luna cried, then lowered her voice, as
she saw a cottonmouth twitch on his
throne.
Lizard, think about this.
We saw your mother in his memory.
She burned an entire civilization down
because she loved you so much.
Lizard opened her mouth, and then closed
it again, emotions warring across her
face.
She was just mad they stole something
from her.
She said finally.
Like Cottonmouth said, dragons are
violent by nature.
It was probably like instinctive for her
to start burning stuff.
She fluffed her wings back, and her
expression settled on indignant.
She could have looked for me.
She didn't even try to find me before she
started burning everything.
We don't know that, Luna said.
We only know what he knows.
She flicked her tail at the human on the
throne.
Are your memories all as sappy as his?
Lizard demanded. jerking her chin at
dusky.
Some of them, Luna said.
Probably.
Lizard blew out a gust of air, then held
out her talons.
Give them anyway.
Did you check?
I mean, are you sure?
Luna started.
Yes, yes, Lizard said impatiently.
I looked at the books in one of Dusky's
library memories.
It felt like I was reading them over his
shoulder, but then the words slid right
off my brain when I left the memory.
Whenever you're trying to protect should
be fine.
Luna still wasn't sure this was a good
idea, but she had promised, and Lizard
had kept her side of the deal by helping
her friends escape.
And maybe, this is the only good thing
left that I can do.
I can't help anyone else right now.
But I can give lizard a chance to feel
what it's like to be part of our world.
She sat back, and let Lizard seize her
front talons.
She had only about a moment to wonder
which memory they'd fall into 1st, and
then they were there, in the art room at
Silkworm Hall, her and Blue, Sortell and
Io.
She was vaguely aware that Lizard and
Dusky were there too.
Perched atop the tall cabinets, but they
faded into the background next to Luna's
3 best friends in the world.
Are we allowed to be in here after
school?
Blue whispered.
I need Luna's help with my metamorphosis
weaving idea.
Io said cheerfully.
Are they really going to be mad at us for
doing extra work?
I don't think so.
But the rules.
Are vague on this point, Swartell said
bumping blues side with his hip.
Come on, Blue.
They totally won't care as long as we
don't break anything.
Stop worrying so much, my little
caterpillar.
Blue looked around at the mess of silk
and fluff, and scribbled notes, and ends
of threads, and spilled dies.
Ooh, he said.
Maybe if I tidy up, that'll make them
less mad.
Luna laughed from the top of the table
where she was sitting.
That would be too funny.
Silkworm Hall's model student banished to
misbehavior's way for stealth cleaning
without permission.
Blue hesitated, biting one of his claws.
Do you think I need permission?
No.
Luna threw a silk pillow at his head.
You walking lump of sugar?
Go ahead and tidy if you want to.
Her brother happily bustled off to get a
broom.
I'll follow him, Swartell suggested.
Just to make sure he doesn't walk himself
straight into a high wing guard.
Thanks, Hordail, Luna said, returning his
smile.
As soon as they were gone, Luna and Io
leaned over the drawing on the table.
I thought I would use purple for my color
Io said.
I love that, Luna said.
Silver waterfall, Purple Mountains?
Yes, and some purple butterflies in the
spray, I think.
IO glanced around, making sure Blue was
out of the room.
She lowered her voice to a whisper.
But I can't figure out where to hide my
chrysalis symbol.
Hmm.
Luna studied the design again, tilting
her head.
This was not long after she'd learned of
the chrysalis.
The secret group of silk wings that
wanted to change things.
Io was the one who had told her about how
chrysalis members. wove a little red
shape into their weavings, a shape that
could be a leaf or a teardrop, depending
on how you looked at it.
It was a small wave to other chrysalis
members.
We're out here.
We'll keep fighting.
We have one another.
You're not alone.
But if you added a fish to the pond below
the waterfall, Luna suggested.
It could be purple, but with silver silk
woven over top of it, so it's partly
underwater, and you could hide the
chrysalis leaf in its scales.
Ooh, IO said, as Blue came back into the
room, dragging a broom.
She picked up a pencil and started
sketching.
I wish I could do a forest for my weaving
Luna said dreamily.
Or for a truly giant tapestry.
Trees as far as the eye can see, with
silk wing palaces and playgrounds
everywhere connecting them, and all the
dragons are happy and kind, and take care
of each other.
Luna.
Blue paused his weeping, and shot an
anxious look at the door.
No trees is definitely a rule.
Doesn't it seem like a silly rule
though?
Luna asked.
He wrung his talons together.
I don't want you to get in trouble.
I don't want anything bad to happen to
you ever.
The Luno watching sighed inwardly from
the future.
Poor Blue.
Would never have imagined the trouble she
was in now.
I know, sweetness, Luna said, flicking
her tail at him.
Don't worry, I'll probably end up doing a
night sky or something, like everyone
else.
Blue exhaled with relief and went back to
sweeping.
Io was just leaning forward to show her
new sketch to Luna when Sortell came
flying into the room.
Look out, look out, he said in a rush.
Headmaster coming.
Everybody hide.
He bolted out the door again.
Io dove into one of the cabinets and
pulled the door shut behind her.
Luna shot across the room to Blue, grabbed
him, and threw him into the pile of
discarded, half finished weavings that
Miss Clorin kept in the corner for scraps
and practice.
Stay really still, she whispered.
And then she covered him over with
weaving scraps, until he was completely
buried.
Shouldn't we turn ourselves in?
He whispered back.
We weren't doing anything wrong.
Sh, she said.
Do not move blue.
She ducked behind a loom in the farthest
corner from the door.
A heartbeat later.
The headmaster poked his head into the
room.
He swiveled his snout in a slow
appraising arc.
His gaze lingering on the broom, and Io's
sketch on the table, and then coming to a
stop on the weaving discard pile.
To Luna's horror.
He stepped stealthily into the room, as
if the weavings were his prey, and he was
sneaking up on them.
I'm over here.
Luna shouted.
Bursting out of her hiding spot at the
same exact moment as Swordtail came
pelting into the room, yelling, I'm sorry
I did it.
Whatever it is, it was me.
The headmaster jumped nearly a foot in
the air.
He swung around and glared at the 2 of
them.
What are you doing here after school?
He demanded.
Thieving little worms.
My office, now.
Thieving?
Literally, what would we steal?
Swordell asked as the headmaster pushed
him out the door.
Luna started after them, resisting the
urge to glance back and make sure Blue
was still hidden.
Io would get him out safely.
Why did you do that?
Lizard called from her perch.
The memory froze around them.
Luna shook herself, and turned toward the
small dragon.
Do what?
You enter nitwit, Lizard said.
You both got caught on purpose, like you
were volunteering to get in trouble.
Were your brains not working that day?
Do silkwing brains work at all?
Don't be mean.
Dusky piped up.
They were helping.
Helping?
Lizard echoed, as though he'd said hippo
carcass.
Why?
Blue was about to get caught, Luna said
pointing toward the corner where her
brother was tucked away.
We were distracting the headmaster, so
Blue and Io could get away.
It's really not that weird.
I think it is, Lizard said.
He could have caught Blue, and you could
have gotten away.
But blue would have been so sad if he got
in trouble, Luna said.
It didn't bother me or soordail nearly as
much.
She hadn't loved the week of punishment
spent sorting and dying the new bales of
silk, but SwordTail had been with her, and
side by side, it hadn't been too bad.
Besides, we're the ones who talked him
into staying after school.
So it would have been really unfair if
you wound up being the only one punished
for it.
Lizard shook her head and made a face.
So weird.
He's just... another dragon.
Who cares if he's sad or it's unfair?
I mean, we do, Luna said.
Because we love him.
Gross, Lizard shouted.
Stop saying that word.
She sat up suddenly and grabbed her
head.
They jerked abruptly back to the fake
throne room, and in the mind space, Luna
could feel a weird thrum in the air.
Oh, ooh, incoming, Lizard said.
This one's worth bringing here.
The thrum intensified for a moment, and
then there was a sound on the edge of
hearing that might have been a boom or a
click.
And suddenly, Pineapple was sitting
beside Luna.
Bright green, and looking petrified.
Chapter 20.
Surprise!
Lizard crowed.
Pineapple?
Luna cried.
She jumped forward to catch him as he
staggered, but he was bigger and heavier
than her, and they both collapsed to the
floor.
She sat up and patted his face gently.
Pineapple, are you all right?
What are you doing here?
Are you in the abyss in real life too?
Not yet, Lizard answered for him.
But he's coming this way with the other
two, flying fast, with a lot of dragons
chasing him.
I mean, he's not the one flying himself
anymore though.
She tipped her head toward Cottonmouth.
He is.
Oh no, Luna said, her heart's sinking.
Pineapple, can you hear me?
What?
Luna?
Pineapple held out his talons and turned
them in front of his face, like he didn't
recognize them.
Why did my wings do that?
Why can't I?
He trailed off.
They met Luna's eyes.
Am I dead?
No.
Luna spread her wings.
You're still alive, pineapple.
The plant got you, but you're not dead.
Oh, he said.
I guess it works on Pyrean Dragons too
then.
That answers that question.
He opened and closed his talons again.
So this isn't real, and it's controlling
my body right now?
Yes, Luna said.
Technically, he is.
She pointed to cottonmouth, and pineapple
squinted at the human in puzzlement.
But the plant is part of him, or he's
part of it.
And so is she.
Pineapple transferred his confused look
to Lizard.
Pineapple, what's happened to the
others?
I saw you escape Queen Wasp, but then
what?
Did you find moon and everyone else?
It'll be faster if we go see for
ourselves, Lizard said briskly.
The ground fell away from Luna's feet, and
she yelped in surprise as the sky
appeared all around her.
For a startled moment, she plummeted, and
then she managed to ride herself and
swing back into an air current.
The Pentalin coastline was flashing by
below her, the ocean to her left, an
inlet to her right, a peninsula jutting
out up ahead.
She chanced to look behind her and saw
clouds of green dragons filling the
evening sky.
The leaf wings that had fallen to the
plant on the snarling river battlefield.
Right above her was tsunami, her face
grim.
Her wings beating furiously.
Kibble's sword a few wing beats behind.
His eyes kept darting to the patch of sky
beside him, where Luna knew he was seeing
pineapple.
But she could see cottonmouth floating
eerily in midair.
Doing okay?
Kibley called.
Cottonmouth tilted his head in that odd
way he did whenever he was inside a
dragon.
Yes, he answered.
A little furrow appeared in Kibley's
forehead.
Don't feel bad about what you did to
Queen Wasp, he said.
She would have done much worse to us.
You're the whole reason we escaped
pineapple.
Yes, Cottonmouth said again.
Kibley looked even more worried.
Where are we going?
Tsunami called back to them.
If we can lose them.
If we keep flying south, we'll reach a
big lake, Cotton Mouth said.
There are a 1000000 caves there where we
can hide.
Hello, what?
Kibley said.
How do you know that?
Cottonmouth blinked slowly and looked
around, his gaze snagging on Luna, Lizard
and Dusky flying alongside them.
Luna told me.
He said at length.
Oh, right.
Just your normal, everyday conversation
about the geography of Penthala?
Kibli asked.
That's right, Cottonmouth answered.
I find it hard to believe those green
dragons haven't caught us with you 2
moving this slowly.
Tsunami observed over her shoulder.
Stop talking so much, and fly faster.
Kibley closed his mouth on whatever he
was about to say, but he cast a worried
glance sideways at pineapple.
Hmm, Lizard said.
Boring.
Flat, flap, flap.
We don't need to watch this.
What if sundew shows up?
Luna said.
Don't you want to see that?
Lizard frowned at Cottonmouth.
I suppose, she said.
I guess it would be better to know before
he starts gloating like a big old gloat
snake.
The 3 Pyrean dragons flew without
speaking for a while, beating their wings
steadily.
Luna realized she wasn't getting tired.
Despite carrying dusky on her back, and
no matter how long they flew.
As far as she could see, Lizard was also
keeping up easily despite her small
size.
I guess that makes sense.
Since we're not really here, or using our
real wings, Could you jump into pineapple
and talk to them?
Luna asked lizard.
Not allow cotton mouths in there.
Lizard said with a shrug.
Oh.
One of the leaf wings then, maybe?
They're not going to catch up, Lizard
pointed out, as though this was
blindingly obvious.
Cottonmouth is holding them back, but
keeping them in sight to drive these
dragons south.
Luna did not like the sound of that.
Why?
He's bringing them to us in the hopes
that sundew will follow.
Lizard rolled her eyes again.
Is her leaf speak really that
impressive?
Luna asked.
He seems so obsessed with her?
I guess it's impressive.
Lizard said with a snort.
She flexed her own talons.
It's stronger than mine, that's for
sure.
I can maybe double a plant's normal
growth speed, but I have to stay focused
on it, and I can make plans move a bit if
I'm near them.
But sundew can make them grow so fast.
If he absorbs her, he could make her
cover this whole continent in breath of
evil within a month, I bet.
Yikes, Luna said.
She really didn't like the tapestry that
conjured up in her head, a nightmare of
vines choking the entire landscape, and
every dragon wide eyed and hopeless.
They flew onward, as the sky darkened
into night, and the moons rose.
Two of them shimmered over the ocean
casting silvery tails that seemed to
belong to giant distant dragons.
Maybe sundew shouldn't have come with
us.
Maybe she should have stayed in Pyria, so
Cottonmouth couldn't get her and her
power.
But maybe, she's the only one who can
stop him.
If her leaf speak is that strong.
Maybe bringing her into the abyss will
mean she can control the plant and
destroy it.
It was interesting that Lizard had leaf
speak too.
Maybe leaf wings were descended from
lizard's mother way, way back.
Maybe other tribes were too.
Wait, lizard, Luna said. suddenly
realizing something.
Are you controlling the vines moving in
the abyss?
Like, that's your power, not his?
All me, Lizard said, banning out her
wings and soaring to a higher current.
Otherwise, the plant can only move as
much as a normal plant.
Ha ha!
That's right, you old man.
She shouted at Cottonmouth suddenly.
I am important and useful.
He didn't even turn to look at her, and
the wind whipped her words away.
But that means, You're the one who
blocked the doorway, Luna said.
And you're the one who's got the vines
wrapped around me and Dusky in the real
world.
You trapped us.
That's right, Lizard said smugly.
He couldn't have done that without me, but
do I get a thank you?
Does he spend one minute thinking about
how great I am?
No, and that's fine.
I don't think about you either.
Lizard, Luna said, trying to keep the
little dragon focused on her.
That means you could let us go.
Lizard looked at her as though Luna were
insane.
Why would I do that?
I went to a lot of trouble to get Desky.
But you have him now, Luna argued.
He's in your mind space forever, right?
So you could let his body go free?
And mine.
I like him better right here with me
Lizard said sulkily.
If I can't go anywhere, why should he?
But won't he die if you leave him like
this?
Luna asked.
And then he'll be gone really soon, just
like that.
Whereas if you let him go, he could live
so long and be in your mind space giving
you memories his whole life.
You are such a pain, Lizard shouted.
Stop messing with my head.
She stuck out her tongue at Luna, and
whisked away to fly next to tsunami
instead.
There's something here, Luna thought.
A way to change things, a way to change
how lizard sees the world may be.
Something about her reaction to our
memories.
She had the 1st glimmer of an idea.
She turned it over carefully in her head
as they flew. thinking about lizard's
short, awful life, and very long, lonely
existence.
Tsunami.
Look, Kibley called.
The sea wing swooped around, and Kibli
pointed down at a speck of light on a
beach up ahead of them.
What are you thinking?
Tsunami asked.
I think that looks like fire, Kibley
said.
And there aren't any free dragons on this
continent who can make fire, except moon
moon, or bullfrog, right?
If one of them has made a fire, so that
every dragon in Pentala can find them, I'm
going to shove them into the ocean and
cover their eyeballs with starfish.
Tsunami growled.
But it could be a signal for us, Kibley
said.
If I were them, I'd make a fire, then
turn invisible, and hide nearby to see
who shows up.
It's not that stupid.
Tsunami sighed heavily.
All right, fine.
We can check.
Maybe the dragons chasing us will fly
right over us in the dark.
It would be nice if you were a night wing
right now.
Wow, there's a sentence I never thought
I'd say.
Pineapple, camouflage, she called.
Cottonmouth tilted his head, then
squinted as though something very strange
was coming out of his ears.
He, he, he, lizard chortled.
He doesn't know how to do that.
He's turning all sorts of silly colors.
Pineapple?
Kibley said.
I don't feel well.
Cottonmouth said hurriedly.
He veered suddenly down toward the beach
and the others swung around to follow
him.
It was a fire.
A small one, just a few branches.
Crackling quietly on an empty stretch of
sand nearby.
Moon speckled waves crept ashore and
rippled out again.
There were boulders scattered everywhere
3 times as tall as a dragon, and notches
in the cliff face behind them, signaled
caves where dragons could hide.
Hello?
Tsunami called.
Moon?
Sundew.
It's us.
But we are being chased, so Kibley
started.
But before he could finish, something
invisible taggled him to the ground.
Eep, he yelled.
Is this an attack or a hug?
Three dragons appeared out of thin air.
Sundew was sitting up next to the fire.
Pressing the ice wing wristbands together
with lynx standing nearby, smiling.
Moon had her arms and wings wrapped
around Kibley, and her face buried in his
neck.
And she was radiating happiness so bright
the fire and the moonlight seemed
unnecessary.
Luna had to close her eyes for a moment.
Sore tail.
I miss you so much.
Aw, Kibley said, hugging Moon close.
Best invisible attack ever.
You got away.
Sandu cried.
Are you all right?
Are you yourselves?
Absolutely, tsunami said.
And, Yes, said Cottonmouth, a little too
fast, but no one else seemed to notice.
We wanted to rescue you too, Sundu went
on, but we'd left Cricket and Luna and
ran alone for so long.
We were worried about them.
Links finished.
We were hoping if we got to the abyss, we
could defeat Queen Wasp that way and then
come back for you.
Make sense?
Tsunami said.
I myself am pretty good at doing the
smart thing, instead of the impulsive
thing these days.
Sometimes.
Once in a while, I'm working on it.
I wanted to stay and free you, Moon said
in a quiet voice to Kibli.
They were sitting up now, with one of his
wings around her, and their tails
intertwined carefully around his venom
barb.
But then you remembered that I'm very
clever, and would totally figure out how
to escape on my own.
Kibli joked, right?
Guess what I did.
I stood there, like an absolute hero.
While pineapple saved all of us.
Didn't I, tsunami?
Heroes and books talk way less than you
do, Tsunami said.
When we get back to school, I'm going to
start a class called Not Taunting the Bad
Guys while they're Holding You Hostage
and you're getting an automatic fail
before it even starts.
Rude, Kibley said.
Bad guys love my taunting.
Tsunami glance to the sky.
We should hide, and destroyed this.
She stepped over and swept sand into the
fire with her tail and talons until the
flames were out and the embers were
covered.
Back to being invisible, Sandu agreed.
She held up her talons and glanced around
at the other dragons.
Are you ready?
Meet at the tallest tree by Lake Scorpion
if we get separated, Link said.
That's the biggest leg on the southern
peninsula, apparently.
Sundoo touched the wristband diamonds
together and murmured, Hidden B. And all
6 of them flickered out of sight
including Cottonmouth.
Luna was left standing with Lizard and
Dusky on what seemed to be a deserted
beach.
It felt like a giant blanket of
loneliness suddenly crashing down and
smothering her.
She had forgotten for a moment, that she
wasn't really with them.
She'd forgotten that she was half a
continent away, pinned under vines in a
dark abyss, absorbed by the other mind.
And that I might die here, and never see
any of them again.
That must be the same like you mentioned
pineapple.
Kibley's voice said out of the dark.
Oh, I can still hear them.
Because we're getting this through cotton
mouth pineapple, and he's invisible with
them.
She realized.
That's kind of a weird coincidence that
you're going there too.
Kibley went on.
Cricket and Luna left us a message, said
Sundew's voice.
That's where they're going.
Supposedly the abyss is near there, or at
least they think so.
Hmm, Kibley said thoughtfully.
If everyone is able to fly.
Tsunami's voice interjected.
I think we should get as far as we can
tonight.
Agreed, said Sundo.
I'm worried about Ren and the others.
If they go into the abyss without us, and
anything happens to them?
I'm ready to fly, Link said.
Her voice closer to Luna than Luna had
expected.
She wished she could turn and grab Lynx's
talons, and they could both know the
other was there.
Like they had in the sky over the ocean
the 1st time they turned invisible.
Me too.
Moon and Kibley said at the same time
Ready.
Cottonmouth agreed, a half beat later.
Ooh, exciting, Lizard said.
The beach and the dark starry sky faded
to gray, and the mind space throne room
closed in around them.
Pineapple was still beside Luna.
He was watching Cottonmouth with a
faraway expression, as though he were
trying to unravel a tapestry, not by not
with his mind.
More dragons coming to the abyss, Lizard
said, rubbing her claws together.
Weird dragons.
Dragons who probably have more normal
prickly memories than you 2 cuddly
butterfly hug monsters.
It's going to be crowded in our throne
room for the 1st time ever.
So many dragons to absorb.
She grinned to the lea.
Sundu is going to tear this place apart
Luna said, with as much ferocity as she
could muster.
Uh-huh, Lizard said.
We'll see.
There is one thing I can try, Luna
thought to herself.
I shouldn't sit here and wait for Sundu
to save us, especially if this whole
thing is a trap for her.
I have to do something, no matter how
small it seems.
Lizard, I have a new proposal, Luna
said.
Lizard quirked an eyebrow at her, and
Luna pointed to pineapple.
If I can convince him to give you his
memories too.
I want you to set me and Dusky free.
Chapter 21.
No, Lizard said.
She added a yawn for good measure.
Obviously not.
Hear me out, Luna said.
She sat down and spread her wings.
You think silk wings must be different
from other dragons, right?
That all other dragons will be tougher
and meaner and stronger than us, or
something like that?
Yeah, Lizard said.
I'm sure of it.
Other dragons don't do hugging and saving
each other and sappy nonsense.
I've seen the ones in cotton mouths
memories.
They're terrifying.
Big and scary.
To the end hungry.
I want to feel what it's like to be the
dragon eating the human.
I want some memories that match the
enormous monster I could have been.
That's why I'm offering you pineapples
Luna said.
Oh, pineapple said beside her, and she
trod on his foot to shut him up.
That's not enough, Lizard said.
For me to let you fly out of here?
One dragon's memories?
Pfft!
Never going to happen.
But you could always bring us back
couldn't you?
Luna said desperately.
You would only be letting our bodies out
into the world.
Knowing you could still control them and
bring us here whenever you wanted.
She waved her talons at the mind space.
I feel like we're the ones who aren't
getting enough out of this deal.
The small dragon lashed her tail and
narrowed her eyes at pineapple.
I can't unblock the door, she said at
last.
That's part of his whole elaborate sundew
trap.
He'll never let you wander off, even for
a minute, because you're the bait.
Remember?
Luna's wings drooped.
She had been hoping that wasn't quite all
she was.
But I can let you out of the vines, Lizard
said reluctantly.
She tossed her head.
It's a little tiring keeping them wrapped
around you anyway.
Luna felt a tightness in her chest start
to ease.
She hadn't even realized how hard it had
been to breathe.
She closed her eyes and tried to focus on
feeling her body, her real body.
She didn't think either lizard or cotton
mouth were inside it right then.
It wasn't like they could use her for
anything, as long as she was still
trapped in the throne room.
So much for my great superpower, Luna
thought.
The wondrous and rare flame silk, chosen
by destiny to have fire under her
scales.
Ends up in the one situation where she
can't use it.
She remembered what she'd down with
cricket when they were invisible
grounding herself in her senses other
than sight.
She breathed into her scales, sensing the
places where they touched the damp
slippery vines.
Until she could feel her real talons
stretch and flex.
Finally, her wings fluttered loose, and
she stretched them as wide as she could.
With her eyes closed, she felt her way
along the vines until she reached Dusky's
cold scales, and then she carefully
untangled him too, and hugged him close
to her chest.
All right, all right.
Lizard said impatiently, bringing Luna's
attention back to the mind space.
Luna opened her eyes.
Disconcerted by the feeling of dusky in
her arms, while her eyes told her he was
standing a few steps away beside Lizard.
Big, fierce memories now.
Lizard demanded.
Ooh, you're the one with the death spit.
She eyed pineapple and rubbed her talons
together with glee.
Show me all the times you've melted
dragons' faces with your death spit.
Um.
Pineapple gave Luna an, are you sure
about this?
Look.
Trust me, Luna said.
Tell her yes, she can see your memories.
All right, Pineapple said, shrugging
agreeably.
Lizard grabbed his talons, and a
heartbeat later.
They were all standing on a platform in
the greenest, leafiest place Luna had
ever seen.
Luna gasped with awe.
It was beautiful.
There were trees all around them.
Huge trees, 50 times the size of dragons
and there were flowers everywhere, tiny
lavender ones that looked like claws, and
giant bright orange and gold ones, like
rioting flame silk, and there were birds
100s of birds in every color.
Some of them in 8 different colors at
once.
And there were glass winged butterflies
as big as Luna's talons, and everything
around them smelled like green, and
mangoes, and bananas, and mammals and
birds, mammals?
Oh, yes.
Now she could see furry little silver
gray creatures snoozing on the nearest
branches, and the air was warm and
buzzing, and sunlight through leaves was
somehow so much gentler and more peaceful
than the same sun beating down on the
hives, and, Luna.
Dusky breathed.
I love this place.
Where are we?
Lizard demanded.
The rainforest in the distant kingdoms
Luna guessed.
She knew that's where Pineapple's tribe
lived, but she'd never imagined how close
it would look to her dream of a silkwing
future.
She wasn't sure she could possibly
capture all this in a weaving, but she
would be happy to spend her whole life
trying to.
Lizard turned in a circle and stomped her
foot on the polished wooden platform.
Is there about to be a battle?
Is someone going to attack?
Where is he?
Up there, Dusky said, pointing.
They looked up and saw a huge leaf
hammock hanging just beyond the platform
cuddled inside of it, drenched in
sunlight, were 2 sleeping dragons, one
bright yellow with splashes of pink, one
bright pink, with hints of yellow around
his ears.
What?
Lizard barked.
The yellow rain wing yawned and looked up
at the leaf canopy overhead.
We should probably be done with suntime
now.
From his voice.
Luna realized that was pineapple.
He looked so rested and happy.
The pink rain wing shook his head, and
snuggled farther into the hammock.
Nuh uh.
I need more pineapple time.
Pineapple laughed.
Your entire life is pineapple time.
I'm always here for you.
Because I'm very cute, said the pink
dragon, with his eyes still closed.
And excellent at tree gliding and related
to royalty.
Hmm, said pineapple.
If those are my reasons, I must be a
pretty shallow dragon.
No, no, said the Pink Dragon.
You are so deep, the most deep.
Very deep.
So, so, DB.
He trailed off, making snoozy, snoring
noises.
Pineapple chuckled softly.
All right.
I'll prove what a deep boyfriend I am by
letting you drool on me.
Just this once.
Very cute drool.
The pink dragon mumbled.
Jambu.
A voice called from somewhere out in the
trees.
Jumboo.
Not here. the pink dragon called, waking
up again.
No jamboos, no pineapples, just as
frogs.
Rubit, go away.
Luna recognized the dragon who came
sailing down onto the platform.
This was Queen Glory, the one who
currently ruled both the rain wings and
night wings.
Jamboo, you goof, Glory said, throwing a
nut that bounced off the pink dragon's
head.
Suntime ended ages ago.
Told you, Pineapple said, nudging Jambu
with a grin.
Jambu flopped one arm and one wing over
the edge of the hammock, and gave
glorious soulful look.
But I'm tired. he said.
I watched Peacemaker and his little
friends all morning, and that dragonette
has so much energy, and it was
exhausting.
Yes, well, he could be worse, Glory
said.
Zambu, listen, I have to go to
sanctuary.
I was hoping you'd come with me.
Pineapple rested his head on Jambu's
shoulder.
Right now?
Why?
What's happened?
Dragons have arrived from the lost
continent, apparently, Glory said.
They've come asking for help.
So we're having a queens gathering.
I won't know the details until I get
there.
But I want to bring a few dragons I can
count on.
John Boo said, burying his face in the
leaf hammock.
Hours and hours of boring politics talk.
I mean, yay.
I could go in his place.
Pineapple offered.
Jambu looked up and batted his
eyelashes.
Ooh, and I could go back to sleep.
Glory shrugged elegantly.
I suppose that's all right with me.
If you really don't mind coming along.
I wouldn't mind, Pineapple said.
I'd like to be helpful.
Well, I, Jambu said, would like to be
sleeping instead of helpful.
Pineapple bummed him with his snout.
You've done lots of helpful things, he
said.
You helped our amazing queen become
queen.
Let me take a turn.
All right, yes.
Love you.
Bye.
Jambu said, wriggling all the way back
into the hammock.
Pineapple laughed as he extricated
himself.
Once he was hovering in the air beside
the hammock, he reached in and squeezed
one of Jambu's talons.
I'll miss you too.
Deep and noble.
John Boo mumbled sleepily.
Thanks, pineapple.
Glory said, moving a small blue
salamander off her tail.
Hopefully, you'll be home and sleeping in
the sun again in no time.
The memory drifted away like morning mist
slower than the others, leaving the ghost
of the scent of jasmine in the mind
space.
Talons and tentacles!
Lizard yelled, making them all jump.
That was even worse than yours.
She clamped her talons to her temples and
scrunched her eyes shut.
Luna glanced over at pineapple, but he'd
gone back to his far away, undoing knots
in his brain expression.
They'd flown together for 3 days, and he
hadn't let on that he was missing someone
back at home.
He'd always acted so cheerful and even
keeled.
He might have been really sad all that
time, and I had no idea.
I wish he'd told me.
We could have talked about Jambu and Sore
Tail.
At the very least, I could have given him
a hug or told him I understood.
Or said thank you, for coming all this
way and risking so much, to help save
someone I love the way he loves Jambu.
We're going to get you home, pineapple
she said.
I don't know how, but I promise you'll
see him again.
He blinked, as if he were coming out of a
fog.
And then he looked down at her and
smiled.
Little rays of yellow bloomed all around
his scales.
I know, he said.
I will.
None!
Lizard exploded.
She stormed over to pineapple, and
deliberately stommed on one of his feet.
He took a polite step back as she kept
shouting, not one single face melting.
What is wrong with you?
You have death spit?
And instead of using it for something
cool, like melting the faces of your
enemies.
You spend all of your time, cuddling, and
eating chocolate, and making up songs
about pandas with your boyfriend.
Oh, wow.
Luna said, thinking about the rainforest
again.
She'd only had chocolate twice before, and
it was almost as wonderful as honey
drops.
That sounds like the perfect life.
I don't have any enemies.
Pineapple told lizard mildly.
At least, until Queen Wasp, and that was
quite stressful, actually.
I think you might be overestimating the
awesomeness of face melting.
You literally make no sense.
Lizard huffed away, across the throne
room, and threw herself into a petulant
sulk in the corner.
Luna tried sensing her real body again.
She opened and closed her wings, and felt
the weight of Dusky in her arms, still
free.
So at least a lizard hadn't taken out her
anger on them by snaring them in the
vines again.
When she opened her eyes, Pineapple was
watching her curiously.
Why did you let that dragonette think
she'd find scary memories in my head?
He asked quietly.
Because that's what she expects to find
Luna said.
But I want her to see that dragons are
not what she thinks.
I want her to know what it really feels
like to live a dragon life, which is
something she never got to do.
I want to weave her into our tapestry, she
thought.
But she wasn't sure if that would sound
too mystical and fluffy to pineapple.
Aw, pineapple said, poor little dragon.
And I'm hoping she sees that dragons
mostly want to take care of each other
and love, and be loved, and not fight all
the time, or hurt anyone.
Luna hesitated and took a breath.
At least, I hope that's what most dragons
are like.
Sometimes I'm not sure.
I mean, I'm not sure about hive wings, I
guess.
Pineapple nodded.
I know exactly what you mean.
That's how I felt about Nightwings when
they 1st came to the rainforest.
They'd done all these terrible things, and
they thought they were the only dragons
worth caring about, and that everything
should belong to them, and they should
get to decide how all other dragons lived
their lives.
I thought they were too different from us
and they'd only cause trouble.
He looked down at his talons.
I didn't see how we could even start
forgiving them.
Did you?
Luna asked.
It's a work in progress, he said, with a
rueful smile.
But they're more like us than I
expected.
They wanted to live somewhere safe and
take care of their families.
We just had to make it really clear to
them that they should treat dragons
equally, even if they're from different
tribes, and that glory was their queen
now, and that they had to work to atone
for everything they did.
There are some night wings.
I don't know if I'd call them friends
yet.
But I can see that they're trying to be
better.
Hmm.
Luna found it almost impossible to
imagine trusting any hive wings who
weren't cricket.
Pineapple lifted his head and twitched
his ears.
Do you hear that?
Is it cricket coming back?
Luna asked.
Oh, wait.
No.
You're not where I am in the real world.
What is it?
I thought I heard someone say my name, he
said.
Turning slowly in a circle.
Hello?
Pineapple?
I heard at that time, Luna said
startled.
I'm here, Pineapple said.
I'm in here.
Down here.
Hmm.
I'm right here.
Oh, there.
Found you, Moon said, appearing next to
him.
That was very confusing.
She blinked at the throne room, the small
dragons staring at her, the silent human
on the throne, and finally, at Luna.
Um, where are we?
Chapter 22.
Oh, no.
Luna cried.
Moon, what happened?
How did the plant get you?
The planned?
Moon said, her eyes going slightly
unfocused.
I don't.
We don't have her, Lizard said.
She stood up and came over to peer at
Moon.
We haven't absorbed this one.
What in the moons?
How are you here?
Kibli, shh.
Moon said to the air, then shook her
head.
Pineapple.
There's something else in your head, isn't
there?
I had to kind of um, slide around it to
find you.
He nodded, and she touched one of his
talons.
The other mind got you.
But how?
I think it was a drink.
They gave me while we were in the Wasp
Hive Prison, he said.
Sorry, I should have been more
suspicious.
I bet Kibli and Tsunami didn't drink it.
Moon.
Luna said insistently.
Talk to me.
How are you doing this?
The Night Wing scratched her head and
peered at Luna.
Are you really here?
Actually, Luna?
Yes, Pineapple answered.
Well, the other mind controls my body.
My own mind was brought here.
I think it's a mental construct.
Like, an imaginary space where several
minds can meet, as though it's a real
place.
The other mind seems to be 3 minds woven
together.
The plants, humans, and a young dragons.
He nodded at Lizard.
Ha, Lizard said.
Unlike 5000 years old, you snoozy
gorilla.
And Luna is here too, Pineapple said.
So she must have been caught and taken
over by the other mind as well.
Watch out, if you run into her in the
real world.
You won't, Luna said.
I'm in the abyss.
Moon, how are you here?
The Night Wing hesitated again for a
painfully long time, and then she said
all in a rush.
Don't be mad, I can read minds.
What?
You...
I thought you could see the future, Luna
blurted.
I can do that too.
Moon squirmed uncomfortably.
I didn't know how to tell you.
It's hard to bring up, and then the
longer I don't tell someone, the weirder
it gets.
I'm still bad at dealing with it.
It's one of the many things wrong with
me.
I'm sorry, Luna.
If it makes you feel any better, Pineapple
offered, I just found out too.
Bullfrog and Sky and Lynx don't know
either.
Moon said with a wince.
Queen Glory thinks we should keep it
pretty quiet as long as we can.
The whole time, on the beach, and in
sanctuary, and when we were flying back
here, you could hear all my thoughts?
Everything I was thinking?
Luna's head was spinning.
I try not to, Moon said.
I've gotten better at filtering out most
dragons.
I mean, it feels like 100 conversations
going on all around me at once.
So I've had to learn how to make it
quieter.
Unless you're directly thinking at me, I
usually can avoid hearing it.
Three moons.
Luna had thought all kinds of things at
Moon.
She didn't know whether she felt more
angry at Moon for keeping this secret or
guilty about all the mean things she'd
ever thought around her.
While she was struggling to figure out
what to say.
Pineapple brushed Moon's wing with his.
So right now you're, he prompted, we
stopped to get some sleep, she said.
And Kibble asked me to check your mind
because he said you've been acting
weird.
Oh, pineapple, what do we do now?
Time me up and leave me behind, Pineapple
said.
I'm dangerous, as long as he's...
A strangled roar of fury came from the
throne.
Cottonmouth's consciousness was back, and
he'd finally spotted Moon.
He shot to his feet and pointed at her.
How?
he bellowed.
What sorcery is this?
Uh-oh, Moon said, and vanished.
Cottonmouth roared again and slammed one
of his fists into the stone behind him
cracks like lightning zigzagged out from
the impact.
Not real.
Lizard whispered to Dusky.
So melodramatic.
What is he doing?
Luna asked anxiously, as Cottonmouth's
eyes closed.
Lizard, is he hurting pineapple or moon
in the real world?
Can we see what's happening?
Lizard shrugged, and flung their minds
down on a dark beach.
Rain was pouring from the sky and
thunders seem to be coming from
everywhere at once.
Wet talon prints were scuffling outside a
nearby cave, and Luna remembered that all
these dragons were currently invisible.
She ran toward the sound of shouting.
Everyone wake up!
Kibley was yelling.
Pineapple has the other mind in his
head.
That's not true.
Cottonmouth shouted back.
Moon does.
She's the one who's been infected.
She's lying to you.
There was a sound of claws connecting
with scales and a gasp of pain.
Moon?
Kibley cried frantically.
Where is he?
Tsunami roared.
Kibli, where's pineapple?
I think he's.
Kibley's voice cut out with a yelp.
Sundo.
We need to see him.
Lynx's voice said urgently.
Use the bracelets, and then make everyone
but pineapple invisible again.
A flash of lightning illuminated the
beach as 6 dragons appeared.
Sundew in the opening of the cave
pressing the wristbands together, links
right behind her, wings touching, Kibley
on the sand outside, a long, bloody slash
along his neck, tsunami, a few steps
away.
Crouched and ready to pounce.
Moon in motion, darting away from the
cave into the boulders, and cottonmouth
inside pineapple, reared up tall and
hissing, slashing the air in front of
him.
Don't attack him.
Kibli yelled to tsunami.
He'll use his venom.
Sundu, quick, now.
Leng shrieked.
Cottonmouth whipped around, fast as a
cobra, and launched himself at sundew.
Lynx darted forward at the same moment
and shot a blast of freezing air at his
face.
He rolled out of the way just barely in
time, so it hit his shoulder instead, and
he roared with rage and spun to attack
her, and then 5 of the dragons vanished
again.
No, Cottonmouth howled.
He leaped for the spot where sundew had
been, and his talons closed on empty
air.
You need me.
He whirled and put his back against the
rock wall, seething.
I have your flame silk.
I'll kill her right now if you fly away.
Uh-oh, Lizard said.
Conversationally to Luna.
I might have to strangle you after all.
Couldn't you not do what he wants?
Luna burst out.
Don't you hate him enough to always do
the opposite of what he says?
Don't you want to fight him?
Lizard scowled.
Shut up.
She said with a snarl.
I do what I want when I know what I
want.
But what he does works too.
I wanted dragon memories, and now I have
them, even though they're stupid.
And the whole reason I have them is
because of his sneaky plans.
Why should I fight?
There's nothing to fight for.
Luna's friends reappeared on the beach.
In a semicircle around pineapple, but
several paces away.
Kibley was the closest.
In his talons, he held a sharp wooden
stick, which he lit on fire and pointed
at pineapple.
Opposite him in the half circle, Lynx had
her jaws hinged open, ready to shoot ice
again.
But Cotton Mouth's gaze went straight to
sundew. standing directly across from
him.
Are you lying?
Sundu asked.
No.
I have Luna, he said.
Ask your devil creature.
He nodded at Moon.
It's true.
Moon said.
Luna was there, in the mind space, with
real pineapple.
Does it have cricket and sky too?
Sundu asked.
Moon shook her head.
How did you catch Luna?
She asked Cottonmouth.
She flew into the abyss and threw herself
into my vines.
Cottonmouth said nastily.
Perhaps she was trying to prove what they
say about the tiny, tiny brains of silk
wings.
She's still alive.
But if you want her to stay that way
you'll come down here and join her.
Luna lashed her tail.
Don't listen to him, she said, even
though she knew they couldn't hear her.
Sundew and Kibley exchanged glances.
You want us to come to the abyss, Kibble
clarified.
Will you let Luna go?
If we do, Sundu asked.
Certainly.
Cottonmouth said, with a magnanimous
sweep of his arms.
I will allow her to fly right back out
into the open sky.
In exchange for one of you.
I think you know who I mean.
Not going to happen.
Tsunami growled.
Sandu made a little wait, gesture at
her.
We had been planning a trip to the Abyss
anyway, she said.
How about this?
You lead us there, and we'll see what
happens.
Sundo, Link said worriedly.
Sounds interesting.
Cottonmouth said, his eyes glittering.
Sundew pointed at him.
You fly ahead of us.
The rest of us will be invisible, so none
of your zombies can show up and grab us.
When we get to the abyss, I'll go down
with you.
Nobody else.
R, no, Kibley started, and Links said
sundo, again, and tsunami growled, but
Cottonmouth said, agreed.
He looked up at the sky.
The rain is slowing.
Shall we go now?
Sundew looked at Moon.
Is pineapple all right in there?
Will he be okay if we keep flying now?
Moon's gaze drifted vaguely over Sundew's
shoulder.
And Luna realized, she'd seen that look
on Moon's face a 1000000 times.
That's her.
Listening to thoughts expression.
Or distracted by other dragon's thoughts
I guess.
She must be talking to pineapple in the
mind space.
He says yes.
Moon reported.
Her eyes focusing again.
He says go save Luna.
It's not about me.
Luna couldn't stop herself from
protesting.
You have to come destroy the plant.
She reached for the leaf wing
hopelessly.
Sundo, please don't let him catch you.
You're the only one who can stop him.
But Sundu couldn't hear her.
And Luna's claws drifted through her
friend, as ineffective as smoke.
Chapter 23.
See?
That's the thing, Lizard said, shifting
them back into the mind space.
She tossed her head at Luna.
You tell me to fight cottonmouth, but all
you really want is to kill the plant
which means killing me too.
Of course I'm going to stick with a
monster who's at least got a reason to
keep me alive.
Luna sighed.
Lizard was right.
If Sundew managed to crush the plant with
her leaf speak, then lizard's
consciousness would die, along with a
plant and cotton mouth.
Luna crouched on the floor of the mind
space temple, and traced a tree in the
dirt with her claws.
Her idea about giving lizard real dragon
memories, hadn't quite worked the way
she'd hoped.
She'd wanted to give Lizard a feeling of
connection, and some understanding of
dragons from a dragon point of view.
Instead of cotton mouths, twisted
perspective.
It had worked for Luna.
She felt closer to Dusky and Pineapple
even with only those two short memories.
And seeing the rainforest, made Luna feel
so hopeful.
She loved knowing that somewhere like
that existed, and that it was possible to
live peacefully and kindly.
If they survived Queen Wasp and the other
mind.
The Silk Wings could try to build a home
like that.
But perhaps, it only made Lizard feel
worse.
Or even less connected, knowing she'd
never get to go there, or have that kind
of life.
I'm sorry about our memories, lizard, she
said.
You should be, Lizard said, dragging
Dusky over and plunking them both down
beside Luna.
The angry little dragon drew a circle in
the dirt, and Dusky leaned over to add
sun rays around it.
You all seem to spend your time doing
things for other dragons, or hugging.
So much hugging.
Yeesh.
She gave a little shudder.
Dusky drew a snaking line in front of her
and Lizard added wings to it.
It's just my luck that the 3 most boring
dragons ever are the ones who agree to
give me their memories.
Actually, I meant I'm sorry if our
memories made you sad.
Luna offered.
Lizard gave her the most outraged look
Luna had ever seen.
I'm not sad.
They didn't make me sad.
What a weird thing to say.
Why would I be sad?
Because no one's ever hugged you?
Dusky guessed.
I don't care about that.
Lizard shoved him over, so he toppled on
his side.
I never got to set anyone on fire.
I never got to fly into battle, or eat a
human, or stab anyone even once.
That's what I'm sad about.
Real dragon stuff.
Except, I'm not sad.
Shut up.
Hugs are better than all of that, Dusky
said, sitting himself up again.
I barf at you.
Lizard snapped.
Do you want one?
Dusky asked.
Maybe you'll like them better if you get
a real hug.
It won't be real.
Lizard barked.
Nothing about this is real.
But It would be close, right?
He said.
Can I hug you?
She scowled ferociously.
Then wrapped her wings around herself and
hunched her shoulders.
Fine.
But only if you promise to shut up about
hugs and sad feelings from now on.
Dusky didn't have wings to hug with yet
but even as tiny as he was, he was still
bigger than lizard.
His arms fit around her folded wings, and
he rested his chin on the top of her
head.
Humph.
Lizard muttered after a moment.
Stupid.
But she didn't push him away.
Luna watched them for a moment.
Wondering how it felt to be hugged for
the 1st time, in a 5000 year half life
and whether lizards saw the world any
differently, with all of pineapples and
duskies and Luna's memories in her head.
Luna crossed the room and crouched beside
pineapple.
I think we need more memories.
She said to him in a low voice.
He blinked out her sleepily.
For lizard.
Didn't we give her all of ours?
Yes, but I think it wasn't enough.
She can convince herself that we're
different from other dragons, because of
our tribes, but that most dragons are the
way she thinks they are.
We need to show her memories from more
different tribes.
Luna dug her talons into the dirt.
I don't know how to get them, though.
I mean, I'm not volunteering anyone to
get absorbed by the plant.
They already have lots of hive wings
don't they?
he asked.
Maybe one of them would let her have his
memories.
But what if their memories are as bad as
she expects the dragons to be?
Luna worried.
That would reverse everything I'm trying
to do.
She thought for a moment, then said
slowly, What if could Moon help?
I don't know how mind reading works, but
maybe?
She's been checking in with me, he said.
I'll ask when she comes back.
Thanks, pineapple.
He smiled, and brushed one of her wings
with his.
Luna closed her eyes, reached through her
scales until she sensed her real body, and
hugged Desky closer, hoping he could feel
it somehow.
In her real body.
She felt the slippery twists and tangles
of vines underneath her.
What else can I do?
Her wrists felt warm, and she was sure
they were glowing brightly in the dim
gray green tomb.
Why would the prophecy send me down
here?
Why would the universe give me flame silk
and put me in front of a monster, if I'm
not supposed to use it?
Maybe because I'm not the one who's
supposed to change the world after all.
Maybe.
I'm supposed to sit here. and wait to be
rescued, again.
She sank her real claws into the vines
and felt sap ooze around the holes she
left.
If I set these vines on fire, would the
smoke really rise all the way to Bryony's
group of dragons?
Would everyone in the caves be infected
and absorbed?
But if the fire destroyed all of the
plant down here, there'd be nothing left
to control anyone, would there?
She wasn't sure, it was safe to take that
chance.
What if the other mind could live on and
use its power, as long as any plant roots
survived anywhere?
Lizard.
Pineapple said.
We can get you more memories, if you want
them.
Luna opened her eyes, and saw him crouch
beside Lizard, who had wiggled out of
Desky's hug, but was still sitting near
him, tails lightly touching.
Moon was there too.
Hovering at pineapple side, with her gaze
fixed nervously on cotton mouth.
You can?
Lizard sat up.
How?
Did you infect the others?
No, Pineapple said, giving her a serious
look.
That's not going to happen.
But we think moon can be a conduit.
It wouldn't give you all of someone's
memories, but she can connect to the
others flying with her, and they could
each choose a memory to share with you.
He glanced at the silent human on the
throne.
Just you, possibly.
Not totally sure how this will work.
Yes, yes, Lizard said immediately, holding
out her talons.
Give, give.
Wait.
She pulled back and eyed him with
suspicion.
What do you want for them?
I can't let Luna go.
He shrugged.
No trade.
We're flying right now, so it should be
easy to do.
And Luna said they might make you happy
so... why not?
That sentence seemed to puzzle lizard
into silence.
She looked down at the dirt, where she
had drawn an awkward looking butterfly.
Beside it, Dusky had drawn another.
With their wings touching.
Fine, Lizard said.
Whatever, sure.
I'll take it.
She held out her talons.
Pineapple took one, and Dusky took the
other.
Moon slid pineapple's other talon between
hers, and Luna took Dusky's free talon
forming a chain.
Wait, Lizard said, as Moon closed her
eyes.
I only want something fierce, no
hugging.
Suddenly they were back in the
rainforest.
But now it was nighttime, with the 3
moons spread out across the sky.
This was blurrier than the other memories
like paint on glass, or like a sketch
left out in the rain.
The frogs and insects and trees.
All seem to be holding competing
orchestras, filling the forest with
noise.
A tiny black dragon, no bigger than
lizard, was sitting in a pool of
moonlight, gazing up at the stars.
Imperial.
She whispered, pointing to the biggest
moon.
Her claw traced across the sky to the
next one.
Oracle and perception.
She brought her talons down and wrapped
her wings around herself.
I remembered.
She looked up at Oracle and whispered
Mother will be here soon.
A moment passed, and then she looked away
from the moon.
Well, she said she'd try.
The small black wings fluttered.
If she doesn't come tonight, she'll come
tomorrow.
Or the next day.
Another pause.
She'll always come back.
Luna didn't know.
If she was somehow feeling Moon's
emotions too.
But the loneliness was almost
overwhelming.
This dragon was so small to be alone in
this wild, noisy place.
Another moment, and then little moon said
even more quietly.
I'll be all right.
A cold wind whisked around Luna's talons
and the warm rainforest folded aside
replaced by rolling hills of endless
snow.
Someone had built a small snow fort.
Probably one of the 5 white and blue
dragonettes running around it. and
fortified it with frost breath to make it
shine in the winter sunlight.
This is our fort, shouted one of the
dragonettes, scaling the wall and sitting
on top of it, glaring down.
She wore a lopsided tiara talon made out
of icicles.
Go make your own.
No, I think we'll take this one, said the
biggest dragonette.
He nudged the dragon next to him, and she
pounced on the smallest dragonette.
Ha, ha.
And now we have a hostage.
The captured dragonette squeaked and
wriggled.
Luna recognized the pattern of blue
scales freckled across her snout.
This one was lynx.
Surrender the fort, snowfall, or we'll
toss her in the ocean.
And maybe the walruses will eat her
cackled the one who had lynx pinned
down.
Do your worst, Snowfall shouted.
You took the wrong hostage.
Lynx can swim better than either of you
and she's not afraid of walruses.
Write links.
Lynx managed to rest her snout free long
enough to yell.
Walruses are adorable, boss.
Before her captor stuffed her head back
into the snow.
The 5th dragonette suddenly surged over
the wall of the fort, pelting the 2
hostage takers with snowballs.
Let her go, he shouted, we never leave a
dragon behind.
Winter, Snowfall said, with an aggravated
sigh as the biggest dragonette easily
knocked him over.
Lingx doesn't need rescuing.
This is why I don't play with you, because
you play all wrong.
I'm going to switch to Hellstorm side, if
you keep doing stupid heroic things.
Look, see?
Now I'll have to rescue you.
A gust of wind blew snow in Luna's face
and as it melted away, so did the fort
and the ice wings, and the frozen
landscape, leaving them in the streets of
a busy dragon town, baking in heat.
When I try to remember being lizards
age.
Well, lizards size.
My memories are short and blurry too.
Luna thought, turning to try to guess
where they were, and whose memory this
was.
Then a crowd of sand wings ran by
shouting, Fight, fight, fight!
And she realized, this must be Kibley's.
Maybe this will be fierce enough for
Lizard, she thought. hurrying after
them.
You took it from him, a voice yelled.
So what?
Another voice shouted back.
I'm big and he's small.
That's how it works.
The dragons were gathering outside a
cluster of market stalls, a tea shop, one
selling candles, another hung with dried
herbs and flowers.
A fourth, glittering with bejeweled metal
figurines.
Two sand wings were facing off, hissing
at each other.
But neither looked like Kibley.
The one she'd heard 1st was a tawny
female sandwing, and the dragon facing
her was twice her size, grinning smugly
with a mouthful of broken teeth.
But I made it, shouted a tiny dragonette
charging between the feet of the female
dragon.
Aha.
There was Kibley.
I had to figure out how and get all this
stuff, and it was really hard and you
give it back.
You don't care about this little
pipsqueak, said the big dragon.
Let me buy you a lemonade, and we'll
forget all of this.
Give him back his drum toy. hissed
Kibley's defender, or fight me.
Kibley looked up at her, his eyes around
with awe.
You would fight for me?
He breathed.
Instead of taking lemonade?
It's not just for you, kid, she said.
I'm fighting for justice.
Yes.
Kibble whispered to himself.
I'm gonna do that too when I'm big.
He puffed up his chest.
No, I'm gonna do that right now.
With a great hollering yell, he threw
himself with a big dragon and sank his
teeth into the thief's ankle.
The memory broke apart in chaos and
shouting, and dragons throwing punches.
Dropping them into sundew's mind.
The scene was the poison jungle.
It started with chasing a frog through
dark leaves, and ended with meeting a
green dragon named Willow.
Lizard's not going to like that one.
Luna thought.
She probably thought sundew of all
dragons. could give her a battle memory.
But even fierce, scary sundew, keeps
thinking about the dragon she loves.
The last memory took them to a cave that
flickered with torches.
Five little dragonettes sat in a circle
by an underground river, studying a faded
map.
One was muskly and brown.
One was tiny and golden yellow.
One was a fidgety nightwing.
The other 2 Luna recognized as a much
younger tsunami and glory, who were
arguing with each other.
Look, the kingdom of sand is clearly
biggest, tsunami shouted. stabbing one
claw at the map.
You don't know where the borders are
Glory argued back.
Maybe the Sky Kingdom includes all of
this.
She yanked the map toward her and pointed
at a swath of northern mountains.
Oh, please be careful, said the night
wing, tisking nervously.
If we tear this map, Kestrel will be
furious.
She'll do something awful to both of
you.
I know it.
No, it'll be worse, said the little
yellow one.
Because Clay will tell her it was his
fault, and she'll punish him instead.
They all turned toward the brown dragon
who was blissfully chewing on something
and looked very startled to suddenly have
their attention.
Moof, he said.
Wha?
Yeah, he would do that.
Tsunami agreed.
All right, I'll keep my claws off it.
Glory said, lifting her talons in the
air.
But I still say the Sky Kingdom is bigger
than we think.
Everyone is fighting over the kingdom of
sand, tsunami cried.
It has to be the biggest.
Clay poked tsunami in the nose.
Doesn't matter which one is the biggest
he said.
Oh, really?
Tsunami batted his claw away.
Nope, he said.
Only matters which one has the best
food.
That's where we're going to live all
together.
One day, when we're old and creaky.
The little one dissolved in laughter, and
Gloria said, I have no intention of ever
being creaky.
Tsunami slung one wing around her and
said, oh, you'll get there as long as
Clay keeps stopping me from murdering
you.
And then they were back in the mind
space.
Moon exhaled, let go of pineapple, and
rubbed her forehead with a wince.
I'll be back, she whispered and
disappeared.
Luna looked from dusky to pineapple to
lizard.
They all looked a little wind blown from
being whisked through all those memories
one after the other.
Well, Lizard said finally.
I hated all of that.
You did?
Luna said.
But that was so many different dragons.
All those different kinds of lives.
Isn't that what you wanted to see?
Lizard growled to herself for a minute
and then she burst out.
I thought there would be someone like
me.
I wanted to know what I could have been
like, but none of those dragons are
anything like me.
I think they are, Luna said.
I mean, everyone is different, but we all
still fit together.
Like the threads of a tapestry.
We can weave lizard in.
She can still be part of something.
Think about what you saw.
Moon as a dragonette was so lonely, but
she kept surviving anyway.
That's just like you.
Kibli stood up for himself, even when his
enemy was much stronger than him.
You do that too.
Every time you yell at Cottonmouth
Tsunami got mad so quickly as a
dragonette, I think she still does that.
And you do too.
But you've had to learn to calm yourself
down, with no one else here to help.
Lizard rubbed her face.
What about the other two?
Luna thought for a moment.
Sundew goes after what she wants, without
letting anything stop her.
I think you're determined like that.
And you heard that ice wing.
Lynx didn't need rescuing.
She wasn't afraid of being fed to
walruses, and neither are you.
Lizard snorted.
That's true.
I have no idea what a walrus is, but I
know I could take one in a fight.
She paused and took a deep breath.
If I'd had a chance to grow up and meet
one anyway.
I think I'm more like that other white
dragon on the wall though.
Snowfall?
She was my favorite.
Lizard?
It's not fair what happened to you, Luna
said.
What's really not fair?
Is the biggest difference between me and
those dragons?
Lizard said passionately.
They all had someone who loved them.
No one ever loved me.
Not that I care.
I don't care.
But that's the unfair part.
Actually.
You're right.
Luna hesitated.
I think maybe also, though, it's unfair
that you never got to love someone.
That's important too.
And I'm sorry you never had that.
Lizard sniffed, and wiped her face again
with an impatient gesture.
She glanced sideways at Dusky.
Seems like loving someone makes you do
really stupid things, she said.
Yeah, true, Luna said, thinking of the
many times Swordell had thrown himself
into trouble to spare her, or Blue, of
Blue breaking all the rules he cared
about so much, to find Luna, when she was
taken to the Flame Silk Cavern, and
Cricket, leaving behind her entire tribe
and risking her biggest secret, to help a
silk wing she barely knew.
Lizard looked at the throne.
Had the tortured grimace on Cottonmouth's
face as he puppeteered 100s of dragons at
once, somewhere far away.
She looked back at Luna, and the flame
silk on Luna's horns reflected in the
fathomless pools of lizard's eyes.
All right, Lizard said.
Listen, because I'm only going to say
this once.
She took a deep breath.
If you cut the vine that's growing
through our heads, she said, her voice
low and shaking.
The plant will be a normal plant again.
And we'll be gone.
Chapter 24.
Luna stopped breathing.
What?
She finally whispered.
You heard me, Lizard said.
Don't make me say it again.
Don't make me think about it.
I don't want to talk about it.
And you better not say thank you.
And whatever you're going to do, I don't
want to know.
I shouldn't know.
Distract me.
Dusky, be interesting.
Um.
Dusky sat up. looking very alarmed.
Like, how?
Sing, dance.
Grow an extra head.
I don't know.
Lizard shoved him again, and this time
Desky pounced on her.
Lizard yelped, and they rolled across the
dirt, play wrestling.
Quiet over there.
Cottonmouth shouted, and then went back
into his trance, muttering, Cut the
vine.
Luna pictured the throne room she'd flown
into.
The vine growing from the floor through
lizard's head and then cotton mouths.
Can I really do it?
Me?
Of all dragons?
I should probably wait for sundew.
She could do it easily, I bet.
But.
I should try, at least.
I'm the one who knows about this.
I'm the one who's here, in this throne
room, right now.
Even if I only get so far.
Even if I only help a little bit, that
would still be a little bit closer to
defeating the other mind and freeing the
others.
I have to be like the dragons whose
memories I just saw.
Dragons who don't give up.
Dragon to jump in to save the ones they
love.
Dragons who fight, even when the enemy
seems much too big.
Dragons who don't need rescuing.
I don't want to be the dragon who always
needs to be rescued.
All right.
So how do I do this?
Can I get over there without him
noticing?
And then what?
Saw through the vines with my claws?
He can take over my body and stop me
anytime.
My only chance is to get there stealthily
and then do it quickly.
Ideally when he's distracted.
She closed her eyes and reached her way
back into her real body.
It was heavy and cold, clammy from the
damp vines under her talons.
Her claws were still curled around
Dusky's small, listless form.
What do I do with him?
If I leave him here on the vines.
Cottonmouth could use him against me.
The moment he realizes what I'm doing, he
could hurt Dusky and make me stop.
But I guess that's true no matter where
Dusky is.
And I'd rather have him with me.
Blindly, she pushed and tugged the small
dragonette over her shoulder until he was
draped between her wings.
She felt his tiny talons twitch against
her neck.
She forced her limbs to take a cautious
step forward. and felt the vines flex and
bow and ripple under her feet.
It was worse than walking on the sand on
Jerboa's beach.
There were a lot of vines, and they were
very thick.
But her talons kept slipping through the
gaps and tripping her up.
It didn't help that she couldn't see
where she was stepping, or be sure which
way she was going.
I hope I'm pointed at the throne.
She slid forward another inch.
And then another.
Hurry.
Her muscles screamed, but her mind
screamed back.
Careful.
And what if he sees you?
And too fast.
And it was a whole stressful mess of
conflicting instructions riding around
inside of her.
She wasn't sure how much time had passed
or whether she felt time the same way
inside the mind space.
Her internal clock felt like it was all
out of order.
When she heard cotton mouth let out a
hiss.
Instantly, she froze her real body in
place.
Nothing to see here, nothing to see, she
thought frantically.
She opened her eyes in the mind space.
Dusky and Lizard were still romping
around the room, tackling and pinning
each other, and wriggling free and
running off.
They looked so much like ordinary
dragonettes playing for a moment, that
Luna's heart hurt.
I wish there was a way to save her.
To keep lizard alive and give her a real
life.
We are approaching Lake Scorpion
Cottonmouth said imperiously.
Lizard, stop being infantile and focus.
He stood up and glared around the mind
space as Lizard stumbled to a stop.
Make sure the mind walker does not get in
here.
Do not let her speak to these 2 again.
He nodded at Luna and Pineapple.
Why do I have to do anything?
Lizard asked mutinously.
I thought you were so brilliant, and I
was so useless, that I might as well not
even be here.
But you are here.
So do as you're told, he said.
I'm busy enough.
There are dragons causing trouble at
Cicada Hive.
Queen Wasp won't stop moaning and wailing
about the pain in her face, so she's no
help at all.
And this rainbow dragon I'm in is about
to run into my rogue hive wing and her
merry band of human pets.
He thought for a moment.
I know.
Jump into a hive wing and cicada hive and
kill a couple of silk wings to make them
all shut up.
He didn't notice the expression on Luna's
face, but Lizard did.
Boring, she said.
Don't feel like it.
Ooh, I could make the guardian climb up
and steal another dragonette, though.
He gave her a withering look.
How would that help me at all?
No, I forbid it.
You've already cluttered up the place
with these toys.
That is quite enough for now.
Bleh, Lizard said, flopping down on the
floor and resting her chin on her
talons.
Well, you can sulk, or you can come fight
some dragons.
I don't care which.
Cottonmouth said, closing his eyes
again.
Just tell me if the mind walker comes
back.
I assume you can be trusted with a task
that simple.
Lizard stuck her tongue out at his blank
face.
Should we check on Cicada Hive?
Luna asked nervously.
What does he mean?
Dragons are causing trouble.
Are sore tail and blue all right?
Probably, Lizard said, exhaling.
She toppled dusky over. sat on him, and
waved one talon in the air like a
conjurer whisking away a curtain.
The mind space floated aside, and the
cicada hive market settled in around
them.
It was much noisier than before.
Many of the silk wings were standing now
shouting at the guards, asking for
answers.
The dragons guarding the exits were white
eyed and perfectly still, blocking the
way with their bodies, but not fighting
back, or responding.
Luna thought she saw a flicker of dark
purple wings in the crowd.
Aisle?
But when she turned, she couldn't see her
friend anywhere.
She spotted Swordtail on the far side of
the hive and spread her wings to fly over
to him.
Ooh, hang on, Lizard said, bumping her
side.
Exciting things happening over by Lake
Scorpion.
Come on.
Luna had no choice.
A moment later, they were hovering in the
air above a huge lake, glittering in the
midday sunshine.
Luna blinked, disoriented by the light.
She hadn't realized how much time had
passed in the real world.
Bringing sundew closer and closer to
cottonmouths trap.
Speaking of whom?
There was the human, descending through
the sky toward a cave opening on the
north shore of the lake.
It looked like the cave in the drawings
Luna had seen, the one with all the
humans walking into it.
A leaf wing was waiting on the pebbly
beach by the lake.
Water rippled over the dragon's green
talons, and it seemed to be staring up
into the trees, real actual trees, on
Pantala.
Luna had never been to this peninsula, and
she didn't know anyone else who had
either.
It wasn't quite the wild jungle of
pineapple's memories, or the forest Luna
had visited around sanctuary, but there
were trees here.
Growing along the hills that covered the
cave system.
I bet that leaf wing is as amazed as I am
Luna thought.
I wonder if they're thinking the leaf
wings should have hidden here, instead of
the poison jungle.
But then again, it would have been much
easier for wasp to find and attack them
here.
Wait.
Who is that?
Briony?
Hemlock or pokeweed?
Who else could it be?
Cottonmouth in pineapple landed and
approached the leaf wing, Luna nearly
called out to warn the green dragon, not
that it would have helped.
But then the dragon turned, and she saw
his boiled egg white eyes.
Oh, no.
One of Cottonmouth's creatures.
They didn't speak.
But the other dragon turned toward the
copse of trees behind him, and 6 other
white eyed dragons came forward.
Three hive wings, 3 leaf wings, dragging
cricket and bullfrog between them.
Cricket!
Luna yelped.
The bespectacled hive wing had 2 leaf
wings flanking her, brandishing spears at
her side.
She blinked in confusion at Cottonmouth.
Pineapple?
she said.
What are you doing here?
Pineapple is out to lunch.
I'm afraid, Cottonmouth said, smirking
cruelly.
Cricket's face crumbled.
Oh, no, pineapple.
I'm so, so sorry.
There was a kind of crackling in the air
and suddenly, the rest of Luna's friends
were standing behind pineapple.
Sundew's scowl was so fierce.
Luna was surprised Cottonmouth didn't go
up in flames.
Cricket burst into tears.
All of you?
No, Kibley said quickly.
Cricket, we're all right.
It only got pineapple.
And Luna.
Bullfrog looked startled.
Cricket glanced toward the cave opening
and pressed her talons together.
But she's in the abyss.
She said if I brought you, sundew, that
she'd be okay.
She will be, Sundoo snarled, her eyes
locked on Cottonmouth.
Tangles and threads.
Luna suddenly realized.
I should be trying to cut the vine.
I got distracted by watching, but this is
my best and last chance.
Quick, before anything else terrible
happens here.
She closed her eyes and reached, reached
for her real body.
It was harder from here, where she could
sense the warmth of the sun on her scales
and hear the trees rustling in the wind.
This felt so much more real, than the
cold, damp, uneven, green, rot smelling
place where she really was.
Breathe, like cricket said.
Finally, her real claws began to tingle.
And when she ordered her muscles to move
forward, it was her real body that moved
not the one in the mind space.
The weight of Dusky still rested between
her shoulder blades, breathing deeply.
Let cricket and bullfrog go.
She heard Sundu say, with menace in her
voice.
One step.
Another step.
Slippery vines around my ankle, carefully
disentangle them.
Another step.
Why in the world would I do that?
Cottonmouth answered.
It would be much more fair if I absorbed
one of them, or both of them.
Then you'd have 4 of your dragons, and
I'd have 4 of your dragons, and you'd be
much less tempted to try any clever
tricks.
Luna's real nose bumped into something
solid.
A wall?
A column?
She felt it with her talons, flat
straight, a few vines zigzagging up it.
The wall then.
Pick a direction.
Keep going.
She turned right, and kept one left wing
touching the wall, as she felt her way
forward again.
The clever tricks are non-negotiable.
Kibley said.
Sundew is not going to deliver herself
into your, um, pedals, sundew.
What do you call the part of plants that
eats dragons?
Jaws, Sundu said grimly.
Yeep, Kibley said.
I think I'll stick with pedals.
Luna's wing on her right side brushed
cold stone.
She reached out and felt it, smooth and
curved, one of the columns.
Hope I'm going the right way.
She took another step.
Vines squishing and flexing under her
talons.
You don't exactly have a choice
Cottonmouth said.
I have infinitely more dragons than you
do, and...
Hang on, Kibley interrupted.
Not literally infinitely.
That's mathematically impossible.
Another column on Luna's right.
That seemed promising.
She'd been close to the door, hadn't
she?
So if she was going the correct way, she
would have to pass 2 columns before
reaching the far wall with the throne.
She thought, she hoped.
It was hard to focus while listening to
her friends in danger.
She pictured the throne room again, using
the mental tapestry she'd imagined when
she 1st saw it.
What if she anchored herself to make sure
she could find her way back, if anything
happened.
Carefully.
She rested both front talons on the
column, then spun out a long thread of
ordinary golden silk.
She passed it around the column and tied
it off, leaving the other end still
unspooling from her wrist as she started
forward again.
Do not bother being aggravating.
Cottonmouth said, in a bored voice.
Sun do.
This hive wing is Caribid.
I chose him specially to be the one to
inject you.
He has marvelous stingers in his claws
and tail.
And the ability to inject much more toxin
than boring wasp.
He's been consuming all the breath of
evil I could get him from the moment I
met you.
I think we might be able to absorb you on
the 1st stab.
Although, if we need to do more stabbing
there's time for that too.
Back up, tsunami yelled, making Luna
stumble.
Don't you get any closer?
If you turn invisible again, or shoot any
more unpleasant ice in me, I will have
Caribid stab cricket first.
Cottonmouth hiss.
Luna walked straight into a wall.
She was shaking a particularly clingy
vine off one of her back feet, and forgot
to reach forward for a moment.
Her head thudded painfully against stone
and she let out a gasp of pain.
Luna?
She heard lizards say.
Nothing.
She whispered, dizzy.
She took a deep breath, waiting for the
shock of the pain to subside.
Ignore me.
She'd reached the corner.
With luck, if she turned right here, she'd
find the throne.
Or, if she'd come the wrong way, she'd be
back at the blocked entrance to the
room.
She turned, kept one wing on the wall, and
felt her way forward.
Suddenly, chaos erupted in the mind space
Dragon screams filled Luna's ears, and
she instinctively froze, paralyzed with
terror.
What's happening?
she cried.
Should I open my eyes?
But I can't help them in the outside
world.
I can only help them if I stay focused
and keep going in here.
A whole bunch of leaf wings just
attacked!
Lizard yelped, including Sandu's mother.
This is so exciting.
Didn't you know they were coming?
Luna cried.
Couldn't you have warned us?
How and why exactly?
Lizard asked.
You can't expect me to do everything
around here?
That's true, Luna thought.
Stay on task.
She pressed forward again in her real
body.
The vines were so thick here, both
underfoot and swarming up the wall.
It was hard to feel the wall at all most
of the time.
She felt like she was floundering through
a twisting pit of snakes, while at least
20 dragons roared and battled in her
ears.
Plants are just bursting out of the
ground, Lizard reported gleefully.
Sendu's got carabit pinned in a bramble
bush.
Ooh, Cottonmouth nearly got tsunami with
his death spit.
Eee!
Belladonna just tried to stab Moon and
Kibley jumped in the way.
That ice dragon has frozen 2 of the leaf
wings.
Ach!
Like 9 of our dragons, just grabbed
cricket, and threw her at Carabid.
Oh, snap peas, we're finally getting
cricket now.
Cricket, Luna squeezed her eyes shut and
covered them with her talons to stop
herself from opening them.
Can she hear me?
Cricket, She felt the thread connected to
the column flick against her wings
humming softly.
I'll take care of her, said Pineapple's
voice, distant and drifting.
You keep going.
Forward.
Another step.
Fight the vines.
And then, her reaching talons found a
mass of vines, and her heart sank.
Am I on the wrong end of the room?
She plunged her talent through the vines
feeling around frantically.
There.
There was a heavy stone shape under the
vines, solid and unyielding.
The throne.
It has to be.
I'm almost there.
Sandew is mad, Lizard announced.
Moon keeps yelling, don't hurt
pineapple.
Don't kill him.
Sundo.
Remember, it's not him.
But with all these branches flying
everywhere?
I'm pretty sure someone's going to die.
Luna could hear a moon's cries herself.
She also heard links shouting, the
wristbands, and Kibli shouting about 8
different instructions, and Bullfrog and
tsunami roaring furiously, and it was so
hard to think.
So hard to stay here, in the slow, tangled
space, instead of opening her eyes to
make sure her friends were safe.
Do the thing I can do.
Pray that it helps.
I hope that Lizard is right about this.
She found a vine so thick, her talons
couldn't reach all the way around it.
When she gingerly traced its path upward
her claws brushed a tiny foot and brittle
scales.
Lizard's body.
She thought with a shudder.
This is the vine I have to cut.
Do I cut it below Lizard's body before it
reaches them?
Or...
If I cut the vine that's growing between
lizard and cottonmouth, would that cut
cottonmouth out of the other mind, but
leave lizard alive?
Lizard hadn't said exactly where to cut
it, and Luna didn't want to ask, in case
Cottonmouth heard her.
All right, I'll try cutting it between
them, and hope that works.
Oh, wow, Lizard said, through the din of
the roaring dragons.
Someone injected that big brown one too.
I wonder what his memories will be like.
Bullfrog.
Don't think about that.
Focus on this.
Luna was hovering in the air now, her
wings keeping her aloft in front of the
tall throne.
She beat them once to rise a little
higher, tracing the curve of the vine up
and through lizard's skull, keeping one
talent on the vine.
She reached up to be sure Cottonmouth's
head was above her, connected along the
same winding trail.
Here.
But now what?
She couldn't use her claws.
The vine was so dense, and the moment she
started to hack or slice at it
Cottonmouth would surely sense the attack
jump into her and stop her.
She carefully rested her feet on the edge
of the throne.
The silk connecting her to the column
rubbed against her wing again.
What if?
Luna spun out several more coils of silk
and cut it loose from her wrist.
She looped the silk lightly around the
vine.
Gentle, gentle, harmless, only leaves
brushing each other.
Crossed over the thread coming from the
column, and tied the loose end to her
arm.
I hope the silk is strong enough.
I hope my weight is enough to pull it
straight through the vine in one quick
slice.
Luna took a deep breath, braced herself
to shove off, and launched herself away
from the throne at full speed.
Chapter 25.
The shriek.
That filled Luna's head, drowned out all
the other dragons, and then they all cut
off mid roar, mid shout, mid scream.
And Luna was flung violently out of the
mind space.
She opened her eyes just in time to see
the wall of the real world throne room as
she smashed into it.
Oh.
Oh, she moaned, sliding down and landing
in the carpet of vines.
Silence, enveloped her.
She sat up, her head reeling, and reached
over her shoulder.
A little talon clutched hers, and her
heart leaped.
Tusky.
Are you all right?
The dragonette scrabbled up her back?
Wrapped his talons around her neck and
leaned into her, breathing deep, shaky
breaths.
I think so.
He said after a moment.
What happened?
Where's Lizard?
Luna turned to look at the throne.
Finally.
Her trick with the silk had worked.
With her momentum pulling on one end, and
the other anchored at the column, the
silk had sliced right through the vine
severing its connection with cotton
mouth.
How strange.
I thought my flame silk was what made me
special.
And that it was the one magic thing I
could use to save the day.
But instead, it was my ordinary silk, and
it could have come from any silk wing at
all.
And now, something was happening.
All the vines that branched out of the
top of cottonmouth's skull were withering
shriveling into brown and curling shreds
before her eyes.
The decay spread rapidly out along the
long tendrils of the plant, all the way
up to the ceiling and racing along the
walls.
Luna scooped dusky up, and beat her wings
to hover in the air just in case.
She thought the plant was dying, but she
didn't want to be standing on it, if it
happened to have any last creepy death
throws.
Lizard, she said out loud.
The petrified body of the dragonette on
the throne looked exactly the same.
While cotton mouths husk already looked
like it was starting to crumble around
the edges.
Are you still there?
Can you hear me?
You did it wrong, said Lizard's voice.
Echoing inside their skulls, instead of
coming through their ears.
Why would you do it wrong?
I did?
Luna said.
But it looks like it's working.
Do you mean I cut it in the wrong place?
I was trying to get rid of cotton mouth
and keep you.
Keep me?
There was a sort of floundering silence
for a moment.
You can't, you idiot.
As long as the plant has an intelligent
brain to work with, it won't give up.
It wants to survive more than anything in
the world.
And with only 2 of us in here, now it's
as strong as I am.
Hang on.
But you don't have to be evil, right?
Now that Cottonmouth is gone?
Luna tried.
Maybe you and the plant can coexist.
Maybe you'll like being a not evil
plant.
And we can come visit you down here
right?
And talk to you, like this?
No!
Lizard shouted.
You are so stupid.
The plant is already trying to use my
leaf speak to grow back into cottonmouth
or it'll replace him with a guardian, or
if that doesn't work, it'll find some
other awful human.
Luna had forgotten about the Guardian, but
there he was.
Curled up at the foot of the throne
rocking back and forth with a dazed
expression.
Luna, yelled Lizard's voice in her head.
I don't want to just exist in this
nothingness, trying to fight a desperate
weed for the rest of eternity.
I hate that plan.
I'm sorry, lizard.
Luna was crying now, and so was Dusky.
I'm so sorry.
I didn't want to lose you.
You saved us, and it's not fair.
And you're funny, Dusky chimed in.
And fun to play with, and very loud, and
scary sometimes, and bossy all the time
and brave, and really interesting, and I
don't want you to go away either.
Lizard didn't reply for a moment, and
when she did, her voice was muffled.
Well, I have to, she said.
So you should say goodbye.
And then you should get over here and cut
the vine below my head.
So the plant will stop using my brain to
connive and flail around.
Do it quick, before it gets to
Cottonmouth again.
Luna realized with alarm that Lizard was
right.
A new spray of green was growing out of
the vine, where Luna's silk had sliced it
crawling tentatively up, as though
Cottonmouth's head was the sun.
She started forward, but Dusky tightened
his arms around her.
Wait, he said.
Can we give lizard a new name first?
A real name?
Over own?
So she doesn't have to die?
Still stuck with his name for her?
That seems pointless?
Lizard said.
But Luna thought she could hear a wary
curiosity in her voice.
A new name for 30 seconds?
A new name, forever, Luna said.
One we can remember you by and write
songs about, and weave into tapestries.
Hmm.
Said the 5000 year old dragonette.
You better not put my shriveled corpse
with a hole in its skull in any
tapestry.
Yuck.
Dusky objected.
I won't, Luna promised. laughing through
her tears.
I'll weave you flying.
You'll be with all the dragons who gave
you their memories.
Your friends, Dusky put in.
Especially me.
Can I be in the tapestry?
He asked Luna.
Of course, Luna said.
You'll be together.
And you'll be free.
The tiny dragon sighed inside their heads
long and wistful.
What do you want to be called?
Dusky asked.
I don't know what tribe I was, she
answered.
I don't know what kinds of names we had.
Or what my mother might have called me.
She paused for a moment.
Do you think?
Would freedom be a weird name for a
dragon?
Not at all.
Luna said.
I like it, Dusky agreed.
It's what you'll have.
And also, what you're giving everyone.
We'll call you freedom from now on.
Luna said.
Cool.
Freedom said quietly.
Luna reached up and squeezed one of
Dusky's talons.
They flew over to the throne, now
surrounded by crackling dying vines.
Only the original stem rising from the
floor was still green and vibrant.
That, and the new tendril that was trying
to claw its way back from the severed
vine.
Luna set Dusky down on one corner of the
throne.
Can I help?
he asked.
She touched the top of his tiny head.
He'd already been through so much.
Are you sure?
asked.
Won't it make you sad?
I'm already sad, he pointed out.
This way.
I'd be helping say goodbye.
But, She's already dead.
He said, matter of factly.
What we're doing is setting her free from
the plant.
I suppose that's right, she realized.
That's the right way to look at it.
Luna produced more silk, and tied one end
around his wrist.
Then she wound the silk around the vine
and tugged gently on the other side to
tighten it.
Thanks for this.
Freedom said awkwardly.
And most of all, for the look on
Cottonmouth's face as he poofed into
dust.
It was even better than face melting.
You're welcome.
Luna said with a smile.
And thank you for all your squishy
ridiculous, cuddle monster memories.
Freedom said in a rush.
I guess maybe they weren't so bad.
If I'd had a real life, it would be maybe
okay.
If you 2 were in it.
Hey, we were in it, Dusky said.
In your life, I mean.
Huh.
Freedom said.
All right, fine.
You can be right.
Just this once.
Are you ready?
Luna asked.
I am, Dusky said, nodding.
Me too, said freedom.
Goodbye.
Thank you, freedom.
Luna said.
And then she and Dusky pulled on the silk
and severed the breath of evil from the
dragonette who'd saved them.
Chapter 26.
Soon after they cut the vine.
Both of the husks on the throne crumbled
into dust.
Luna dug down into the dirt around the
last original piece of the vine that
cotton mouth had planted so many
centuries ago.
She used her flame silk to burn all the
roots, which stretched far into the
ground, like burrowing eels.
The smoke was green and a little dizzying
but it dissipated quickly, and there was
nothing left to reach into their brains
or take them over.
All the rest of the vines in the room had
shriveled up, including the ones blocking
the door.
Flying up out of the abyss was much
harder and more tiring than flying down
into it, especially with Dusky on her
back, and the disoriented guardian
cradled in her talons.
But Luna was so happy to be flying, so
happy to be out of that throne room, that
her wings felt like they could keep
beating forever.
At the top of the chasm, she found wren
axolotl, and sky, with the humans who had
kidnapped Dusky.
Muna!
Sky cried, as she rose over the edge.
Yes, Ren said triumphantly.
I told you she'd survive.
You owe me a turtle.
Hang on, why did I agree to bed in
turtles?
Are you all right?
Sky asked.
What happened down there?
It's a long, long story, Luna said.
She landed, and gently deposited the
guardian in front of the other humans.
He pushed himself to his feet, wobbling.
The one named Raven, gasped, and grabbed
her friend's arm, and then they both ran
forward and caught the gaunt, bedraggled
human before he could topple over.
Is he back to normal?
Luna asked Ren.
Ren said something to Raven in human, and
then all the humans had a chatter fest
for a minute.
Finally, Ren looked up at Luna, grinning.
They think so, she said.
That is, he remembers that his name is
Vol, and he remembers the guardian
ceremony, but not much after that, except
being hungry all the time.
They hope he'll be all right after a lot
of rest.
And a bath, Sky suggested.
Also, a haircut.
Maybe several more baths.
Let's go find Cricket and the others, Luna
said.
I think the other mind is gone, but I
want to make sure they're safe.
Cricket, Axolotl said, in a near perfect
dragon accent.
They padded one of the pouches around
Sky's neck, which Luna recognized as the
one with the dragon book in it.
Book friend.
Axolotl added with a smile.
Wow, Luna said to them, impressed, very
good.
They pointed to her.
Luna, fire friend.
We've been practicing, Ren said proudly.
You were down there for days, you know.
I am very, very hungry, Luna realized.
Me too.
Dusky chirped from her back.
We can eat after we find the others.
Do you know how to get to Lake Scorpion
from here?
She asked Ren.
Ren spoke to the abyss humans again, then
said, Raven says she'll take us there.
While Mole gets his brother back to the
village.
It was strange for Luna to walk through
the tunnels, with the sharp faced
feathered human, listening to her
murmuring voice and conversation with Ren
and Axolotl.
This human kidnapping Dusky was the whole
reason Luna had wound up in the abyss, but
Luna couldn't bring herself to be angry
at Raven.
On the scale of all the things that
humans and dragons had done to one
another over the centuries, it was only
one small, desperate act.
And continuing the cycle of fury and
revenge and punishment.
That was for other dragons, perhaps, but
not for Luna.
At least, that's how she felt, when it
came to present day humans.
I'm still angry at Cottonmouth, and Queen
Wasp.
They were trying to make the world a
worse place for their own selfish reasons
and they hurt a lot of dragons.
And she didn't know what to think yet
about the hive wings.
She had a feeling that would depend on
what they did next, without malevolent
voices in their heads.
The sunlight up ahead was so dazzling
that Luna was blinking, her eyes watering
long before they reached the cave
entrance and stepped outside.
How many days had they been underground?
How long had she been trapped in the
abyss?
She had no idea.
But it felt as though years had passed
since the real sun had warmed her
scales.
In the mind space vision, the whisper of
the trees and the leafy scent of the air
had seemed real enough.
But now that she could truly breathe them
in, it was overwhelming.
She stood in the sunlight with her eyes
closed for a moment, letting her senses
and her internal clock realign, feeling
her real body really here, and nowhere
else.
She felt Sky gallop past her yelling
Pineapple, Kibli.
And a hubbub of voices came toward them
through the trees.
When she opened her eyes, Cricket was
standing right in front of her, eyes
shining.
The other mind is gone, isn't it?
Cricket asked.
You did something amazing, didn't you?
Not just me, Luna said.
Everyone helped.
Cricket impulsively threw her wings
around Luna, and Luna hugged her back
smiling.
For the 1st time, this didn't feel like a
hive wing, hugging her.
This was Cricket, who was more than her
scales and her tribe, just like every
dragon.
Sundu interrupted, coming up to join
them.
Before we get to the Hug Fest, can
someone tell me what exactly happened?
One minute, I was locked in a ferocious
battle, turning every plant I could reach
into a fearsome weapon, ready to fight to
the death.
And the next minute?
All my foes suddenly fell over, as though
their bones had turned into ferns.
I felt that, Pineapple said.
It was like, that feeling when you're
holding up a huge bunch of bananas while
someone saws them free, and then suddenly
the last fiber is cut, but you weren't
paying attention.
So the whole thing plummets out of your
talons, and it's like, oops, but wow, you
feel so much lighter.
Sad about the bananas, though.
Hmm.
Maybe that wasn't the best analogy.
Did you feel them both go?
Luna asked.
Cottonmouth, and then the dragon?
Yes.
Pineapple said.
There was an odd in between time.
When I felt like I was myself, but still
sort of tethered, maybe?
And then I felt her and the plant go, and
I was all me again.
Her, Sundu demanded.
Her who?
I'll tell you the whole story, Luna
said.
Everything that happened in the abyss.
She glanced up at the sun, now slanting
down toward the western horizon.
But, can I tell you on the way to Cicada
Hive?
There's someone waiting for me in the
mosaic garden.
And when they arrived the next morning
Sortell was there, he really was.
He was standing on the hills surrounded
by violets and sunshine, waiting, as
though he could wait forever, and would
wait forever for her.
And when she swooped in through the open
sky arches, and soared over everyone's
heads, and crashed into his arms, he
laughed, as they fell over and they
rolled through the grass, and it was real
he was real at last.
Are you all right?
She said, finally, sitting up.
She lifted his eyelids and studied each
beautiful dark blue pupil. 100% sore
tail?
I was all right, he said.
And then you squished the honey drops.
Luna squeaked and jumped back, discovering
a squashed white box under her tail.
See, he said self righteously.
I am not the only one who sits on candy
around here.
Ah, you got me honey drops, she said
beaming.
She scooted the box aside and snuggled
under his wings.
Well, he said, what else do you get for
the dragon who rescued your brain?
I don't think they covered this in
manners and proper behavior class.
They actually did, she said.
And you know what's weird?
The answer is honey drops.
She reached up and patted his snout while
he laughed, checking again that he was
real.
I missed you so much.
I missed you more, he said.
Where's Blue?
she asked.
In the webs, with Io and your mom's, he
said.
He needs a lot of hugs right now.
On it, Luna said, jumping up.
Let's get cricket and go hug the antennae
off that dragon.
She sprinted back to the sky arches with
sore tail behind her. outside.
Cricket and sky and pineapple were flying
in a circle, waiting for her, with Wren
on Skye's back, and axolotl on
pineapples.
The other dragons had gone to Wasp Hive
with Sundew, to make sure someone
imprisoned Queen Wasp, so she could be
brought to justice.
Luna beckoned to her friends and led the
way back to her home in the sunlit, silk
spun webs full of rainbow colored
dragons.
She hadn't been paying attention before
but now that she looked, there was a
weird quiet hanging over everything, the
dragons she could see looked like they
had all just come out of their cocoons
disoriented, startled, and potentially
thrilled, but in a very confused way.
In fact, she realized, she hadn't seen
any hive wings at all yet.
Sore tail, she asked.
Where did all the hive wings go?
Home, he said, deep into the hive.
When the mind control snapped, some of
them tried to keep ordering us around, but
most of them just wanted to go home and
find their families, and be inside their
own bodies again, in their own space.
Wasp had been controlling them since she
brought them to the snarling river, which
is much, much longer than she'd ever
stolen their minds before.
He hesitated.
I still think they're the worst, and if
it were up to me, I take every hive wing
soldier, and merchant, and teacher, and
snob who was mean to us, and put them on
misbehavior's way for a year.
But after having someone in my own head
like that, I mean, it was pretty
terrible.
He looked up at the pale sprays of cloud
feathered across the sky, then back at
her, adding quickly, But they still could
have done something to try and be better
dragons.
Like, maybe they could have noticed that
Queen Wasp was an evil dictator.
And certainly they could have treated
silk wings like equal dragons, and
generally not been jerks.
So, my go back and forth a bit.
My brain words, Luna said ruefully.
He laughed.
Words of my head.
I have no idea what's going to happen
with the hive wings, she said, brushing
one of his wings with hers.
But let's do what we can do for right now
which is take care of Blue.
She glanced around, and saw Cricket
hanging back shyly as they approached
Luna's home.
Luna wondered if Blue had had a chance to
tell their moms about the hive wing who
loved him.
Burnett, Silverspot, and Io all stood up
bristling, when they saw her.
But Luna took one of Cricket's talons in
hers, and guided her into the silken
cell.
Hello all, she said.
This is Cricket.
She's part of our family now.
And then her moms saw the look on Blue's
face as he saw Cricket, and Luna knew it
was going to be all right.
It might take them a moment, the way it
had taken her a moment, but if Blue loved
her and Luna trusted her, soon, they
would too.
She did not even mind that cricket got to
wrap her wings around him first.
That was fine.
Because her wings fit over crickets, and
sore tails could go around hers, and they
were together, and safe.
Finally, finally, finally.
Luna knew.
They had only started to change the
world.
There was still a lot to do.
A lot of dragons who needed help.
Dragons who needed homes, and dragons who
needed a new way of looking at the world
which would be the hardest thing of all.
But she didn't have to do it by herself.
She didn't have to be the one great and
mighty and wonderful flame silk, who set
the world on fire, and saved everyone, and
fixed everything all alone.
And she also didn't have to be the sad
lost dragon who sat and waited to be
rescued.
She only had to be herself.
Luna.
Talon in talon with blue and cricket, and
sore tail, and sundew, and all the
dragons of the distant kingdoms, and
hopefully the humans too.
If each of them tried, even a little bit
to make the world even a little better
then maybe there was hope.
And maybe, things could change.
Epilogue.
The sky was full of dragons.
Luna had made six weavings and was
halfway through a seventh, but she still
hadn't managed to capture quite how
breathtaking it was to see so many colors
and so many wing shapes, diving and
soaring together.
The more visitors flew over from the
distant kingdoms, the more complicated
her tapestries got.
Maybe I don't have the sky color quite
right yet. she said, holding up her claws
to frame a piece of the feathery clouds.
The rain had stopped not long ago.
And the air felt like wading through
sunshine, liquid and gold up close, and
lined with dark gray in the distance, and
completely impossible to capture in
silk.
Or maybe I'll never figure out how to
convey motion in a tapestry.
Like pinning down a dragonfly or a
firefly.
It's not the same if they're not moving.
I think your weavings are perfect
Swordell said contentedly.
And look at that rainbow, Luna said with
disgust.
Nobody would believe it, if I put a
rainbow that pretty into my tapestry.
Everyone would be like, oh, sure, Luna.
I just bet there was also a perfect
rainbow, and your perfect scene of
dragons from different tribes getting to
know each other.
Very subtle metaphor.
Well done.
You could do a tapestry of the silkwing
assembly, trying to get anything done
Sortell suggested.
If you're looking for a less perfect
scene.
Ah!
I love them, but oh my goodness, Luna
said.
Oh, sorry.
Did you have something to say?
Sortell struck a pose, imitating the silk
wings had been chosen for the assembly.
No, no, please, you go ahead.
Wait, maybe she had an idea?
Oh, no, I'm sure he was about to speak.
These are all great suggestions, everybody
really great.
Someday, eventually.
We'll get around to potentially doing
something about some of them.
Break for lunch.
Luna laughed.
They're lovely, she said.
They'll figure it out.
We haven't had a silk wing in charge of
anything in a really long time.
And wasp left no descendants from Queen
Monarch.
So I think this is a good compromise.
I think perhaps 200 silk wings in one
governing body is a few too many.
Swortell said, rolling his eyes
especially when Morpho is one of them.
Io and Tal will sort them out, Luna
said.
At least we're not in the mess the hive
wings are in.
Wasp was imprisoned in her own Flame Silk
Cavern, along with all of her sisters.
Lady Jewel was nominally now queen Jewel
of the hive wings, but there was a lot of
rumbling and grumbling and several
disgruntled factions in the tribe.
Some hive wings wanted to get far away
from the hives, and any reminder of what
wasp had done to them, one, named Tree
Hopper, had immediately come to find Tao
and never left.
Another was Hawker.
One of the checkpoint soldiers, Luna
remembered from Cicada Hive, and to
Luna's surprise and cricket's delight, the
one they'd rescued on the island, Earwig
had defected from the hive wings too.
She'd appeared in the new Silkwing
encampments, looking for the dragons who
had left her the map to get home.
See?
Cricket had said to Sundo triumphantly, it
was the right thing to do.
But not all dragons felt that way.
There were rather horrifying amount of
hive wings who wanted Queen Wasp back
mind control and all, which was the most
mystifying thing Luna had ever heard.
She was glad there were other dragons
leaf wings, mostly, like Belladonna, who
were happy to grapple with that problem.
I was sort of hoping we'd fixed
everything, Luna said to Swordtail.
We defeated the big bad guy.
Whoosh, all better, right?
So why are there still more problems and
things to fix?
I don't like it.
Yeah.
Sortell said, and they're woobly
problems.
All complicated and stuff.
Blur to you problems, I say.
I don't know how you reach dragons like
those hive wings, Luna said.
Like, how do you help dragons save
themselves, or teach them to care about
other dragons, especially ones who don't
look like them?
It feels completely impossible.
She sighed, and Sortell brushed her wing
with his.
You know what makes me feel better?
he said.
Thinking about the good dragons instead
of the bad ones.
I focus on how many dragons are out there
trying to make the world better instead
of worse.
It's not only us.
Lots of other dragons are trying to fix
things too, right?
We all keep going and keep trying and
keep fixing what we can.
And if you're tired or sad or need a
break, that's okay.
Because it's not all on you.
There's lots of us doing this together.
Luna rubbed her eyes and looked up at
him.
I get sad sometimes.
She admitted quietly.
I know, he said, putting his wing around
her.
And when you do, you can tell me.
She nodded and took a deep breath.
Most of the time, she was all right.
Most of the time.
She could think about her art and the
dragons she loved, and the sadness would
lift.
But sometimes it still found her.
Sometimes, especially when she thought
about the hive wings, and how there were
still so many dragons who didn't care
about hurting others.
I kind of wish we could do the same thing
for them that we did for freedom, she
said.
I wish we could link them to our memories
and let them feel what it's like to be
someone else for a little while, or show
them that what we're trying to build is a
better world for everyone, not just us.
Sortell bummed her side.
That's what your weavings are for, he
said.
And those stories, cricket and blue, have
talked about writing.
He reached into the bag around his neck
and pulled out the rolled up weaving
she'd brought for sundew.
It was one of Luna's visions for the Leaf
Silk Kingdom, a vast forest of trees
covering the southern half of the
continent, with webs of silk and hammocks
and tree houses, all connected together.
It looked a little bit like the rain wing
home.
But here, half the dragons were green
with leaf shaped wings, and there were
gardens in the clearings, and galleries
full of silk tapestries, and a library
full of books that told the truth.
Sortell unrolled it and spread it on the
grass, smiling.
You looked at it 5 minutes ago, Luna said
with a laugh.
I know, he said.
Looking at it makes me happy.
I mean, who doesn't want to live in this
world?
Oh, Luna cried. clutching his arm.
Here they come.
Cerulean blue and orange gold black wings
were descending from the sky.
The sunlight reflected brightly off
Cricket's glasses.
Luna waved at them, as Soritail rolled
the weaving back up again, and Blue
veered toward her.
From Cricket's shoulder, Axolotl waved
back.
Did we get here before sundew?
Cricket called.
Nope.
Sundew said cheerfully, bounding up next
to Luna with Willow beside her.
She grinned at Blue and Cricket as they
landed.
Her smile wavered a bit at the dragons
right behind them, but everyone had
already awkwardly met Cricket's parents.
Katy did, and Malachite.
Luna had told them how Malachite tried to
help Kibli, tsunami, and pineapple in
Wasp Hive, and they'd also heard the
story of how Malachite had been taken
away by Queen Wasp when she realized Lady
Scarab cared about him.
He was one of the hive wings who hadn't
been in control of his own body for many
years, him, and the librarian, and a few
others.
Most of them were among those who'd come
to seek refuge in the Leaf Silk Kingdom.
It's so beautiful from up there.
Blue said to Sundew, his eyes shining.
It's like a huge dragon spread green
wings all across the dragon tail
peninsula.
I can't believe how many more trees there
are already.
We were only gone a few days.
She might tell you that's the magic of
leaf speak, Willow said, but the tree
magician will be whoever can get her to
stop and actually eat something once in a
while.
She twined her tail around sundews and
released Bumblebee into the grass.
The little hive wing bounded over to hug
Cricket's leg, her wings vibrating
happily.
Axolotl slid down beside her.
Patted bumblebee's head and gave her a
carrot to gnaw on.
The human was staying with cricket for a
while, to keep studying dragon, and they
had found the way straight to Bumblebee's
heart very quickly.
I eat all the time, Sundu protested.
I ate a...
Something, this morning, while we were
sorting pyrean tree seedlings, didn't I?
I think I did.
The seedlings were very noisy, full of
questions.
It must be weird to fly across an ocean
when you're a tree.
Not a common tree experience, I suspect.
If you're talking about that talent full
of cashews, that does not count.
Willow said.
Does my cashews.
Bumblebee announced grumbly.
Snoodoo in big to a bubble.
Well, we're having a big feast after this
right?
Swordell interjected.
I was promised a tree planting party.
Uh, yeah.
Willow said.
Sunday's idea of a tree planting party is
one where we plant trees all day, and
then look at them and go, well done, us.
Good night, trees, and that's it.
That's the whole party.
Sortell looked outraged, and so did
Bumblebee.
Although that was bumblebee's normal face
much of the time.
So it was hard to tell how much this
concept of a party was specifically
offending her.
No, no, no, Swartail said.
A tree planting party is, we plant one
tree, and then we eat, and dance, and
flop around, and eat some more, and
ideally, place charades.
Turns out Swordtail is weirdly great at
charades, Luna said.
This is a new discovery.
Kibli's fault.
It may not surprise you to hear.
Charades are my secret superpower.
Soratel said, fluffing out his wings.
Just wait until it's my turn to save the
world.
If anyone can save the world with
charades, it's you.
Blue said loyally.
Yes, Luna said.
When the bad guys get so frustrated
because you refuse to tell him what
you're acting out, and the charades never
end, so he can never enact his evil
plan.
I think this party can find some happy
medium. between planting trees all day
and infinite charades.
Willow said with a laugh.
Did you bring it?
Can I meet it?
Sundew asked cricket.
Cricket's wings shimmered as she reached
into the large basket.
Her parents had been carrying between
them.
She gently lifted out a ball of roots and
dirt, out of which grew a tiny, perfect
tree.
Tree, Axolotl said with delight.
Book friend, tree, friend.
They pointed to Cricket, and then Sundo.
Bumblebee bonked their hand with their
snout, and Axolotto laughed.
Loud friend.
I can't believe my tree survived while I
was away, Cricket said.
I wonder if someone at school was
secretly watering my terrarium for me.
Wouldn't that be kind?
I was so happy to see it again.
I hope it's all right.
Can you tell if it's all right?
I tried to explain to it that it was
going to a place where it could grow big
and strong and free in the sunshine.
I'll let it know, Sundew said.
Taking the ball of dirt into her talons.
She touched her snout to the top of the
miniature leaves and closed her eyes.
It's a ficus, she whispered.
It says hello, more or less, in like, a
tree way, you know.
It also says, thank you, cricket, for
keeping it alive.
I mean, I'm translating, but that's
essentially what it's saying.
Would you like to grow bigger, little
tree?
She listened for a moment, then nodded.
All right, let's see.
Sundu carried the tree over to the hole
Luna and Sortell had helped to dig
earlier.
She tucked the ball of rude sin.
Like it was a baby dragonette.
Well, an agreeable baby dragonette, like
Dusky.
Not the shrieking hurricane of fury that
Bumblebee turned into most bedtime.
She's better when they have sleepovers.
Luna reminded herself, glancing at the
little hive wing, who was watching Sundo
with awe.
And Dusky loves her fierceness.
They had found Desky's mother.
The sweetest dark blue dragon, who had
cried and cried when she finally got to
hug her dragonette for the 1st time.
Luna wasn't worried about him anymore.
He'd have all the hugs he could possibly
want, and Luna was close by if he needed
more.
Sundew covered the roots, and buried her
claws in the dirt.
A few moments later, the trees, leaves
quivered, then started to stretch
reaching for the sun.
The branches spread, and the trunk
widened as it grew.
Cricket's parents, and axolotl let out
matching gasps, and Cricket clapped her
talons together with delight.
Soon the tree towered overhead, looking
enormously proud of itself.
I love it, Cricket breathed.
Me too, Bumblebee declared.
Let's call it Bumblebee Jr.
You should make a tapestry of this tree
Sundew said to Luna, the most beautiful
bumblebee in the world.
What?
Bumblebee shrieked.
Sundew and Willow both cracked up, and
Bumblebee shook her little fist at them.
Wait until you see her newest weaving.
Sortell said happily, pulling out Luna's
tapestry again.
I think this is my favorite.
You say that about every single one, Blue
pointed out.
And it's always true.
Sortell beamed.
He unfurled the weaving, and they all
gathered around it.
Oh, wow, Cricket said.
All right, this one is my favorite too.
You also say that about every single
one.
Blue observed, and they gave each other
little starry eyed nudges.
Cricket, Luna said slowly.
I've been wondering if I should make some
tapestries about, Well, about the
scorching, and freedom's story.
The real story of all the terrible things
that happened.
I don't really want to.
I feel like they would be awful weavings
and they'd make everyone sad, which is
not what I want my silk to do.
But I have to, don't I?
Because they'd be true, and everyone
should know the truth, shouldn't they?
Yes.
They should, Cricket said.
But that's what I'm here for.
I'll do that for you, Luna.
I feel like that's my responsibility, and
something I can do.
I'll make sure dragons know the truth, and
that we record history in our books, the
way it really was, about cotton mouth, and
this gorching, about the real book of
Clearsight, and about what humans are
like now.
We'll help, said her dad.
He adjusted his spectacles in exactly the
way cricket always did.
Writing was something I loved to do, when
I was myself.
When I was little.
I had this plan that I would write about
something that happened every day and
give the story to all my neighbors.
I did too, Cricket said, wide eyed.
I had that exact same plan.
Malachide patted her head tentatively
like he was still trying out the gestures
that went with the idea of dad.
My parents shut that down pretty quick
I'm afraid.
Mine too, Cricket said glumly.
I mean, my grandparents did.
You wrote the stories for me for a while
though.
Katie did reminded her.
I loved those, the one about the peacock
that got loose in your school, and ran
around screaming for a day.
That was amazing.
Cricket lit up as though her veins were
full of flame silk.
We can do it now, she said to Malachite.
Together She turned to Luna.
We'll do that part.
You let us worry about telling the past
and you keep making tapestries like this
about the future we can all hope for.
She touched the corner of the one sundew
was inspecting.
Is it worth it?
Luna asked.
Dreaming all these big, wild dreams that
will probably never come true?
Sometimes I think I should make my ideas
smaller and more realistic.
No, Blue said, taking her talon in his.
I want the world with big dreams in it.
Me too.
Sundu agreed.
We need dragons who can see the brightest
futures, so we can try to get there, even
if it takes longer than we wanted to.
And even, if some dragons are stupid, and
make getting there harder than it needs
to be.
SoreTail declared.
Yeah!
Bumblebee shouted, sound dragon stupid.
Cricket winced.
Except we don't use that word, remember?
she said, giving Sortell a pointed look.
We tried to use kind words and understand
each, some dragons very stupid, Bumblebee
shouted, loud enough that several of the
dragons in the sky turned to see what the
noise was.
The stupidest, brains full of stupid.
Ha, ha, ha.
Thank you so much, Cricket said to
Sortail, as Bumblebee bounded off into
the grass, pouncing on grasshoppers, and
yelling insults at them.
He gave her an innocent shrug, and
crouched to roll up the tapestry again
Blue laughed.
We do try to understand each other.
Luna thought, looking at her brother, the
sweetest, most understanding dragon in
the world, who had still managed to fight
back when he had to.
But even if we find a way to understand
the dragons who hurt us, that doesn't
mean we have to let them do all the
terrible things they want to do.
We can empathize with them, like Blue
does, and try to stop them, like sundew
would, all at the same time.
Well, now that certain little chaos
monkeys aren't listening, Willow said
watching Bumblebee charge away.
Who wants to try the fried bananas Luna
and I invented?
But na, na, na, na, na...
Bumblebee bellowed.
Skidding around at top speed and hurtling
back toward Willow.
I suppose I deserve that, Willow said, as
the dragonette scaled her leg and threw
her arms around Willow's neck to yell
Bananas, in her ear.
Axolotl laughed.
Bananas, they tried.
Stu...
Oopid?
Bananas, yes.
Cricket told them, holding out her
talent.
Stupid, no.
Axolotl climbed up to her shoulder
looking puzzled.
Who's got the dream visitor this week?
Sundu asked.
Luna raised her talon, and they all
turned to walk into the forest that
sundew was growing with her leaf speak.
Maybe we can see if any of our friends
are asleep in the distant kingdoms and
want to say hi.
Pineapple and Jambu promised to visit
soon, Luna said.
And then we'll go there, Sortell said.
And then they'll come here, and then
we'll go there, and then there will be
dragons in all directions.
Dragons and humans, Cricket offered
nudging Axolotl's foot affectionately.
Sure, Swordtail agreed.
Weird, but mostly dragons.
Dragons and humans, living in peace after
all this time.
Luna said.
Tilting her head back to watch the
sunlight through the leaves.
I can't wait to see what that future is
like.
A guide to the dragons of Pentala.
Hive wings.
Description.
Red, yellow, and or orange, but always
mixed with some black scales, 4 wings.
Abilities vary from dragon to dragon.
Examples include deadly stingers that can
extend from their wrists to stab their
enemies.
Venom in their teeth or claws, a
paralyzing toxin that can immobilize
their prey.
Or boiling acid, sprayed from a stinger
on their tails.
Queen, Queen Wasp.
Silk wings, description.
Silkwing dragonettes are born wingless
but go through a metamorphosis at age 6
when they develop 4 huge wings and silk
spinning abilities, as beautiful and
gentle as butterflies, with scales in any
color under the sun, except black.
Abilities, can spin silk from glands on
their wrists to create webs or other
woven articles, can detect vibrations
with their antennae to assess threats.
Queen, wasp.
The last silkwing queen, before the tree
wars, was Queen Monarch.
Leaf Wings.
Description, wiped out during the tree
wars with the hive wings, but while they
lived, this tribe had green and brown
scales and wings shaped like leaves
abilities, could absorb energy from
sunlight, and were accomplished
gardeners.
Some were rumored to have unusual control
over plants.
Queen.
Last known queen of the leaf wings was
Queen Sequoia, about 50 years ago, at the
time of the tree wars.
This is Shannon McManus.
We hope that you have enjoyed this
production of Wings of Fire, Book 15, The
Flames of Hope, by 2ET Sutherland.
This audiobook was produced by Dion Audio
and directed by Jack Heidelman.
Executive producer Melanie Gagney.
Print edition published by Scholastic
Press, an imprint of scholastic Inc.
Text Copyright 2022, by 2ET Sutherland.
Production Copyright, 2022, by Scholastic
Inc.
All rights reserved.